CALLING FOR MEMBERS THIS IS THE
LOCAL GOVERNMENT COMMITTEE IN
ROOM FOUR FOUR FOUR SERGEANTS
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
FOR MORE WAIT BRIEFLY TO HAVE
THEM.
ARRIVE
.
THAT'S FOR YOU [inaudible]
YEAH.
IF YOU DON'T LOSE.
YOUR LIFE TO SURVIVE.
OKAY.
WELCOME TO THE LAST LOCAL
GOVERNMENT HEARING.
ON SENATE BILLS JUST A FEW
HOUSEKEEPING ITEMS TO GO OVER
BEFORE WE START.
THE SPEAKER HAS APPOINTED
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LORENA GONZALEZ
TO REPLACE ASSEMBLY MEMBER THREE
OF US FOR TODAY'S HEARING.
WE HAVE TEN ITEMS ON THE AGENDA
TODAY WE HAVE ONE ITEM PROPOSED
FOR CONSENT WHICH IS ITEM NUMBER
TEN SB.
SEVEN EIGHTY THE COMMITTEE ON
GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE.
IN THE INTEREST OF TIME ON THIS
LINK THE LINK THE AGENDA WE
ASKED FOR TWO MAIN WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT AND TWO MEN WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. FOR EACH BILL. FOR
ANY WITNESSES BEYOND THAT PLEASE
STATE YOUR NAME YOUR
ORGANIZATION AND POSITION ON THE
BILL THAT'S IT -- WILL ENTERTAIN
A MOTION ONE THING THAT WE GET A
QUORUM AND WE'LL GO AHEAD AND
START AS A SUB COMMITTEE.
WE'LL BEGIN TODAY WITH OUR FIRST
BILL WE HAVE SIGNED IN ORDER
WILL BEGIN WITH THE FIRST BILL
TODAY.
IS ITEM NUMBER SIX SB THREE
THREE ZERO SENATOR SKINNER
WELCOME
.
JUST BROKE MY KNEE IN THE PIT.
THAT THE YOUR FUNNY BONE IT'S
OKAY.
WRECKED MY BEAUTIFUL OPENING TO
THANK [inaudible]
MADAM CHAIR.
AND MEMBERS BUT WE WILL COMPOSE
OURSELVES IN BEGIN.
THANK YOU.
FOR ALLOWING ME TO PRESENT.
SB.
THREE THIRTY AND I THINK WE ALL
AGREE THAT HOUSING IS A HUMAN
RIGHT AND UNFORTUNATELY.
IN CALIFORNIA IT'S INCREASINGLY
A RIGHT THAT.
MANY MANY PEOPLE CAN'T AFFORD
MANY PEOPLE OF LOST AND I WE
HAVE A SERIES HOUSING CRISIS --
I THINK YOU ALL KNOW THE COST.
OF HOUSING IN CALIFORNIA AND HOW
IT EXCEEDS BASICALLY ALMOST
EVERYWHERE IN THE ENTIRE COUNTRY.
BUT UNFORTUNATELY PART OF THE
REASON THAT OUR COSTS ARE SO
HIGH IS BECAUSE WE HAVE NOT
PROVIDED THE NUMBER OF UNITS
THAT WE NEED FOR OUR POPULATION.
WE ARE THE SECOND LOWEST IN THE
STATE.
OF NUMBER OF HOUSING UNITS PER
PERSON OF ANYWHERE IN THE US.
FORTY NINE THEN HOUSING UNITS
PER CAPITA.
SCARCITY INCREASES COST.
AND THAT COST THEN.
HAS CAUSED HOMELESSNESS
ADDITIONALLY.
SO WE KNOW WE'RE IN A CRISIS IN
MY BILL.
WAS DESIGNED REALLY TO ADDRESS
THAT CRISIS AND WHILE I SAY THAT
IT WAS TO ADDRESS THAT CRISIS IT
IS ALSO A MODEST BILL.
BECAUSE IT STARTS FROM THE
PREMISE THAT.
WHILE I PERSONALLY WOULD LIKE TO
SEE INCREASED DENSITY IN VARIOUS
PLACES.
IT STARTS FROM THE PREMISE THAT.
ARE EXISTING ZONING RULES IN OUR
IN LOCAL GOVERNMENTS UP AND DOWN
THE STATE.
HAVE ALREADY PROVIDED FOR
CONCEPTUALLY.
THE NUMBER OF HOUSING UNITS WE
NEED.
NOW YOU KNOW SOMEONE COULD
QUIBBLE LITTLE BUT BASICALLY.
ON THE BOOKS.
ARE CONCEPTUALLY A GREAT NUMBER
OF HOUSING UNITS THEY HAVEN'T
BEEN BUILT YET.
SO WHAT IS MY BILL DO IT
RESPECTS THE EXISTING LOCAL
ZONING BUT IT SAYS LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS JOIN WITH US.
AND GIVE THE HOUSING APPLICANTS
SOME CERTAINTY.
AND PROCESS THEIR PERMIT IN A
SPECIFIC TIME.
AND DON'T CHANGE THE RULES WHEN
YOU'RE IN THE MIDST OF
PROCESSING THAT PERMIT.
AND THAT WAY WE COULD ACTUALIZED.
THE HOUSING THAT WE'VE ALREADY
CONCEPTUALLY APPROVED ON THE
BOOKS SO THAT'S REALLY THE VERY
CORE OF THIS BILL.
IT'S BEEN MYTHOLOGIZED.
YES.
VERY SENT TO TEASE HAVE TRIED TO
CHARACTERIZE IT IS SOMETHING IT
IS NOT.
IT IS REALLY ABOUT JUST GIVING
CERTAINTY TO THOSE PROJECTS
WHICH YOU'VE ALREADY
CONCEPTUALLY SETTER OKAY SO THAT
WHEN AN APPLICANT COMES IN.
WITH SOMETHING THAT MEETS YOUR
RULES.
MEET YOUR EXISTING DESIGN REVIEW
STANDARDS MEETS EVERYTHING YOU
WOULD -- ASKED.
THAT THEN YOU DON'T CHANGE THE
RULES MIDSTREAM.
YOU DON'T INCREASE THEIR FEES
WHILE THAT APPLICANT IS IN
PROCESS AND THAT'S ANOTHER THING
ON THE FEES PARK.
LOT OF PEOPLE ARE SO FEARFUL
HORSE FOR TO COVER ALL THE FEES
NO.
JUST FREEZES THE FEES FOR THAT
APPLICATION WHILE THAT
APPLICANTS PERMIT IS BEING
PROCESSED.
AND THE BILL WAS BASED ON WHAT
SANTA ROSA DID AFTER THE COFFEE
FIRE.
IN SANTA ROSA LOST HOW MANY
UNITS I DON'T REMEMBER IT CALLED
EXACT NUMBER BUT WAS OVER
THOUSAND UNITS I THINK WAS IN
THE ORDER OF IT WAS MORE AND
THREE THOUSAND UNITS.
AND THEY KNEW THAT THE NEEDED TO
HELP PEOPLE GET BACK INTO THEIR
HOMES.
SO THEY LOOKED AT THEIR OWN
PERMIT PROCESS.
AND THEY LOOKED AT HOW TO
STREAMLINE IT AND HOW TO HELP
PEOPLE.
GET BACK WITH WHAT THEY HAD
ALREADY AGREED.
TO SO THAT'S WHAT THE BILL'S
REALLY ORIENTED.
TO OF OBVIOUSLY I CAN ADDRESS
ANY QUESTIONS OR CONCERNS I
REALLY APPRECIATED THE WORK WITH
YOUR CONSULTANT HAS BEEN VERY
VERY HELPFUL.
ALL THE QUESTIONS AND WE IT WAS
GREAT WORK TOGETHER -- BUT NOW I
WOULD ALLOW MY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT TO INTRODUCE THEMSELVES
AND TO SPEAK ON THE BILL.
THANK YOU SENATOR.
GOOD AFTERNOON -- CHAIR MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS
DAVID GARCIA ON THE POLICY
DIRECTOR AT THE TURNER CENTER
FOR HOUSING INNOVATION AT UC
BERKELEY HERE TODAY IN SUPPORT
OF SENATE BILL THREE THIRTY SO
I'M I DON'T THINK I NEED TO
REMIND EVERYONE HERE WE ARE IN
THE STEPS OF A VERY.
SERIOUS AND WORSENING HOUSING
CRISIS HERE IN CALIFORNIA -- SO
I WON'T BELABOR THE POINT BUT
WHAT I WILL SAY IS THAT THE TIME
TO FIND SOLUTIONS TO THIS CRISIS.
THAT THAT TIME WAS YESTERDAY
TODAY WE NEED TO BE.
TALKING ABOUT ACTIONS WE WE CAN
WE CAN UNDERTAKE AND THAT THE
MEASURES PROPOSED IN THIS BILL
ARE BOTH -- MEETING FULL AS WELL
SENSIBLE AND SO I WANT TO TALK A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT.
THE ISSUE OF COST AND HOW THIS
BILL ADDRESSES THAT SPECIFIC
ITEM AS AS OUR WORK AT THE
TURNER CENTER HAS SHOWN.
BUILDING HOUSING A CALIFORNIA IS
INCREDIBLY EXPENSIVE
PARTICULARLY FOR AFFORDABLE
HOUSING WE ACTUALLY HAVE A
REPORT.
THAT WILL BE RELEASED NEXT MONTH
THAT DETAILS THE SPIRALING COST
OF LOCUM HOUSING PROJECTS.
WE ARE SEEING PROJECTS COME IN
AT EIGHT HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS TO MEET SOMETIMES EVEN
NINE HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS
PER UNIT TO BUILD IN THESE.
RESULTS DOVE TAIL WHAT THE
GOVERNMENT ACCOUNTABILITY OFFICE
FOUND LAST YEAR THEIR NATIONWIDE
REPORT SHOWING THAT CALIFORNIA
IS AN EXTREME OUT LIAR IN THE
COST IT TAKES TO BUILD
AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
AND SO THIS IS A VERY IMPORTANT
POINT TO BRING UP BECAUSE AS YOU
ALL KNOW THE STATE HAS COMMITTED.
SIGNIFICANT NEW DOLLARS TO BUILD
NEW FOUR WHEEL HOUSING BUT AS
COSTS CONTINUE TO ESCALATE THESE
DOLLARS ARE GOING TO BECOME LESS
AND LESS EFFECTIVE.
AND SO OUR WORK HAS SHOWN AT
THESE COSTS ARE DRIVEN BY A
VARIETY OF FACTORS BUT CHIEF
AMONG THEM ARE UNCERTAIN TIME
LINES WENT THE REVIEW PROCESS
SEES.
AYE CHANGING IMPACT FEES AND SO
TO THE EXTENT THAT THIS BILL
ACTUALLY PROVIDES LEVEL OF
CERTAINTY FOR BUILDERS OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING TO BE ABLE TO
MEET THEIR CRITICAL DEADLINES TO
ALIGN WITH STATE LET PROGRAMS --
THAT THAT'S GOING TO DO A LOTS
TO HELP ADDRESS THE ISSUE OF
COST WHEN IT COMES TO BUILDING
THE UNITS THAT WE ALL AGREE ON
WE NEED TO BE BUILDING AS A
STATE SO -- I'LL KEEP MY
COMMENTS BRIEF I'LL LEAVE IT AT
THAT I WANT TO THANK THE SENATOR
FOR HER LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE
I THINK THE COMMITTEE FOR THE
CONVERSATION AND THE COURAGE AND
I VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU IN ONE MORE IN SUPPORT
AND WILL DO THE ME TO USE.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR ARGUE ARE
CURRY MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
MY NAME IS PEDRO GOLF I WHEN I'M
WITH THE NONPROFIT HOUSING
ASSOCIATION OF NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA.
WE ARE A LONG STANDING
AFFORDABLE HOUSING ADVOCACY
ORGANIZATION WITH THAT WORKS IN
ALL NINE BAY AREA COUNTIES IN
OUR MISSION IS. TO FOR BAY AREA
WHERE EVERYONE HAS A STABLE AND
AFFORDABLE PLACE TO CALL HOME
AND WE'RE HERE IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF SB.
THREE THIRTY BECAUSE AS THE
SENATOR SAID AND AND DAVID ADDED --
PEOPLE CREATE MORE CERTAINTY AND
TRANSPARENCY IN THE APPROVAL
PROCESS OF CAN OF BUILDING MORE
HOMES BUT SPECIFICALLY
AFFORDABLE HOMES.
ARE -- OUR MEMBERS -- LIKE OTHER
DEVELOPERS HAVE ALSO BEEN IN
SITUATIONS WHERE.
ONCE THE DEVELOPMENT HAS ONCE AN
APPLICATION HAS BEEN TURNED IN
THE RULES HAVE CHANGED MIDSTREAM
ADDING TO COST -- CAUSING FOR
SIGNIFICANT DELAYS BECAUSE OF
PORTABLE HOUSING DEVELOPERS HAVE
TO BUILD WITH SUBSIDIES SO THEY
HAVE TO GO OUT AND FIND NEW
SOURCES.
AND SO NOT ONLY DOES THAT THE
LATE THE PROJECT COST THE PUBLIC
MORE MONEY BUT IT THE LADIES.
BE DELIVERY OF CRITICALLY NEEDED
HOMES AFFORDABLE TO LOW INCOME
CALIFORNIANS.
AND SO -- WITH THE CERTAINTY AND
TRANSPARENCY THAT THIS BILL WILL
PROVIDE WE WE WOULD REALLY WANT
TO ENCOURAGE THE COMMITTEE TO
TAKE AN AYE VOTE FOR BE BELIEVE
THAT THIS WILL MAKE IT EASIER
FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS HAVE A SAFE
AND AFFORDABLE PLACE TO CALL.
THANK YOU OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
MADAM CHAIRMAN MICHAEL GETTING
CB I A ON BEHALF OF ALL THE B.
I. A.'S IN THE STATE WE URGE
YOUR SUPPORT OF THE BILL THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS ALEX
TORE IS ONLYHALF OF UP FOR
GROWTH ACTION COALITION IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
JAMIE MINOR ON BEHALF OF BRIDGE
HOUSING AS WELL AS SALES AS WELL
AS SALES FORCE IN SUPPORT THANKS.
SYLVIA OFFERING BEHALF OF
FACEBOOK IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
TODAY THE BAY AREA HOUSING
ADVOCACY COALITION IN SUPPORT.
GEN RESPECT ABOUT THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF REALTORS IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU KEITH DONE ON BEHALF
THE CALIFORNIA APARTMENT
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
FOLLOWING TâM FROM SAN
FRANCISCO IN THE IN SUPPORT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ZACKS SEVEN FROM URBAN
ENVIRONMENTALISTS NICE SUPPORT
BECAUSE HOUSING POLICY IS
CLIMATE POLICY THANK YOU.
NOR IN THE NEAR WITH ON BEHALF
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY BUILDERS
AND SUPPORT THANK YOU.
HANNAH FAILING AND ON BEHALF OF
THE TWO HUNDRED AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
KEEP MOTOR FOR MISSION HIM BEING
IN SUPPORT.
MARILYN J. CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF HOUSING
AUTHORITIES IN CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION LOCAL HOUSING
FINANCE AGENCIES IN SUPPORT.
DAVE ROBERTS SAID.
CALIFORNIA B. AND A REALTOR IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
SON YOU TRAVIS CALIFORNIA
RENTERS LEGAL ADVOCACY AND
EDUCATION FUND IN SUPPORT.
LARA FOOT UMB ACTION FOR THE
FUTURE OF CALIFORNIA IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
ROBERT APODACA CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY BUILDERS AND SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
BARBARA SHOW WITH CALIFORNIA ME
AND HOW SACRAMENTO IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
BEN LEVY FROM SAM'S AGAIN BE IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
BEEN LOOSELY WESTERN SO VOICE WE
WELCOME NEW NEIGHBORS AND
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS JAMES CHIANG ON
FROM BERKELEY CALIFORNIA I AM AN
ELECTED MEMBER OF THE BURKE THE
RENT STABILIZATION BAR AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
HI EBONY PEARL ON BEHALF OF
EQUALITY CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT.
HI FOR MANY ON BEHALF A HABITAT
FOR MANY THE CALIFORNIA SB AT
HOME TMZ PARTNER SOUND HELP
PROPERTIES IN CALIFORNIA IN THE
IN SUPPORT GREAT THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON OUT OF WRIGLEY ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER
OF COMMERCE IN SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON CAMERA DIMITRI
WITH TECHNO AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
MAX PERRY THE CITY OF SAN CARLOS
IN SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON TO GET A CREDIT
WITH THE NATURAL RESOURCES
DEFENSE COUNCIL IN SUPPORT.
ON A LAWLER ON BEHALF OF THE
WESTERN SAMA POVERTY AND THE
CALIFORNIA RURAL LEGAL
ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION IN SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADISON RALLY ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA COUNCIL
FOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND
SILICON VALLEY COMMUNITY
FOUNDATION BOTH IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
RUN HIM ONE ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA BE IN SUPPORT.
ANSEL WONDER WITH HOUSE
SACRAMENTO WE'RE HERE IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
DILLON CASEY WITH EAST BAY FOR
EVERYONE HERE IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU [inaudible]
THIS POOR.
SELENA PARK CALIFORNIA STATE AND
DOUBLE ACP AND SUPPORT THANK YOU.
ST GEORGE OF THE AMERICAN
PLANNING ASSOCIATION WERE
ACTUALLY NEUTRAL AS AMENDED AND
WE'RE GONNA CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH THE AUTHOR AND STAFF ON
THIS THANK YOU THANK YOU.
A SEVENTY AYE REPRESENTING
WORKING PARTNERSHIPS IN SANTA
CLARA COUNTY IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
MARILYN HELL ON BEHALF OF SAYS
GO HOUSING ACTION COALITION AND
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
HELLO COMMITTEE MEMBER SEAN
BEGAN WITH THE BAY AREA COUNCIL
IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
ARE THERE ANY OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
OKAY BEFORE YOU MOVE ON WE'RE
GOING TO ESTABLISH WE HAVE
RECORDS WE'RE GONNA TAKE ROLE.
AND THE SECRETARY AGUIAR-CURRY
HERE AGUIAR-CURRY HERE LACKEY
HERE LACKEY HERE BLOOM.
BLOOM HERE BOERNER HORVATH.
BOERNER HORVATH HERE RAMOS
GONZALEZ ROBERT RIVAS ROBERT
RIVAS HERE VOEPEL [inaudible]
VOEPEL HERE.
THANK YOU -- WILL GO ON TO
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
WE HAVE TWO WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION THEN THE ME TO USE
FOLLOWING
.
GOOD AFTERNOON WELCOME.
GOOD AFTERNOON THANK YOU
CHAIRMAN -- MY NAME IS PETER
PAPADOPOULOS AND I AM.
WITH THE MISSION ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT AGENCY IN SAN
FRANCISCO.
AND WE SERVE -- SEVEN THOUSAND
FOUR HUNDRED CLIENTS A YEAR
PREDOMINANTLY LOW INCOME LATINO
FAMILIES IN THE AREAS OF
COMMUNITY ASSET BUILDING SOCIAL
SERVICES AND THEN WE ALSO ARE.
IN AFFORDABLE HOUSING BILLS THAT
WE BUILD EXTREMELY LOW INCOME
VERY LOW INCOME MIDDLE INCOME
HOUSING -- IN THAT CONTEXT I
THINK WE FELT IT WAS IMPORTANT.
TO RAISE OUR OVER ARCHING
CONCERNS WHICH COULD BE --
DESCRIBE MOST SIMPLY AS I THINK
SOCIAL JUSTICE CONCERNS WITH
THIS BILL ESSENTIALLY ARE
POTENTIALLY UNINTENDED IMPACTS
FROM THE BILL WHICH WE WOULD.
BE HAPPY TO CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH THE AUTHOR ON THESE
CONCERNS FOR OUR COMMUNITY.
I THINK THAT -- OBVIOUSLY WE'RE
LOOKING FOR THINGS THAT PROMOTE.
VERY MUCH AN EQUITY FIRST LANDS
THAT IS WANTING TO MAKE SURE
THAT AS WE SPEED UP THINGS LIKE
OUR HOUSING PRODUCTION DURING
THIS CRISIS WHICH WE KNOW WE
NEED TO DO WE ARE VERY MUCH --
FOR EQUITABLE DEVELOPMENT AND WE
ARE BUILDERS OURSELVES SO WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
INCLUDE OUR MOST VULNERABLE
COMMUNITY MEMBERS.
MAKING SURE THAT THEY ARE ARE
PROSPEROUS AND STABILIZED THE
DURING THIS TIME OUR
NEIGHBORHOOD ALONE HAS ALREADY
LOST EIGHT THOUSAND LATINO
COMMUNITY MEMBERS RECENTLY.
AND WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
ARE FINDING.
OUR WAY TO TO MAKE SURE THAT
CULTURAL ECO SYSTEMS ARE
PROTECTED AND SOMETIMES THAT IS
A LITTLE MORE SUBTLE.
AND IT ALLOWS THE VOICE OF THE
COMMUNITY TO BE HEARD AND IT
ALLOWS SOME DISCRETION ON BEHALF
OF OUR LOCAL LAND USE BOARDS.
WORKING TOGETHER WITH THE
ELEMENT TEAMS TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE ARE STABILIZING OUR COMMUNITY
FIRST AND FOREMOST -- ALREADY WE
SEE THAT THIS BILL FROM OUR
UNDERSTANDING FOR EXAMPLE WOULD
DISRUPT.
OUR LATINO CULTURAL DISTRICT
STILL WORKING AFTER HUNDREDS OF
HOURS BETWEEN CITY AND COMMUNITY
TO ESTABLISH ITS DESIGN
GUIDELINES SOME OF THOSE DESIGN
GUIDELINES WE UNDERSTAND WOULD
BE INVALIDATED.
BY THIS PROPOSAL SIMILARLY WE
UNDERSTAND OUT OF LOS ANGELES
BECAUSE OF THE JANUARY FIRST
RETROACTIVE TIMELINE THAT A
COMMUNITY AREA PLAN THEIR
SIMILARLY WOULD ALSO BE.
DISRUPTED BY THIS PROCESS -- TO
TO NAME A COUPLE MORE PARTICULAR
CONCERNS OF PASSAGES.
WE CAN CURVE WITH THE FLAGGING
THAT WAS DONE IN THE SENATE
GOVERNANCE COMMITTEE.
REGARDING THE POTENTIAL ISSUE OF
A SORT OF SPOT ZONING THAT SEEMS
TO BE ALLOWED BY LANGUAGE THAT
WE DETAILED IN OUR LETTER --
THAT SEEMS TO SAY YOU CAN DEFER
TO A GENERAL PLAN INSTEAD OF A
SPECIFIC ZONING IF YOU FEEL
SOMEHOW THAT ZONING IS NOT QUITE.
IN CONCORDANCE WITH THE
SURROUNDING TERRITORY BUT THAT
SOMETIMES CAN BE DONE FOR
REASONS OF CULTURAL ECO SYSTEM.
AS WE MENTIONED LIMITING THE
NUMBER OF HEARINGS TO A TOTAL OF
FIVE WE THINK IS.
A WAY OF OF LIMITING ARE
VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES VOICES
THAT'S ALREADY BEING OVERRUN BY
LARGE FORCES AND THIS IS ONE WAY
THAT WE HAVE TO ENGAGE WITH OF
ELEMENT.
I MAKE SURE OUR COMMUNITY IS
ACTIVELY ENGAGED IN THEIR FUTURE
WE'D LIKE TO SEE THAT NUMBER
EXPANDED OR OVER ELIMINATED OR
SOMETHING TO THE EFFECT THAT WE
MAKE SURE WE STILL HAVE APPEALS
AS A POSSIBILITY RIGHT NOW YOU
COULD VERY WELL GO THROUGH A
PROCESS AS WE KNOW AND END.
UP WITH NO APPEALS WERE THERE TO
BE SOME ISSUES.
WE UNDERSTAND THERE'S NEW
DEMOLITION LANGUAGE TODAY WE'D
LIKE TO REVIEW THAT.
OF PARTICULAR CONCERN WAS SQUARE
FOOTAGE LOSS AND ALSO THE
POTENTIAL FOR STATE DENSITY
BONUS INTERACTING WITH THIS AS
AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
AND FINALLY WE DO HAVE A CONCERN
THAT THERE COULD BE SOME ISSUE
WITH THIS.
ASSESSING OF FEES AND IMPACT
FEES AT THE TIME OF THE PRE OP
WHERE THINGS ARE NOT CERTAIN YET
AND WE'RE NOT SURE HOW THAT
COULD COULD WORK SO WE'D LIKE TO
LOOK INTO THAT WITH THE AUTHOR
OF POSSIBLE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS RAND MARTIN
HERE ON BEHALF OF THE AIDS
HEALTHCARE FOUNDATION FOR THOSE
THAT DON'T KNOW HF IS NOT ONLY
THE LARGEST PROVIDER OF CARE AND
TREATMENT OF PEOPLE WITH HIV IN
THE WORLD.
BUT IT ALSO HAS A GROWING PRETTY
SUBSTANTIAL AND GROWING HOUSING
PROGRAM IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY WE
ARE ALSO DEVELOPER OF HOUSING
FOR LOW INCOME PEOPLE -- WE
REALLY APPRECIATE THE WORK THAT
THE AUTHOR HAS DONE ON THIS BILL --
A LOT OF PROGRESS HAS BEEN MADE --
AND I REALLY DO APPRECIATE THAT
AND WE DO CONTINUE TO HAVE A
COUPLE OF ISSUES THAT WE STILL
LIKE TO WORK OUT WITH HER AS THE
BILL.
NOW MOVES FORWARD. ONE IS AS
MOST PAPADOPOULOS'S HAS
INDICATED HAVE HAS TO DO WITH
THE OPERATIVE DATE RELATIVE TO
GENERAL PLANS ON THAT DATE IS
STILL JANUARY FIRST OF TWENTY
EIGHTEEN WE KNOW IT HAS LIMITED
IMPACT BUT IT DOES IMPACT IN LOS
ANGELES IN PARTICULAR.
A COMMUNITY PLAN THAT WAS
DEVELOPED OVER THE LAST ELEVEN
YEARS I'M WITH LEADERS FROM THE
SOUTH LA COMMUNITY -- THAT
DIDN'T GO INTO EFFECT UNTIL
AFTER JANUARY FIRST OF TWENTY
EIGHTEEN WE'RE VERY CONCERNED
ABOUT WHETHER THAT'S GOING TO
HAVE IT WHETHER THIS BILL IS
GOING TO HAVE AN IMPACT ON THE
ABILITY OF THAT.
OF THAT TO A PLAN TO BE FULLY
REALIZED THE WAY PEOPLE
ANTICIPATED IT -- WE WELCOME THE
LANGUAGE THAT WAS ADDED TO THE
BILL RELATIVE TO DEMOLITION AND
WE THINK OVERALL IT'S A IT'S A
GOOD SECTION AND GOOD THAT
THEY'VE ADDED IT --
UNFORTUNATELY THERE COUPLE
THINGS IN THERE THAT WOULD STILL
LIKE TO SEE FIXED -- I KNOW THIS
IS RECENT LANGUAGE AND WE'RE
JUST NOW GETTING A CHANCE TO
RESPOND TO IT -- BUT WE ARE VERY
CONCERNED ABOUT -- UNDER
POTENTIALLY UNDERMINING THAT'S
NOT RIGHT THE THE RIGHT TERM BUT
IT IMPEDING THE ABILITY OF THE
DENSITY BONUS LAW TO WORK THE
WAY IT WAS INTENDED -- TO SO WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT IT'S
CLEAR THAT -- THAT USING THE
PROVISIONS OF THIS BILL DOES NOT
GET THE DEVELOPER ADDITIONAL
DENSITY BONUS POINTS -- AS IT
WERE -- AND NUMBER -- TWO THEY
TALK ABOUT HAVING THE SAME
NUMBER OF BEDROOMS AS BEING THE
EQUIVALENTS IN TERMS OF THE SIZE
OF THE OF THE UNIT.
SAME NUMBER OF BEDROOMS IN LOS
ANGELES IN PARTICULAR IS NOT
GREAT FOR FAMILIES WHO ARE
LIVING IN -- IN A TIGHT SPACES
MULTIPLE FAMILIES IN MANY CASES.
YOU HAVE MANY PEOPLE LIVING IN
THE SAME NUMBER OF BEDROOMS BUT
WITH A MUCH SMALLER SQUARE
FOOTAGE YOU HAVE MUCH MORE
UNACCEPTABLE PLACE -- FOR FOR
PEOPLE TO LIVE I'M SORRY BE
CONCERNED ABOUT -- ABOUT FIXING
THAT -- BOTH THOSE ARE THE TWO
REMAINING ISSUES AT THIS POINT
THAT WE HAVE -- WITH THE BILL I
MEAN LOOK FORWARD -- TO WORKING
WITH THE AUTHOR FURTHER -- IF
THIS BILL MOVES FOR THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OTHERS IN
OPPOSITION.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS A SMILEY CALIFORNIA
CITIES AND WE DO HAVE AN
OPPOSING THIS AMENDED IN A
POSITION ON THIS BILL THE BILL
HAS COME A LONG WAY WE CERTAINLY
KNOWLEDGE THE EFFORTS.
OF THE AUTHOR OUR MAIN CONCERN
IS REALLY THE PROJECT SPECIFIC
FEES -- THE WAY THE BILL
OPERATES NOW WE WOULD BE
PROHIBITED FROM CHARGING THOSE
BECAUSE IT FREES UP BEFORE WE
KNOW WHAT THEY POSSIBLY COULD BE.
A MYTH THAT ISSUE GETS RESOLVED
I THINK WE CAN GO TO NEUTRAL
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU JUST AS A REMINDER
YOUR NAME AND OKAY SILLY ON
BEHALF OF THE CITIES OF BOWMAN
CUPERTINO LAFAYETTE IN
OPPOSITION.
MANAGER MEMBERS ENTRY ENTRY ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY OF BEVERLY
HILLS AND THE CITY CAN COUNTY
ASSOCIATION OF GOVERNMENTS OF
SAN MATEO COUNTY IN OPPOSITION
THANK YOU.
CHRISLEY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES SUPPOSE UNLESS A MINUTE.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON KIANA VALENTINE
ON BEHALF OF THE URBAN COUNTIES
OF CALIFORNIA OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED AS WELL THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
MANAGER DAVID JONES ABOUT HALF
THE CITIES OF BURBANK GLENDALE --
THE MARIN COUNTY COUNCIL OF
MAYORS AND COUNCIL MEMBERS CITY
OF MARIETTA PASADENA SAN MARCOS
SINCE ONE OF EACH AND FOR THE
RECORD I REPRESENT SAN MARCUS IS
I MEAN SANTA ROSA DOES NOT
OPPOSE IT WAS FIVE THOUSAND
HOUSING UNITS WERE LOST IN THAT
FIRE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOVERNOR MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE BALKANS OFFICER
TODAY ON BEHALF THE CITIES OF
RANCHO CUCAMONGA LAW MARADA
THOUSAND OAKS CAM MARIA AND
TORRANCE IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
CAROLING ON OF THE SOLANO COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS IN
OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON HEIDI FELT ON ON
BEHALF OF A NEWLY FORMED
STATEWIDE ALLIANCE CALLED A
BETTER WAY FORWARD TO HOUSE
CALIFORNIA.
IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
RECALL REPRESENTING TWO GROUPS
OF THE CULTURAL ACTION NETWORK --
WHICH WORKS IN THE MISSION
DISTRICT -- BELIEVES THAT THE
LATEST ADDITIONS TO THE BILL --
CREATE ESSENTIALLY A DEMOLITION
DERBY.
THEY ARE NOT GOOD BUT IT NEEDS
TO BE EXAMINED THANK YOU.
ARE THERE ANY OTHERS IN
OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE ARE THERE ANY
QUESTIONS OF THE COMMITTEE.
VITAL SOURCE OF SORRY I'M YES I
WANNA THINK THE AUTHOR I KNOW WE
ARE IN A HOUSING CRISIS AND I
THINK THIS POINT OF PART OF THE
STATE THAT REMAINS UNAFFECTED.
YOU'VE TAKEN A NUMBER OF
AMENDMENTS AND I'M SORRY I
MISSED YOUR OPENING STATEMENT
COULD YOU RUN THROUGH THE
AMENDMENTS THAT YOU'VE TAKEN --
OVER ALL THE COMMITTEES I THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT FOR THE PUBLIC TO
HEAR I APPRECIATE THAT IT'S
IMPORTANT BUT THIS AND I AND I
DON'T MEAN TO BE CAVALIER AT ALL
BUT THIS BILL.
IN AND I'M NOT SAYING THIS IN
ANY WAY TO DIMINISH THE STILL
VERY BENEFICIAL ASPECTS OF THIS
BILL BUT THIS BILL IS A SHADOW
OF ITS FORMER SELF.
I WOULD BE -- VERY PLEASED TO BE
PRESENTING TO YOU THE BILL I
ORIGINALLY INTRODUCED AND I
WOULD STAND STILL BY THE BILL I
ORIGINALLY INTRODUCED.
BUT I ALSO APPRECIATE THAT THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS IS SUCH THAT
WE NEED TO BE RESPONSIVE
LEGITIMATELY RESPONSIVE TO
CONCERNS THAT ARE RAISED SO FOR
EXAMPLE.
THE LIMITATIONS ON PARKING WHICH
WE'VE HEARD SOME OF THE
OBJECTION NOT ALL TO THE BILL IS
SOME IS THE FEAR.
ABOUT THE IMPACT ON AFFORDABLE
HOUSING.
AND BURDEN IN NOTE THAT WE'VE
HEARD PRIMARILY -- THAT
AFFORDABLE HOUSING DEVELOPERS
AND THE WESTERN CENTER ON LAW
AND POVERTY ARE IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL BUT LET ME THE POINT
I'M TRYING TO MAKE IS THAT.
WHY A PAD PARKING IN THERE WHY I
HAD THE REMOVAL?
OF THE MINIMUM REQUIRED PARKING
UNITS IN THE ORIGINAL BILL.
IS BECAUSE PARKING ADDS COST.
AND I DON'T WANT TO ADD COST WE
ARE IN A HOUSING AFFORDABILITY
AND A HOUSING SUPPLY CRISIS WE
HAVE THE HIGHEST COST OF
CONSTRUCTION OF ANYWHERE IN THE
COUNTRY.
A PARKING UNIT DEPENDING ON THE
PROJECT CAN BE MINIMAL FIFTY
THOUSAND UPWARDS TO TWO HUNDRED
FIFTY THOUSAND JUST FOR A
PARKING SPOT.
SO I WAS TRYING TO BRING DOWN
COSTS BUT THERE WAS SO MUCH
OBJECTION I COMPLETELY
ELIMINATED.
DE ANY REFERENCE TO ANYTHING TO
DO WITH PARKING SO THAT'S GONE.
THERE WAS ALSO CONCERN THAT THE
BILL.
AFFECTED COASTAL HEIGHT LIMITS
SO I PUT IN THE BILL EXPLICITLY
THAT THE BILL IN NO WAY CAN
IMPACT INTERFERE WITH OR IMPACT
OR EFFECT COASTAL HEIGHT LIMIT
SO THAT IS EXPLICIT NOW IN THE
BILL.
THERE WAS ALSO CONCERN THAT THE
WOULD -- THAT I ORIGINALLY FROZE
FEES BECAUSE AND WHAT I DIDN'T
SAY WHEN I OPEN AND I'M
APOLOGIES THIS BILL SUNSETS IN
FIVE YEARS THIS IS JUST FOR FIVE
YEARS.
AND I WAS TRYING TO FREEZE FEES
IN ORDER.
TO GET THE COST DOWN.
BUT THERE WAS.
VERY LEGITIMATE INSUBSTANTIAL
REACTION TO THAT.
SO WE ELIMINATED THAT THE ONLY
PORTION WE RETAINED IS THAT ONCE
CHAU AYE MY HOUSING APPLICANTS
AND THIS COVERS ALL HOUSING IT
COULD BE A SINGLE FOR IT COULD
BE I'M THE OWNER OF A LOT.
I WANT TO PUT IN A SINGLE FAMILY
HOUSE SO I GO TO MY LOCAL PERMIT
COUNTER I SUBMIT MY INITIAL
APPLICATION.
MY CITY OF COURSE CAN THEN
USUALLY ALWAYS THE APPLICATION
IS NOT COMPLETE THEY GO BACK AND
FORTH WITH ME MAYBE THERE SOME
HEARINGS THEN IT MIGHT THERE'S
NO LIMITS ON THE HEARINGS THEN --
THEY ARE DETERMINING WHAT THE
FEES ARE.
ONCE THEY HAVE DEEMED TO MY
APPLICATION COMPLETE THAT IS
WHEN THE FEES FREEZE AND IT ONLY
FREEZES AROUND MY APPLICATION.
NOT ON ANYTHING ELSE SO.
I THINK THAT'S A VERY IMPORTANT
ONE SO I DO APPRECIATE THE
QUESTION BUT I DON'T THINK I CAN
NECESSARILY GO THROUGH ALL THE
OTHER -- ANOTHER.
ONE IT WAS ORIGINALLY FOR TEN
YEARS NOW IT SUNSETS IN.
FIVE ADDITIONALLY.
I HAD IN ORIGINAL BILL.
THE NIGHT IS WHEN I SAY THIS I
KNOW A LOT OF PEOPLE BE LIKE HOW
COULD YOU EVER CONSIDER THIS I
HAD SUSPENDED BECAUSE THE WHOLE
POINT OF THE BILL WAS TO SUSPEND.
SOME OF PUT.
A HOLD ON THE THINGS THAT LIMIT
HOUSING JUST FOR A LIMITED
PERIOD OF TIME SO WE KNOW THAT
SOME OF OUR JURISDICTIONS
THERE'S BEEN VOTER INITIATIVES.
THAT BASICALLY HAVE PREVENTED A
LOCAL GOVERNMENT TO UP SOONER
PREVENT OR MADE A LOCAL
GOVERNMENT HAVE ONLY SO MANY
HOUSING.
SO WIDE SUSPENDED THOSE VOTER
APPROVALS OR THE ABILITY TO PUT
SOMETHING BEFORE THE VOTERS.
BUT OF COURSE AS YOU CAN IMAGINE
THAT WAS HER CAUSED A LOT OF
REACTION SO I GOT RID OF IT.
IT'S NO LONGER THERE -- AND I
ELIMINATED.
I MADE SURE THAT NOTHING IN THE
BILL IMPACTS SEA QUEST.
SO THOSE ARE AMONG THE
AMENDMENTS AND I KNOW THERE ARE
COUNTLESS OTHERS BUT I HOPE IF
THERE'S ANY OTHER ASPECT THAT
WAS OF PARTICULAR CONCERN.
I WILL BE HAPPY TO LOOK THROUGH
IN AN ANSWER THOSE SPECIFICALLY.
YES I'M I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
ALL THE HARD WORK AND AND TAKING
ON THE AMENDMENTS -- I STILL
HAVE SOME CONCERNS THAT WE CAN
TALK ABOUT OFFLINE -- SOMEONE BE
VOTING NO TODAY BUT I HOPE TO
WORK WITH YOU AND MAYBE WE GET
TO THE PLACE WHERE.
I CAN VOTE YES ON THE FLOOR
THANK YOU.
THE OTHER QUESTIONS OF THE
COMMITTEE.
I DO HAVE A MOTION.
WHATEVER MOTION BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER RIVAS SECOND BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER READ OR ALMOST --
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE MR
BETTER YES I WAS HIS NAME SORRY
SORRY TO GET MY HAND UP BOOK
QUICKLY ENOUGH BUT THAT THIS IS
A A VERY QUICK QUESTION I THINK
THE AUTHOR KNOWS THAT -- AT
LEAST ONE OF MY STE WELL COUPLE
MY CITIES -- HAVE ISSUES BUT ONE
OF THOSE CITIES IN PARTICULAR IS
A CITY THAT PRODUCES A LOT OF
HOUSING -- WE'VE TALKED ABOUT --
YOU'RE CONTINUING TO CONVERSE
WITH THEM TO SEE IF BY SOME OF
THEIR ISSUES CAN BE WORKED OUT I
JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
THAT'S ON THE RECORD.
YES ABSOLUTELY THE APPRECIATE
THAT YES THERE ARE -- AN ARM.
THERE WERE A COUPLE OF THEM THAT
WERE TIME SEARCH TECHNICAL IN
NATURE AND I THINK THOSE ARE THE
TYPE OF AMENDMENTS.
AS WE'VE DONE SOME CLARIFYING IN
TECHNICAL THAT DON'T CHANGE THE
SUBSTANCE OF THE BILL BUT HELP
TO ADDRESS SOME VERY SPECIFIC
CONCERNS THAT.
THE CITY THAT TERM.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BLOOM RACING SO
ABSOLUTELY WE AND ON THE BILL
GOES TO APPROACH NEXT AND WE WE
KNOW THAT THE YOUR CONSULTANT
YOUR LOCAL GOVERNMENT CONSULTANT
WILL WORK WITH US. TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE IF THAT IN DOING SO WE
DON'T UP AND ANYTHING ELSE THAT
THE COMMITTEES ANALYSIS.
WE WOULD NOT WANT TO DO ANYTHING
THAT -- INTERFERED WITH YOU KNOW
THE DIRECTION THE COMMITTEE
WANTS GOING BUT ABSOLUTELY HAVE
THAT COMMITMENT.
AND THEN THE I JUST WANTED TO
ADD THAT.
THERE WAS REFERENCE TO THE
DEMOLITION PART THE DEMOLITION
PART HAS ALWAYS BEEN IN THE BILL
ALL WE DID WAS MOVE THE SECTION.
IT'S ALWAYS BEEN IN THERE AND
WHAT I'M WHAT I'M SAYING IS FROM
DAY ONE THIS BILL WAS DESIGNED
TO PROTECT OF EXISTING
AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
I AM THE AUTHOR NOT ALONE WITH
MANY PEOPLE BUT I'VE BEEN
INVOLVED IN THE WRITING AND
DELIVERY OF BERKELEY'S RENT
CONTROL ORDINANCES SINCE.
NINETEEN SEVENTY SEVEN AND IF
THAT AGES ME.
SO BE IT.
BUT I'VE WORKED ON OUR
BERKELEY'S RENT CONTROL
ORDINANCE IN.
777-981-8480 FIVE OR SIX I CAN'T
REMEMBER BUT ANYWAY AND I HAVE A
STRONG COMMITMENT TO AFFORDABLE
HOUSING I DO NOT WANT.
PEOPLE WHO ARE CURRENTLY
PROTECTED BY RENT CONTROL TO
HAVE THIS BILL DISRUPT THEM I DO
NOT WANT ANYONE IN A PERMANENTLY
AFFORDABLE UNIT TO BE DISRUPTED
AND SO WE BUILT IN VERY STRONG
PROTECTIONS WHICH IS WHY THE
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY FOR EXAMPLE IS IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
AND I'LL TAKE THAT AS YOUR
CLOTHES THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SENATOR -- I
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR BRINGING
THIS BILL FOR IT I KNOW IT WAS
TOUGH I KNOW YOU HAD A LOT OF
AMENDMENTS YOU TOOK NOT ALL THAT
YOU WANTED TO BUT I THINK WE
HAVE A FRAMEWORK RIGHT NOW START
TO MOVE FORWARD.
SO I APPRECIATE THAT.
I DO HAVE A FEW THAT REMAINING
CONCERNS WE'VE ADDRESSED SOME OF
THOSE AND I'M JUST GOING TO GO
THROUGH THOSE -- I HOPE TO
CONTINUE TO WORK ON DESIGN
STANDARDSAND THE EFFECTIVE DATE
OF THE BILL.
WORKING WITH THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT ASSOCIATION ON THE
PROJECT SPECIFIC FEE.
ISSUE THAT THEY'VE BROUGHT UP
AND LASTLY IN WORKING ON
REFINING THE DEFINITION AFFECTED
CITY AND AFFECTED COUNTY --
AGAIN I I APPRECIATE THE HARD
WORK BECAUSE YOU'RE RIGHT
HOUSING CRISIS.
AND WE'VE GOT TO WE'VE GOT TO DO
SOMETHING SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD.
AND WITH THAT I WILL ASK THE
SECRETARY DETECTABLE THE MOTION
IS DO PASS AND REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
AGUIAR-CURRY HI AGUIAR-CURRY I
LACKEY.
LACKEY AYE BLOOM.
BLOOM AYE BURNER HORVATH RAMOS.
RAMOS SIDE GONZALEZ ROBERT RIVAS
ROBERT RIVAS SIDE OF HOUSE.
VOEPEL I BILLS AT SIX ZERO THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AND CAN CONTINUE
TO WORK ON THE BILL THANK YOU
SENATOR.
RIGHT NEXT WE HAVE ITEM NUMBER
THREE SB ONE EIGHTY TWO SENATOR
JACKSON WELCOME.
AND WE'RE GOING TO REMIND
EVERYBODY YOU HAVE TWO PEOPLE --
FOR OPPOSITION AND SUPPORT AND
THEN THE ME TO USE WILL FOLLOW
[inaudible]
ALL RIGHTY.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS THIS IS SB ONE EIGHTY
TWO IT IS A BILL THAT REDUCES
THE RISK OF CATASTROPHIC
WILDFIRES DAMAGE TO CALIFORNIA'S
COMMUNITIES.
BY STRENGTHENING LOCAL PLANNING
REQUIREMENTS FOR DEVELOPMENT
APPROVALS IN VERY HIGH FIRE
HAZARD AREAS AND BY DIRECTING
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO DEVELOP
COMPREHENSIVE RETROFIT.
AND FIRE RESPONSE STRATEGIES FOR
EXISTING COMMUNITIES IN NEED OF
FIRE HARDENING I KNOW THE CHAIR
IS WELL AWARE OF THIS ISSUE AND
IT IS IN AN AREA WHERE THERE'S A
KIND OF EFFORT IS CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT.
THE INCREASING THREATS OF WHILE
FAR TO OUR STATE POSE A
SIGNIFICANT RISK TO HOMES AND
BUSINESSES.
AND WHILE MUCH IS BEING DONE TO
FIGHT THESE FIRES AND TO BETTER
MANAGE OUR FORESTS.
MORE NEEDS TO BE DONE TO HARDEN
OUR COMMUNITIES.
AND MAKE THEM MORE RESISTANT TO
WILDFIRE.
AT A MARCH THIRTEENTH HEARING
FOCUSED ON DEVELOPMENT IN FIRE
PRONE REGIONS THE SENATE
GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE COMMITTEE
IN THE SENATE NATURAL RESOURCES
COMMITTEE.
RECOMMENDED THAT THE LEGISLATURE
CONSIDER ACTION TO BOLSTER LOCAL
PLANNING EFFORTS TO DESIGN MORE
RESILIENT COMMUNITIES.
CONDITION DEVELOPMENT APPROVALS
TO ENSURE THAT STRUCTURES AND
COMMUNITIES ARE ADEQUATELY
PROTECTED FROM FIRE.
OR ENCOURAGE DEVELOPMENT OUT OF
HARM'S WAY.
THAT IS PRECISELY WHAT THIS BILL
DOES.
AMONG OTHER THINGS THE BILL
REQUIRES NEW DEVELOPMENTS IN
VERY HIGH FIRE RISK AREAS TO
MEET SPECIFIED WILDFIRE RISK
REDUCTION STANDARDS.
IT REQUIRES LOCAL JURISDICTIONS
TO VERIFY ON GOING COMPLIANCE
WITH THE FENCIBLE SPACE
VEGETATION MANAGEMENT AND LOCAL
FIRE -- PLAN AND WHILE FIRE
HAZARD MITIGATION PLANS.
THE DIRECTIONAL OCAL GOVERNMENTS
TO DEVELOP A COMPREHENSIVE
RETROFIT STRATEGY FOR STRUCTURES
THAT ARE VULNERABLE TO WILDFIRE.
INCLUDING BUYS ESTABLISHING
GOALS ANTI MINDS FOR COMPLETING
RETROFIT WORK AND IDENTIFYING
FUNDING SOURCES AND FINANCING
STRATEGIES.
IT REQUIRES ALL DEVELOP.
ALL DEVELOPMENT IN VERY HIGH
FIRE RISK AREAS TO MEET
SPECIFIED FIRE RESPONSE.
WATER INFRASTRUCTURE AND
IGNITION REDUCTION STANDARDS.
AND FURTHER DIRECTS THE STATE
FIRE MARSHAL TO ESTABLISH NEW
WILDFIRE RISK REDUCTION
STANDARDS THAT ACCOUNT MORE
PRECISELY FOR CALIFORNIA'S
CLIMATE WEATHER TOPOGRAPHY AND
DEVELOPMENT PATTERNS.
MEMBERS WITH CLIMATE CHANGE
CREATING THE POTENTIAL FOR
LONGER AND MORE SEVERE WILDFIRES
IN CALIFORNIA WHICH MANY IN THIS
ROOM HAVE ALREADY EXPERIENCED.
IT IS NOW I'M MORE IMPORTANT
THAN EVER WE ACT TO STRENGTHEN
OUR PLANNING POLICIES TO REDUCE
THE RISK TO OUR COMMUNITIES.
AND TO FUTURE GENERATIONS.
AND WITH THAT I HAVE WITH ME
TODAY TRACY RYAN FROM THE RURAL
COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES A
CALIFORNIA.
AND LAUREN Và THE VALENCIA YOU
SANCHEZ ON BEHALF OF THE
AMERICAN PLANNING ASSOCIATION
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SENATOR
WELCOME.
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING OR GOOD AFTERNOON --
TRACY RIGHT BROKEN RIBS AS OF
CALIFORNIA -- AS YOUR KEENLY
AWARE OF WE ARE ADDED ANOTHER AT
THE PRECIPICE OF ANOTHER FIRE
SEASON AND EACHONE IS MORE
DESTRUCTIVE THAN THE LAST AND
MOST TIMES NOT ALL BUT MOST
TIMES THOSE ARE HAPPENING IN OUR
WORLD COUNTIES.
AND THAT'S WHY ARE SO YOU'RE SEE
IS A VERY HAPPY AND VERY
POSITIVE TO THE AUTHOR INCLUDING
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS IN FINDING THE
SOLUTION.
WE THINK THAT THIS IS BEEN A
COLLABORATIVE PROCESS THERE BEEN
MANY STATE STAKEHOLDERS INVOLVED
INCLUDING LOCAL GOVERNMENTS --
AND WE HAVE CONTINUED TO WORK
THROUGH ADDRESSING THE ISSUES OF
THE OPPOSITION AND WE LIKE TO
CONTINUE WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR --
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE ADDRESS
THOSE THINGS AND FIND -- FUNDING
FOR THE ADDITIONAL MANDATES THAT
ARE IN HERE FOR LOCAL GOVERNMENT
BUT WE ARE VERY SUPPORTIVE AND
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS LEARNED EVELYN SAY
REPRESENTING THE AMERICAN
PLANNING ASSOCIATION ALSO VERY
PLEASED TO BE HERE IN SUPPORT OF
THIS VERY IMPORTANT BILL -- AS
MY COLLEAGUE SAID WE ARE A UPON
ANOTHER FIRE SEASON HERE IN
CALIFORNIA AND FRANKLY I DON'T
THINK WE'RE EVER OUT OF FIRE
SEASON ANYMORE UNFORTUNATELY IN
CALIFORNIA AND SO WE REALLY DO
BELIEVE.
THAT THE TIMING IS CRITICAL TO
PASS THIS BILL WE BELIEVE THAT A
LOT CAN BE DONE -- ON THE
PLANNING SIDE UP FRONT TO REALLY
START TO PREPARE OUR COMMUNITIES
HARDEN THOSE EXISTING HOMES THAT
ARE IN OUR COMMUNITIES WHERE
THEY ARE NEEDED.
AND ALSO LOOK AT WHAT WE CAN DO
FOR NEW DEVELOPMENT TO MAKE SURE
THAT THERE'S ADEQUATE PROTECTION
IN PLACE SO.
WE DO SUPPORT THE WILDFIRE RISK
REDUCTION STANDARDS IN THE
PLANNING REQUIREMENTS THE BILL I
WE ALSO BELIEVE THAT AS AS WAS
SAID WE NEED TO CERTAINLY FIND
ADEQUATE FUNDING -- TO DO SO SO
WHAT LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING
TO WORK ON THAT ISSUE AND WE
ALSO REALLY BELIEVE THAT AT THE
IF THAT EFFECTIVENESS OF LOCAL
ENFORCEMENT STANDARDS ARE VERY
VERY IMPORTANT -- SO WE REALLY
APPRECIATE ALL THE WORK THAT'S
BEEN DONE ON THIS BILL ENERGY MY
VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OTHERS IN
SUPPORT.
CHRISLEY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANY OTHERS SEEING NONE
ANY AN OPPOSITION.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS SILVIO FOR ABOUT THE
CALIFORNIA BUILDING INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION WE'RE IN ONE OF
THOSE KIND OF AWKWARD POSITIONS
CAUSE WE ARE OPPOSE THE BILL BUT
WE WOULD ACTUALLY ENCOURAGE YOU
TO VOTE THIS BILL OUT AND PASS
IT TODAY -- THERE'S BEEN A VERY
VERY COLLABORATIVE DISCUSSIONS
HAVE GONE WITH THE AUTHOR THE
AUTHOR STAFF AND TREES IN RC RC
HAVE BEEN WONDERFUL AND WE CAN'T
THINK ENOUGH WE THINK WE'RE
GONNA GET THERE AND WE'RE
GETTING CLOSE SO.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AS A BIG
SIGH OF RELIEF FROM THE SENATOR.
OKAY ARE THERE ANY QUESTION ANY
OTHER IN OPPOSITION SEEING NONE
ARE THERE ANY QUESTIONS OF THE
COMMITTEE.
WE HAVE A QUITE COMMITTEE TODAY
I WOULD LIKE SO ENTERTAIN A
MOTION -- AND WHO TOOK THE
SECOND.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ASSEMBLY
MEMBER -- ROSS AND A BORDER
BURNER HARBOR HARBOR
[inaudible]
OKAY -- PROJECT CLOSE.
JUST VERY BRIEFLY WE DO CONTINUE
TO WORK WITH THE BUILDING
INDUSTRY THERE ISN'T THAT WE'RE
GOING TO GET THERE.
THIS IS REALLY AN IMPORTANT
ASPECT WHERE WE TALK ABOUT -- A
THINNING THE FORESTS AND ALL
THOSE OTHER THINGS THAT ARE
OBVIOUS THAT WE NEED TO DO FOR
THE IMMINENT FIRE SEASON WE
REALLY NEED TO TAKE A GOOD LOOK
AT OUR COMMUNITIES.
AND MAKE SURE THAT WE CAN
PROTECT THEM BOTH NOW AND IN THE
PLANNING PROCESS SO WITH THAT I
WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR HIGH
VOTE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR BRINGING
THIS FORWARD I'M WITH YOU WE'VE
HAD THIS DID THESE DEVASTATING
FIRES.
THE CAST OFF.
AND IF THERE'S ANY WAY THAT WE
CAN -- HELP FAMILIES AN
UNFORTUNATE BUT IN THESE RULES
THAT YOU SHOULD BE HEARTENING
YOUR HOUSE OR WHATEVER -- SO
REALLY IMPORTANT SO I'M THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR BRING IT
FORWARD AND WEWILL BE
SUPPORTING THE BILL TODAY.
THANK YOU.
SECRETARY THE MOTION IS DO PASS
AND REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS AGUIAR-CURRY HI
AGUIAR-CURRY I LACKEY BLOOM.
BLOOM I BOERNER HORVATH HI BRING
HER BACK I RAMOS.
RAMOS SIDE GONZALEZ ROBERT RIVAS.
ROBERT RIVERSIDE VOEPEL.
VOEPEL NOT VOTING.
THE BILL IS.
BILLS OUT FIVE ZERO THANK YOU
SENATOR HE VERY MUCH IN IN MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS ALL RIGHT NEXT IS
ITEM NUMBER NINE SB SIX SEVEN TO
A SOME US SENATOR HILL.
WELCOME [inaudible]
RATING.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR GOOD
AFTERNOON GOOD AFTERNOON AND
MEMBERS HI. ONE NOVEMBER IN
NOVEMBER OF TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN THE VOTERS IN BRISBANE
CALIFORNIA IN MY DISTRICT MADE A
SIGNIFICANT COMMITMENT TO
REGIONAL HOUSING.
WHEN THEY APPROVED MEASURE JJ
WHICH WOULD PERMIT THE
DEVELOPMENT OF EIGHTEEN HUNDRED
TO TWO THOUSAND TWO HUNDRED
UNITS OF HOUSING ON THE BAY
LANDS?
THIS WOULD MORE THAN DOUBLE THE
HOUSING STOCK IN THE CITY OF
BRISBANE.
PASSED THE MEASURE JJ WAS A
WATERSHED MOMENT FOR BRISBANE IN
THE STATE.
JJ REVERSES NEARLY FIFTY YEARS
OF VOTES AGAINST DEVELOPMENT OF
THE BAIL AND IT REPRESENTS THE
TYPE OF LOCAL LEADERSHIP WE NEED
THROUGHOUT THE BAY AREA.
N. THE STATE IF WE ARE GOING TO
PUT A REAL DENT IN THE HOUSING
CRISIS.
SB SIX SEVENTY TWO ALLOWS
BRISBANE TO FOCUS ITS EFFORTS ON
GETTING THE BAY LANDS AN
IMPORTANT REGIONAL PROJECT.
DEVELOPED PROPERLY THE BILL DOES
DOES THIS BY INSURING
CONSISTENCY IN BRISBANE'S
REGIONAL HOUSING NEEDS ARE
ALLOCATIONS.
DURING THIS PLANNING CYCLE AND
THE NEXT IN RECOGNITION OF THE
COMMITMENT ALREADY MADE BY THE
CITY'S VOTERS TO DOUBLE DOUBLE
ITS HOUSING STOCK.
SB SIX SEVENTY TWO IS NOT A GIFT
THAT IS THE BENEFIT TO BRISBANE
UNDER THE BILL IS ONLY AVAILABLE
IF THE CITY CONTINUES TO MAKE
STEADY PROGRESS WITH THE BALANCE
DEVELOPMENT UNDER THE OVERSIGHT.
OF THE DEVELOP DEPARTMENT OF
HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
AND CHAIR MEMBERS THIS MEASURE
HAS RECEIVED UNANIMOUS
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND HAS NO
OPPOSITION AFFECT VS ROBERT I DO
HAVE A WITNESS.
THANK YOU WELCOME.
THANK YOU HAVE A GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS DELYLAH CLAY
HERE ON BEHALF OF THE CITY OF
BRISBANE.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT TODAY AND WOULD REALLY
LIKE TO THANK SENATOR HILL FOR
HIS EFFORTS ON THIS MULTI YEAR --
EFFORT ON THE ON THE BAY LANDS
ON THE VOTE IN NOVEMBER TO ALLOW
EIGHTEEN HUNDRED TO TWENTY TWO
HUNDRED UNITS OF HOUSING --
REPRESENTED A REAL SHIFT IN THE
COMMUNITY IN RECOGNITION OF THE
NEED FOR HOUSING IN THE REGION --
AND A DESIRE TO SEE THE BAY
LANDS CLEANED UP -- TO ALLOW FOR
A MORE BENEFICIAL USE TO THE
ENTIRE REGION AS SENATOR HILL
EXPLAINS -- THIS WILL DOUBLE THE
SIZE OF THE CITY THIS IS A MAJOR
COMMITMENT THAT MOST CITIES ARE
NOT UNDERTAKING.
ON THE BAY LANDS IS HEAVILY
ENVIRONMENTALLY IMPACTED WAS A
FORMER LANDFILL -- AND RAILYARD --
THE PROJECT WILL BE COMPLEX WILL
REQUIRE YEARS OF COORDINATION
BETWEEN VARIOUS -- AGENCIES THE
CITY THE DEVELOPER AND THINGS OF
THAT NATURE SO -- THIS BILL IS
REALLY AN IMPORTANT MEASURE TO
ALLOW THE ALLOW PLANNING
CONSISTENCY FOR THE COMMUNITY --
AND WITH THAT REALLY AS FOR YOUR
IPHONE.
I THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- AND
OTHERS IN SUPPORT YES MANAGER
MEMBERS JASON RILEY CALIFORNIA
CITIES WERE ALSO SUPPORT THIS
MEASURE.
SEE MY TO CENTERS BERRY COUNSEL
AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHERS IN SUPPORT EEING
NONE ANYONE IN OPPOSITION.
IT LOOKS LIKE WE HAVE NO
OPPOSITION THE JUST CHECKING IN
THAT HALLWAY.
THE HOLDING PEN.
ALL RIGHT WE HAVE NO OPPOSITION.
ACCORDING TO THE SERGEANTS SO
THAT'S GREAT -- IN THE IN
QUESTIONS OF THE COMMITTEE.
APPEARS THERE'S A QUITE
COMMITTEE TODAY.
I NEED A MOTION.
THANKS FOR AFFECTED.
OKAY WE HAVE A MOTION BY OUR
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RIVAS IS SECOND
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER BLOOM.
LIKE TO CLOSE RESPECTFULLY ASK
PRIVATE MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR
YOU'VE GOT MY I HAVE A THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
THIS IS A GREAT BILL -- YOUR
COMMITTEES DOING A GREAT GREAT
JOB AND WHICH WAS OTHERS TO DO
THE SAME THING AS COULD TAKE
SOME TIME BUT CONGRATULATIONS
AND ARMS FOR THE BILL THANK YOU
MADAM.
THE US SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AND RE
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS AGUIAR-CURRY HI
AGUIAR-CURRY I LACKEY BLOOM.
BLOOM I BOERNER HORVATH BOERNER
HORVATH I RAMOS FROM ASIDE
GONZALEZ ROBERT RIVAS ROBERT
RIVAS I VOEPEL [inaudible]
I BILLS AT SIX ZERO THANK
EDUCATION THANK YOU IDENTIFY ANY
OF THE SENATORS WE JUST SEND
MORE AWAY.
I KNOW WE'RE OKAY GREEN
ENTERTAINING MOTION ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR.
OKAY WE HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND.
WE GOT HIT THOSE WERE.
AGUIAR-CURRY I AGUIAR-CURRY I
LACKEY BLOOM.
WILL MY BOERNER HORVATH.
BOERNER HORVATH I RAMOS ROMA
PSYCH AND SALAS [inaudible]
ROBERT RIVAS.
ROBERT RIVAS FIVE VOEPEL
[inaudible]
VOEPEL HI.
BILLS AT SIX ZERO CALENDARS AT
SIX ZERO OKAY WE'RE WE HAVE A
CALL OUT FOR ADDITIONAL SENATORS
THAT WILL TAKE A A BREATHER HERE
FOR SECOND
.
ALL RIGHT GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS
A ITEM NUMBER TWO SB THIRTEEN
CENTER Y. CASKEY WELCOME.
MADAM CHAIR -- GOOD AFTERNOON
MEMBERS LET ME START OFF BY
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS.
ON PAGE EIGHT OF THE ANALYSIS.
IN FULL I SB THIRTEEN ADDRESSES
THE TOP EIGHTY YOU BARRIERS
IDENTIFIED BY THE DEPARTMENT OF
HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT WHICH INCLUDES
REDUCING IMPACT FEES.
ELIMINATING OWNER OCCUPANCY AND
PROVIDING A SAFE PATH OF FOR I'M
PERMITTED EIGHTY USED TO BE
BROUGHT UP TO CODE.
WE HAVE SIGNIFICANT STUDIES FROM
PLACES SUCH AS THE CITY OF SANTA
CRUZ AND UC BERKELEY THEY HAVE
SHOWN THAT DEVELOPER IMPACT FEES
ARE EXCESSIVELY HIGH FOR
ACCESSORY DWELLING UNITS. FOR
INSTANCE UC BERKELEY FOUND THAT
SOME LOCALITIES ARE CHARGING AS
MUCH AS FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS
PER UNIT.
AND THAT NUMBER DOESN'T EVEN
INCLUDE THE IMPACT FEES CHARGED
BY DID YOU TELL THE DISTRICTS
AND OTHER DISTRICTS MANY
HOMEOWNERS THAT WANT TO BUILD A
THE USE A READER STOPPED IN
THEIR TRACKS WERE BILLED THEM
ILLEGALLY I'M PERMITTED.
WHEN THEY'RE HANDED THAT THESE
FEES IS ESTIMATED THAT THERE ARE
NEARLY? 330-010-00300 THOUSAND
AND PERMITTED UNITS IN THE
GREATER LOS ANGELES AREA ALONE.
EIGHTY USER BUILT ON LOTS THAT
ARE HAVE ALREADY HAVE ALREADY
PAID DEVELOPMENT FEES HOMEOWNERS
SHOULD NOT HAVE TO PAY.
THEM AGAIN LET ALONE PAY THE
AMOUNT CHARGED FOR THE PRIMARY
UNIT.
THIS IS ESPECIALLY TRUE
CONSIDERING THE FACT THAT
HOMEOWNER CAN EXPAND THEIR HOUSE
FOR A BED FOR BEDROOM KITCHEN A
BATHROOM AND THEY WOULD PAY ZERO
IMPACT FEES.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS I THINK I
MENTIONED THIS LAST YEAR MY WIFE
AND I BUILT A FOUR HUNDRED FORTY
SQUARE FOOT.
ADDITION ONTO OUR HOUSE PUT
ANOTHER.
STOVE IN A BRAND NEW BATHROOM
AND FOUR HUNDRED FORTY FEET IT
WAS A ONE DAY PERMIT.
OF ONE DAY OVER THE COUNTER --
PERMIT AND WE DIDN'T PAY ANY
IMPACT FEES.
SO SB THIRTEEN ALSO ADDRESSES
THE OWNER OCCUPANCY ORDINANCES
WHICH REQUIRED THAT THE OWNER TO
LIVE ON EITHER THE EIGHTY YOU OR
THE PRIMARY UNIT AND WE'RE
NEARING THE BLOOM LANGUAGE THAT
WAS ADOPTED BY THIS COMMITTEE
EARLIER.
THERE IS THERE'S AN UNFOUNDED
FEAR.
THAT INVESTORS WILL BE BUYING
HOMES JUST TO BUILD THEIR EIGHTY
USED TO RENT THEM OUT.
IN REALITY STUDIES HAVE SHOWN
THAT THIS FEAR.
IS MISS PLACE AND THAT THE
MAJORITY OF EIGHTY USE ARE BUILT
BY HOMEOWNERS TO HOUSE FAMILY
AND FRIENDS.
THE CITY OF PORTLAND DID A STUDY
THAT FOUND THAT OUT OF ONE
THOUSAND TWO HUNDRED EIGHTY YOU
SURVEY ONLY 10% WERE BUILT BY
INVESTORS.
OWNER OCCUPANCY REQUIRES --
REQUIREMENTS LIMIT THE
MARKETABILITY OF EIGHTY USE AND
PREVENTS THE CONSTRUCTION OF
THEM.
THERE HAVE BEEN BANKS REFUSING
TO GIVE A LOAN OUT TO HOMEOWNERS
BECAUSE OF THIS REQUIREMENT.
THERE IS NO OTHER TYPE OF
RESIDENTIAL UNIT THAT HAS SUCH
RESTRICTIONS THE STATE OF OREGON
IS ON THE VERGE OF BANNING HOME
OCCUPANCY AND SEATTLE JUST
RECENTLY PASSED AN ORDINANCE
PREVENTING AT CALIFORNIA SHOULD
FOLLOW IN THE FOOTSTEPS OF WILL
HAVE FIVE YEAR PERIOD. TO SEE
HOW THAT LOOKS.
OUT WE NEED TO ADDRESS THESE
REMAINING BARRIERS THAT
PROFESSIONALS RESEARCHERS AND
BANKERS HOMEOWNERS AND
LEGISLATURE HAVE IDENTIFIED AS
IMPORTANT ISSUES WITH ME TODAY
ARE A COUPLE OF EXPERTS.
WE HAVE A STEEP ALEJO'S WHO'S
DEPRESSED THE PRESIDENT OF PRE
FAB EIGHTY YOU AND I HAVE DOCTOR
BEEN THAT -- MUKHERJEE MUJAHID
SKEWS ME DOCTOR WHO'S A
PROFESSOR IN THE DEPARTMENT
CHAIR OF URBAN PLANNING AT UCLA.
DOCTOR.
WELCOME THANK YOU THANK YOU --
GOOD AFTERNOON.
MY MY RESEARCH IS ON INFORMAL
HOUSING WHICH I CALLED.
ON PERMITTED AND UNREGULATED
HOUSING AND I USED TO DO THIS
MORE IN DEVELOPING COUNTRIES BUT
RECENTLY LAST FEW YEARS --
CALIFORNIA AND CITY OF LOS
ANGELES PARTICULARLY.
BY LOOKING AT SALES REAL ESTATE
SALES LISTINGS UP TRY TO
ESTIMATE HOW MANY ON PERMITTED
SINGLE FAMILY HOMES HOW MANY
[inaudible]
UNITS.
HOW MANY UNCOMMITTED ES DE USER
THERE WITH SINGLE FAMILY HOMES
IN THE CITY OF LA AND MY
ESTIMATE SO WE HAVE ABOUT? FIFTY
THOUSAND IN THE CITY OF LA AND
ROUGHLY. TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND IN
THE COUNTY OF LA -- SINCE THE
VARIOUS.
SB TEN SIXTY NINE IN AB TWENTY
NINE TWENTY TWO NINETY NINE LOS
HERE THE CITY OF LA HAS HAD
SUCCESS.
IN A LOVING COMMITTED A. B. USE.
AND WE HAVE SEEN.
ALMOST TEN THOUSAND TO PERMIT
APPLICATIONS FOR EXCESS THREE
DWELLING UNITS IN THE CITY OF LA.
IN TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN
EIGHTEEN IN THE FIRST QUARTER OF
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN THE CITY
OF LA SUCCESS.
HAS LARGELY BEEN BASED ON THE
LACK OF THE OWNER OCCUPANCY.
REQUIREMENT IN THE CITY -- THE
CITY OF LA ALSO HAS.
RELATIVELY LITTLE.
PERMIT FEES NOT PERMIT FEES BUT
DEVELOPMENT FEES RELATED TO
EIGHTY YOU SAID THOSE TO HAVE
BEEN.
A KEY IN THIS MOVE TO WOODS MORE
FORMAL LADY USE.
N..
I THINK IT WOULD BE.
HELPFUL TO HAVE SIMILAR
REQUIREMENTS ACROSS THE OTHER
CITIES IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
AND CERTAINLY THE STATE WE WILL
ARE LIKELY TO SEE.
MANY MORE PERMITTED A TO USE IF
THE FEES WERE LESS IF OWNER
OCCUPANCY REQUIREMENTS WILL
LOWER.
AND IT IS.
MY ESTIMATES ARE IF IF WE DO
HAVE FIFTY THOUSAND ON COMMITTED
UNITS.
THAT IS ABOUT SEVEN AND A HALF
BILLION DOLLARS OF REAL ESTATE
VALUES THAT COULD BRING IN --
SEVENTY FIVE MILLION OR SO IN
REAL ESTATE TAXES EVERY YEAR AT
THE CITY COUNTY LEVEL THAT WOULD
BE THREE HUNDRED MILLION.
SO THERE MIGHT BE WAYS OF MAKING
UP FOR LOST REVENUE ON THE
DEVELOPMENT FEES SIDE THROUGH
PROPERTY TAXES.
BUT WE WOULD HAVE WE BEEN BILL
AND THE OPPORTUNITY TO REGULATE
SOME OF THESE UNITS AND STOP THE
ONES THAT ARE PARTICULARLY.
DANGEROUS.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
[inaudible]
WELCOME.
I THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME HERE --
MY NAME IS STEVE LAOS -- I'M THE
PRESIDENT OF PRE FAB EIGHTY YOU --
I'E BEEN BUILDING A USE FOR
ABOUT FOURTEEN YEARS NOW -- SO
I'VE I'VE SEEN THE CHANGE -- IN
THE EIGHTY YOU INDUSTRY -- SINCE --
PURELY LEGISLATION IS TO AND AND
TO WHAT'S HAPPENING NOW -- I
BUILT OVER A HUNDRED EIGHTY OF
THEM SCATTERED ACROSS MULTIPLE
JURISDICTIONS -- SO I'VE SEEN A
LOT OF DIFFERENT CITIES AND AND
AND HOW THEY REACT TO EIGHTY USE --
WE KEEP ABOUT FIFTEEN TO TWENTY
ACTED BUILDS IN ABOUT THIRTY TO
FIFTY IN THE DESIGN AND APPROVAL
PROCESS SO WE WERE VERY AWARE
ABOUT WHAT'S ACTIVELY GOING ON
IN THE MARKET SO I WANT TO SHARE
WITH YOU SOME INFORMATION ABOUT.
THE MARKET ITSELF AND THEN AND
THEN HELP -- REALLY FOCUS ON
THESE TO THESE TWO KEY ISSUES OF
HONOR OCCUPANCY AND IMPACT FEES.
SO RIGHT NOW WE'VE DONE A STUDY
OF OF OF THE OF THE MARKET AND
THERE'S ABOUT NINE MILLION HOMES
IN IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
THAT WOULD QUALIFY FOR AN EIGHTY
YOU -- WITH STUDIES COMING OUT
OF THE BAY AREA COUNCIL --
YOU'RE DOING RESEARCH ON
HOMEOWNER INTEREST -- THE
INTEREST LEVELS ABOUT 25% SO
THAT WOULD MEAN THAT IN
CALIFORNIA THERE'S ROUGHLY ABOUT
TWO POINT TWO FIVE MILLION --
HOMES THAT WOULD BE INTERESTED
IN DOING EIGHTY OF SO.
NEED TO SAY THERE'S A THERE'S A
HUGE OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS
AFFORDABLE HOUSING WITH EIGHTY
YEARS AND I THINK IT'S MUCH
GREATER THAN MOST PEOPLE -- EVEN
EVEN THINK THAT'S POSSIBLE.
AS WE SPEAK LA IS RECORDED OVER
TEN THOUSAND A YOU APPLICATIONS
SINCE.
SINCE THE EARLY TWENTY SEVENTEEN
BILL FROM MY KOWSKI -- AND WE'RE
CURRENTLY WORKING ON A DEAL WITH
SAN JOSE RIGHT NOW TO PRODUCE
FIVE THOUSAND UNITS FOR THEM ---AND FOCUSING ON THEM BEING
AFFORDABLE AND AN EXPEDITED --
AND WE'RE WORKING ON SIMILAR
EFFORTS WITH SAN MATTEO NAPA
SONOMA COUNTY AS WELL AS OAKLAND
SO THE INTEREST LEVEL IS
DEFINITELY THERE THERE'S NO
QUESTION ABOUT IT -- EVERYBODY
SEES THIS IS A VIABLE WAY TO
ADDRESS FOR WILL HOUSING BUT
WHAT DOES THAT REALLY MEAN.
SO WHEN WE LOOK AT EIGHTY USE
AND WE AND WE DO EIGHTY USE AND
WE ACTUALLY PROVIDE FINANCING IN
HOUSE WHAT IT MEANS IS THAT WE
CAN GENERATE HOMES ACTUALLY --
CAN BE RENTED OUT AT 15250% OF
THE LOCAL A MY LEVELS -- AND I
THINK IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT TO
KNOW THAT BECAUSE YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT A PRODUCT HERE.
THAT DOESN'T REQUIRE SUBSIDIES.
SO THERE'S NOT A LOT OF RED TAPE
IT DOESN'T REQUIRE
INFRASTRUCTURE DOESN'T REQUIRE
US ALLOCATING LAND -- IT'S A
IT'S A PRETTY SEAMLESS PRODUCT
IN TERMS OF OF WHAT CAN BE DONE
HERE AND AND AS AN EXAMPLE WE'RE
ACTUALLY WRAPPING UP A PROJECT--
IN DAVIS WHICH I THOUGHT WOULD
BE OF INTEREST TO YOU -- THE THE
EIGHTY YOU IS IS ACTUALLY
COSTING THEM EIGHT HUNDRED
THIRTY DOLLARS A MONTH --
FINANCED.
AND SO MARGUERITE UNITS ARE
GOING FOR ABOUT TWENTY TWO
HUNDRED DOLLARS A MONTH SO
THAT'S ABOUT A THIRTEEN HUNDRED
DOLLAR THIRTEEN SEVENTY SAVINGS
AND THAT PUTS THEM AT RIGHT
ABOUT 50% THE AND MY LEVEL TO
PUT A FAMILY MEMBER IN THAT UNIT
SO -- AND AGAIN ALL WITHOUT
SUBSIDIES SO HE HE THESE THIS
EFFORT HERE IS IS HUGELY
IMPORTANT IN A AND I I WANT TO I
WANT TO EMPHASIZE THAT BUT WHEN
WE LOOK AT THE THINGS THAT ARE
BARRIERS -- OWNER OCCUPANCY IS
IS DEFINITELY -- IS A CONCERN AS
AS AS THE CENTER MENTIONED.
IN EIGHTY USE ARE THE ONLY THING
THAT SEEMS TO BE SITTING ON
SINGLE FAMILY PROPERTIES THAT
ARE GETTING IN ON A ROCK HITS
THE REQUIREMENTS.
AND IT'S STRANGE THAT EVEN SHOWS
UP TIED TO EIGHTY USE GOING INTO
MULTI FAMILY WHERE WE THAT SAME
MULTI FAMILY PROPERTY WE CAN
BUILD A DUPLEX AND THERE'S NO ON
OUR OCCUPANCY ON IT.
SO IT IT IT'S A IT'S A LITTLE
STRANGE TO DO THIS AND
HOMEOWNERS ARE VERY RECEPTIVE TO
THAT -- BUT BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY
I WANT TO SHARE WITH YOU THAT
THAT AS A BUILDER OF EIGHTY USE
AND AND REALLY THE NUMBER ONE
BUILDER VIDEOS IN THE STATE. 80%
OF OUR BUSINESS IS DONE FOR
FAMILIES SO I UNDERSTAND THAT
THERE'S A FEAR THAT -- BUT THIS
COULD BE SOMETHING WHERE
INVESTORS COME IN AND AND RUIN
THE NEIGHBORHOOD.
BUT BUT WITHOUT WITHOUT ANYBODY
YOU KNOW REALLY.
IF FOCUSING ON RESTRICTING THAT.
WE'RE WE'RE STILL DOING 80% IN
AREAS LIKE LIKE OAKLAND THAT
DOESN'T HAVE OWNER OCCUPANCY
REQUIREMENTS.
SO I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO
KNOW THAT THAT THAT THERE'S A
FEAR BUT IT'S NOT IT'S NOT BASED
IN FACT IT'S BASED IN YOU KNOW A
POTENTIAL OUR CONCERN OF WHAT
COULD HAPPEN.
WE DO KNOW AS AS CENTER
MENTIONED FROM PORTLAND THAT --
THAT WENT OUT ON OUR COMMITTEE
WAS REMOVED SEVERAL YEARS BACK
IT YOU KNOW THEY'RE THEY'RE
STILL SEEING THAT SPECULAR BILL
SPECULATIVE BILLS ARE ONLY. 10%
OF THE MARKET -- WE ALSO KNOW
THAT.
WHEN WE LOOK TO MARKETS THAT ARE
MORE DEVELOPED AND TRY TO
UNDERSTAND WHAT'S GOING ON WITH
THEM?
THERE ARE FOUR MARKETS THAT ARE
THE BIGGEST EIGHTY MARKETS IN IN
NORTH AMERICAN THAT'S PORTLAND.
LOS ANGELES VANCOUVER IN AUSTIN
AND ALL OF THEM HAVE ONE THING
IN COMMON.
THEY DON'T HAVE OWNER OCCUPANCY
RESTRICTIONS.
SO IT'S IF WE'RE GOING TO TAP
INTO THE POTENTIAL OF EIGHTY USE.
IT'S IT'S INCUMBENT THAT WE FIND
A WAY TO REMOVE THAT OUR
OCCUPANCY REQUIREMENTS.
IS THAT IS THAT IS SOMETHING
THAT HOMEOWNERS JUST DON'T SEEM
TO UNDERSTAND.
AND I THINK IT'S A VERY
DIFFICULT THING WHEN WE GET INTO
IMPACT FEES THAT'S ANOTHER PIECE
OF THIS PUZZLE THAT I I THINK IS
A IS A BIG DEAL BREAKER -- WE
JUST RECENTLY COMPLETED A
PROJECT IN DUBLIN.
THE TOTAL FEES WERE THIRTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR THREE HER
SQUARE FOOT UNIT THE EIGHTY YOU
COST NINETY SEVEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS.
SO THOSE FEES REPRESENT ABOUT
31% OF THE BUILDING COST WHEN WE
DIVVY UP THE FEES THE ACTUAL
BUILDING PERMIT PORTION OF IT IS
ONLY THIRTY NINE HUNDRED DOLLARS.
SO -- REALLY SAYING IS THAT THAT
YOU'RE LOOKING AT TWENTY SIX
THOUSAND DOLLARS WORTH OF IMPACT
FEES TIED TO THIS THREE HUNDRED
SQUARE FOOT EIGHTY YOU.
AND I I THINK WE NEED TO ADDRESS
THIS BECAUSE THERE'S A THERE'S A
EVEN AT THE CITY LEVEL THERE'S A
MISUNDERSTANDING ABOUT THAT
PROPORTIONATE.
SCALE AND HOW TO APPROPRIATELY
DEAL WITH THAT.
AND WHEN THERE'S A
MISUNDERSTANDING THERE'S A
TENDENCY TO LEAVE THINGS THE WAY
THEY ARE AND MAKE THE HOMEOWNER
THAT THE THE ONE WHO BURDENS
THAT RATHER THAN ADDRESS IT AND
AND THAT'S WHY I THINK IT REALLY
DOES NEED TO BE ADDRESSED.
AT THIS LEVEL ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT I ALWAYS TELL PEOPLE WHEN
WE LOOK AT THIS IS WHEN WE BRING
TWO SCENARIOS AND COMPARE THEM
TO EACH OTHER.
WE LOOK AT IN ADDITION AND WE
LOOK AT AN EIGHTY YOU OF THE
SAME PROPERTY THE SAME SIZE
HOUSE. ONE PERSON DOESN'T
ADDITION THE OTHER PERSON DOES
THE DATE THE EIGHTY YOU THE
ADDITION ISN'T ASSESSED ANY OF
THOSE IMPACT FEES.
BUT YET THE EIGHTY YOU IS ONE
SOLUTION THE ADDITION JUST
CREATES A A MCMANSION PROBLEM
FOR US.
THE OTHER IS ACTUALLY PROVIDING
AFFORDABLE HOUSING BUT YET THE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING SOLUTION IS
GETTING HIT WITH THE IMPACT FEES.
SO WE REALLY NEED TO LOOK AT
THIS AND THINK ABOUT THIS AND
UNDERSTAND IT BECAUSE IT ISN'T
AS IF WE'RE TAKING MONEY AWAY
FROM CITIES WHEN WE TALK ABOUT.
REMOVING THIS WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT ACTUALLY GETTING THEM TO
UNDERSTAND IT IN THE SAME WAY
THEIR UNDERSTANDING THAT
ADDITION WHICH ISN'T HELPING THE
CITY OUT AT ALL CAN YOU WRAP IT
UP.
YES THANK YOU THAT'S ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ARE OTHERS
IN SUPPORT PLEASE.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR ADAM
WRIGLEY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
IN STRONG SUPPORT THANKS.
HI DON CASEY THE EIGHTY DIRECTOR
FOR CALIFORNIA RENTERS LEGAL
ADVOCACY AND EDUCATION FUND AND
FULL SUPPORT THANK YOU.
SENATE TRAVIS FROM SAN FRANCISCO
BAY AREA RENTERS FEDERATION
STRONG SUPPORT AN OWNER
OCCUPANCY REQUIREMENT IS AN ANTI
RENTER PROHIBITION VERY UNFAIR
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU JUST YOUR NAME.
SHE AS ALTHOUGH I'M HAPPY
CALIFORNIA STATE RETIREES AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MATT REGAN WITH THE BAY AREA
COUNCIL IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
ZACKS YOU'VE BEEN WITH URBAN
ENVIRONMENTALISTS AND THAT'S A
FEW BE IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. ONE TEN WITH SAM'S IS
GOING TO BE IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
KEEP MOTOR WITH MISSION YOU'LL
BE IN SUPPORT.
HOWEVER MANY ON BEHALF A HABITAT
FOR HUMANITY CALIFORNIA AND THE
NONPROFIT HOUSING ASSOCIATION
RATHER CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
LOUIS MANTE ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA BE IT'S TRANSPORT.
TODAY THE BAY AREA HOUSING
ADVOCACY COALITION IN SUPPORT
THANK.
JENNIFER SPEC ABOUT THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS IN SUPPORT.
DAVID GARCIA TURNER CENTER FOR
HOUSING INNOVATION AT UC
BERKELEY IN SUPPORT.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS MICHAEL
GOING WITH THE CALIFORNIA
BUILDING INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION
HERE IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
ARE THERE ANY OTHERS IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL.
SEEING NONE WILL MOVE OVER TO
THE OPPOSITION [inaudible]
ME [inaudible]
GOOD AFTERNOON.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS.
EXCUSE ME J. SLIGHTLY CALIFORNIA
CITIES.
WE HAVE AN APOSTLE SUBMITTED
POSITIONS BILL WE'VE WORKED A
LOT.
WITH CENTER Y. CASKEY IN THE
SUMMER BLOOM ON ON THESE VARIOUS
CD YOU BILLS OVER THE YEAR.
I THINK THAT THE MAIN STICKING
POINT REALLY IS AROUND YOUR FEES
WE'VE TALKED A LOT ABOUT IMPACT
FEES.
AND IT IS LIKE A MINOR ONE THAT
YOU KNOW THE IMPACT FEES AND WE
DON'T MAKE MONEY ON IT.
IF WE'RE GONNA YOU KNOW THE
GENTLY BEFORE WAS TALK ABOUT HOW
YOU KNOW WE'RE IS CAN DEPRIVE
CITIES OF MONEY.
I THINK WE DON'T HAVE THE IMPACT
FEES ARE WE'RE DEPRIVING
RESIDENTS OF THE SERVICES THAT
THEY'RE GONNA DEMAND WHEN THEY
LIVE IN OUR COMMUNITY -- BUT WE
DO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT IT CAN BE A
PROBLEM AND IT CAN BE A BEAR AND
I THINK YOU KNOW WHAT THOSE FEES
STUDY COMING OUT WE SERVE OUR
WORK IN THE LEGISLATURE IN
ADDRESSING.
ON THAT THE FEE ISSUE -- BUT YOU
KNOW.
WE WITH THAT PROVISION IN THE
BILL WE MUST RESPECTFULLY --
REMAIN OPPOSED LOS AMENDED.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME -- MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS ERIN HOLLAND PUBLIC
INFORMATION OFFICER FOR THE
NORTH TAHOE FIRE PROTECTION
DISTRICT ON BEHALF OF FIRE CHIEF
MIKE SCHWARTZ.
NORTH TAHOE FIRES A SPECIAL FIRE
DISTRICT SERVING MOST OF THE
CALIFORNIA SIDE OF THE LAKE
TAHOE BASIN.
THERE IS NO DOUBT THAT WE ARE IN
THE MIDST OF A TRUE CRISIS IN
REGARD TO HOUSING.
AS A PUBLIC SAFETY AGENCY
OPERATING IN A HIGH END SEASONAL
RESORT TOWN WE FEEL THE CRISIS
OF AFFORDABLE WORKFORCE HOUSING
TO OUR CORE.
AND WE ADMIRE AND SUPPORT THE
AUTHORS DEDICATION TO SEEK
SOLUTIONS HOWEVER WE MUST STATE
A POSITION OF OPPOSE AS WRITTEN.
DUE TO THE UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES OF SB THIRTEEN IN
ITS CURRENT FORM.
AFFORDABLE HOUSING IS NOT THE
ONLY CRISIS THAT WE FACE.
THE FLOW THE SLOW MOVING CRISIS
LOOMING OVER ALL OF US IN
CALIFORNIA IS INSURE ABILITY OR
THE LACK THERE OF IN MY FIRE
DISTRICT SEVEN OUT OF TEN
HOMEOWNERS ARE BEING FACED WITH
CANCELLATIONS OR NON RENEWALS
FOR SINGLE FAMILY HOMES.
THESE ARE HOMES THAT HAVE
DEFENSIBLE SPACE THAT MEET THE
STATE FIRE MARSHAL'S CODE
REQUIREMENTS AND THAT WERE BUILT
WITH ACCEPTABLE MATERIALS.
THESE HOMEOWNERS PAY THEIR
PREMIUMS ON TIME AND HAVE A
SOLID HISTORY OF NO CLAIMS.
AND ARE BEING BLANKETED BY THE
ZIP CODE WITH CANCELLATIONS OR
INCREASES THAT ARE PUTTING THEIR
MONTHLY INSURANCE PREMIUMS.
UP THERE WITH THEIR MONTHLY
MORTGAGE PAYMENTS.
WHAT IS THAT GOING TO DO TO
PROPERTY VALUES WHO WILL FINANCE
HOMES THAT CAN'T BE INSURED AND
WHO CAN PURCHASE A HOME WITH THE
MONTHLY INSURANCE PREMIUM AS
HIGH AS THEIR MORTGAGE?
A LARGE PORTION OF THE STATE IS
RATED AS HIGH OR VERY HIGH FIRE
DANGER LIKE MY FIRE DISTRICT.
AN EXISTING HOMEOWNERS ARE
STRUGGLING TO FIND INSURERS.
EIGHTY USE WITHIN HIGH FIRE
DANGER AREAS ARE NO LONGER
REQUIRED TO MEET MANY OF THE
STATE FIRE MARSHAL'S CODE
MINIMUM REQUIREMENTS.
THAT APPLY TO OTHER DWELLINGS IN
THESE AREAS AS A RESULT OF
EFFORTS TO KEEP EIGHTY USE
AFFORDABLE.
THIS MEASURE OLYMPIC IT
ELIMINATES THE MITIGATION FEES
THAT WOULD FIND THE ADDITIONAL
FIRE SERVICE PROTECTION REQUIRED
FOR THIS ADDITIONAL DENSITY.
THAT IS LACKING FIRE PROTECTION
SYSTEMS.
OUR STATIONS MANY OF THEM ARE AT
CAPACITY WITHOUTTHESE FEES WE
DON'T HAVE THE ABILITY TO FIND
MORE PERSONNEL FOR ADDITIONAL
APPARATUS.
AFTER THE RECENT DEVASTATING
FIRE SEASONS SEASONS THAT HAVE
SET NEW RECORDS FOR CALIFORNIA
AND LOSS OF MIKE'S.
IN LOSS OF LIFE AND PROPERTY IT
IS ALL TOO CLEAR THAT FIRE LIFE
SAFETY REQUIREMENTS CANNOT BE
OVERLOOKED OR WAIVED FOR ANY
REASON.
ADDING DENSITY ADDS RISK.
WAVING CODES AND FEES WAVES
SAFETY PERIOD.
MEASURES TO ADD DENSITY MUST
INCLUDE FIRE LIFE SAFETY CODES
AND MUST INCLUDE MITIGATION
MEASURES TO MAINTAIN FIRE
PROTECTION SERVICE LEVELS THAT
MEET THE DEMANDS OF AN INCREASE
SERVICE POPULATION.
FIRE DISTRICTS ARE WITHOUT A
REVENUE SOURCE TO KEEP US TO
KEEP UP WITH POPULATION GROWTH
AND THE NEW SERVICE AN
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT IT DEMANDS.
AS A RESULT OF PROPOSITION TWO
EIGHTEEN FIRE DISTRICTS ABILITY
TO LEVY SURCHARGES FEES ARE
ASSESSMENTS.
IS NOT SIMPLE OR LIKELY TO BE
ACHIEVED. EIGHTY USE MAY NOT OUT
PARCELS BUT THEY WILL ADD
DENSITY.
MY DISTRICT ALREADY HAS A
SCALABLE FEEL FEE SCHEDULE WHERE
BY OUR FEES ARE RELATED TO THE
ADDITIONAL SQUARE FOOTAGE OR
FUEL BEING ADDED TO THE FOREST.
KEEPING DEVELOPMENT AFFORDABLE.
EIGHTY USE ARE ALLOWED TO BE
CONSTRUCTED UP TO TWELVE HUNDRED
SQUARE FEET IN MOST COMPETE
COMMUNITIES THAT IS THE SIZE OF
A TYPICAL THREE BEDROOM TWO
BATHROOM SINGLE FAMILY HOME.
IN THE WILDLAND URBAN INTERFACE
THAT MAY BE CONSIDERABLY LARGER
THAN THE ORIGINAL WELLING.
THERE ARE NO PROVISIONS THAT
REQUIRE THESE UNITS TO ADDRESS
WORKFORCE HOUSING ISSUES BY
RENTING FOR BELOW MARKET PRICE.
THERE ARE NO PROVISIONS THAT
PROHIBIT THESE UNITS FROM BEING
PLACED INTO VACATION RENTALS.
AND THERE ARE NO PROVISIONS THAT
REQUIRE THE UNIT ACTUALLY BE
RENTED OUT AT ALL AND NOT SIMPLY
BE TREATED AS A CHEAP WORK
AROUND FOR A HOMEOWNER TRYING TO
BUILD ON IN ADDITION.
THESE ARE ALL UNFORTUNATE
CONSEQUENCES OF ALLOWING THIS
WELL INTENDED BILL TO PASS IS
WRITTEN AND DO NOT FULFILLTHE
MAJORS INTENT OF ADDRESSING THE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING CRISIS
ESPECIALLY IN THE WAKE OF THIS
INSURANCE CRISIS.
WE RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THAT YOU
OPPOSE THE BILL AS WRITTEN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OTHERS IN
OPPOSITION.
A GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS KAREN LAYING ON THE OF
THE SOLANO COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS THE OPPOSITION IS
BASED ENTIRELY ON THE CODE
ENFORCEMENT PIECE OF THAT THEY
DID OF A CHICKEN COOP CONVERTED
TO AN EIGHTY YOU AT ONE POINT
THAT THEY HAD TO ABATE.
SO THEY'RE VERY CONCERNED ABOUT
THAT PIECE SPECIFICALLY THANK
YOU.
JUST YOUR NAME IN YOUR THE
CHICKEN COOP GOT ME.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS ENTRY ENTRY
ON BEHALF OF THE CITY OF BEVERLY
HILLS AND OPPOSITION.
SURPRISE.
I'M SORRY MEMBERS AREN'T ABLE
AND SAY REPRESENTING THE
AMERICAN PLANNING ASSOCIATION I
WAS OUTSIDE I APOLOGIZE THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS ARE BEING.
ACCEPTED YES OKAY SO I WITHOUT
WILL TAKE A LOOK WE MAY BE ABLE
TO GO NEUTRAL WITH THOSE MOMENTS
AND APPRECIATE THE COMMITTEE'S
WORK ON THAT SO THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON KIANA VALENTINE
ON BEHALF OF THE URBAN COUNTIES
OF CALIFORNIA WE HAVE AN OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED POSITION.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHEN GUNS ALL OF
HIS ON BEHALF OF THE CITIES OF
BEAUMONT IN CUPERTINO AND THE
EAST CONTRA COSTA FIRE
PROTECTION DISTRICT IN
OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE BALKANS OFFICER TODAY
ON BEHALF THE CITIES OF RANCHO
CUCAMONGA THOUSAND OAKS CAM RIO
TORRANCE IN SANTA CLARITA IN
OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU.
CHRISLEY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES OPPOSE MOST MINUTE.
THAT IN TURN MEMBERS MORE TOP ON
BEHALF THE CITY OF ANAHEIM IN
OPPOSITION.
DAVID JONES ABOUT THE CITIES OF
BURBANK AND SAN MARCOS IN
OPPOSITION.
NOT HER MOM ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF BY
RECREATION PARK DISTRICTS.
THE OF CALIFORNIA FIRE CHIEFS
ASSOCIATION AND THE FIRE
DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA
ALL IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
ANTHONY TOWN HALL CALIFORNIA
SPECIAL DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION
STILL IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ALL RIGHT WE
HAVE NO OTHERS IN OPPOSITION
OTHERS ANY QUESTIONS THE
COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU ARE ALMOST MADAM CHAIR
AND JUST TO JUST TO BE CLEAR
THERE'S SEVERAL AMENDMENTS THAT
WERE -- OFFERED IN AND THE
AUTHOR OF THE BILL DID ACCEPT
THOSE AMENDMENTS WE HEARD SOME.
TESTIMONY RIGHT NOW AS FAR AS
OPPOSED AND UNLESS AMEND IT.
BUT THERE WAS SOME SEVERE
AMENDMENT -- THAT WERE OR
OFFERED AND ACCEPTED BY BY THE
AUTHOR IS THAT CORRECT.
YES IT IS MY REPUTATION PRECEDES
ME SO I'M WHICH I HAVE ACCEPTED
THE AMENDMENTS CONTAINED IN THAT
REPORT -- I THIS IS STE -- THE
FOURTH YEARS I'VE HAD AND
ACCESSORY DWELLING UNIT BILL AND
IT'S GENERALLY THE SAME.
GROUP OF PEOPLE OR SAME
INTERESTS THAT HAVE OPPOSED THE
BILL SO I'M I THINK SOME OF THE
OF THE SOME OF THE PEOPLE WHO
ABOUT OPPOSE WHEN THEY GET A
CHANCE TO LOOK AT THE AMENDMENT
TO LOOK AT THAT THEY MIGHT
WITHDRAW OR GO NEUTRAL ON IT
THAT'S OUR OUR HOPE.
BUT I WOULD IMAGINE THEY'LL
STILL BE PEOPLE WHO WILL OPPOSE.
ANYTHING THAT HAS WHITE HOUSE
HIS NAME AND EIGHTY YOU I GET I
GET THAT.
I GET IT.
BUT I THINK IT'S SIX IT'S
SIGNIFICANTLY ALTERED THE THE
CONCERNS THAT THEY HAVE WITH --
IMPACT FEES AT A CERTAIN SIZE
WE'RE WE'VE CUT IT OFF AT SEVEN
HUNDRED AND FIFTY FEET AFTER
THAT THE IMPACT FEES ARE THERE
AND HOMEOWNERSHIP MERE --
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BLOOM SPELL THAT
WILL ALLOW FOR NO HOMEOWNERSHIP
FOR FIVE YEARS I'M.
I EXPECT TO STUDY IT EXTENSIVELY
TO DETERMINE WHAT THE THE TRUE
IT IMPACT IMPACT HIS BUT THOSE
SEEM TO BE THAT THE TWO BIG
ENCHILADAS THAT ARE CONCERNING
PEOPLE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER SUB QUESTIONS
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BLOOM QUESTIONS
AND COMMENTS.
I CAN NOT THAT I I I CAN ASK A
QUESTION THAT HAS IT REALLY BEEN
FOUR YEARS.
SINCE -- YOU AND I'VE BEEN
WORKING ON THIS -- ISSUE FOR A
LONG TIME THAT THAT'S A THAT'S
FOR SURE AND IT IS -- A
REMARKABLE HOW MANY -- UNITS
HAVE BEEN BUILT IN THAT PERIOD
OF TIME.
I THINK -- YOU KNOW IN TERMS OF
RESPONDING TO THE HOUSING CRISIS
THE THIS RELATIVELY SIMPLE
CHANGE AROUND EIGHTY USE.
HAS PRODUCED A TREMENDOUS AMOUNT
OF HOUSING -- WHEREAS OTHER
EFFORTS UNFORTUNATELY HAVE OR
MANY OF THEM HAVE HAVE
LANGUISHED -- SO I'M GLAD THAT --
YOU AND I CONTINUE TO TO TO BE --
OF PUSHING THIS A LONG WEEK --
ALONG WITH TWO OTHER MEMBERS
HAVE FOR THE HAVE LEGISLATION
THIS YEAR THERE'S INTENSE
INTEREST IN THE SUBJECT I THINK
BECAUSE OF A AS AS I'VE.
FOR A SUGGESTED -- TO TOO MANY
AT LEAST IN MY COMMUNITIES -- IT
THIS IS A AN EFFORT THAT IS
SUPPORTED BY BOTH HIM BEES AND
THEN THESE.
ARE THE FOLKS WHO I TALKED -- TO
IN MY DISTRICT WHO HAVE
TYPICALLY BEEN.
OF THE FOLKS WHO HAVE OPPOSED A
DEVELOPMENT HAVE EMBRACED IN
WELCOME TO EIGHTY IS.
AND TO AND OF COURSE -- THOSE
SIR WHO I JOIN WITH AND IN IN
PROMOTING ADDITIONAL HOUSING
EFFORTS OF HAVE ALSO HAVE ALSO.
BEEN -- BEEN VERY ENTHUSIASTIC
ABOUT EIGHTY IS I THINK THE
CHANGES THAT ARE -- THAT ARE IN --
IN YOUR BILL ARE ARE IMPORTANT --
I APPRECIATE THE FACT TO THAT
YOU -- WORKED HARD TO BE ABLE --
TO COME TO AGREEMENT WITH THE
COMMITTEE ON AMENDMENTS -- YOU
AND I SPOKE YESTERDAY ABOUT MY
BECOMING A CO AUTHOR OF YOUR
BILL HELP YOU'LL BECOME A UNLESS
YOU ALREADY ARE A CO AUTHOR OF
WHAT -- BUT I I'M HAPPY TO MOVE
THIS FORWARD AND MAKE THE MOTION
[inaudible]
THANK.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE HAVE A
MOTION [inaudible]
NEWS SECOND.
OKAY WE HAVE A SECOND.
WE HAVE ASSEMBLY MEMBER BLOOM
SEVEN RAMOS.
OKAY WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE I
WOULD URGE AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR WORKING WITH THE
COMMITTEE -- IS REALLY IMPORTANT
TO HELP GET THESE PROPOSED
AMENDMENTS THROUGH AN M. MAKES
ME FEEL GOOD THAT YOU TOOK THE
TIME.
AND THAT YOU APPRECIATE THE FACT
THAT EVERYONE IS WORKING HARD TO
HELP MAKE THIS -- GO FORWARD AND
I THINK THERE'S A LOT OF GREAT
THINGS ARE GONNA HAPPEN RIGHT
WITH THE EIGHTY USE WITH SO MANY
PEOPLE TRYING TO COME UP WITH A
SOLUTION AND WE'LL SEE WHAT
HAPPENS -- ON THE FLOOR SO THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
SECRETARY TAKE THE ROOM THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED AND
RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS AGUIAR-CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY I A LACKEY BLOOM.
BLOOM I BOERNER HORVATH RAMOS.
RAMESSIDE GONZALEZ ROBERT RIVAS
VOEPEL.
VOEPEL AYE THANK YOU.
THE BILL'S GOING TO NEED ONE
MORE VOTE SO PHONE CALL.
ALRIGHT LET'S.
WE HAVE THE AUDIENCE WELL IT
LOOKS LIKE WE HAVE SENATOR
HERTZBERG ITEM NUMBER FIVE SP
TWO ZERO FIVE WELCOME MISTER.
SENATOR.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
I MAKE.
BASS.
COMMITTEE TO APPROVE
[inaudible]
CHAU ARMED.
YEAH.
AS AS STORM WATER.
RUNS INTO OUR SYSTEM.
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IN THE
STATE GOVERNMENT.
HAVE COME UP WITH THE REGULATORY
SCHEME.
THAT IMPOSES LIABILITY FOR THE
STORM WATER DISCHARGES ON CITIES
AND COUNTIES AND BUSINESSES.
IT'S A BIG ISSUE COSTS A LOT OF
MONEY.
THE STORM WATER RUNS OFF AND
IT'S IT HAS ALL KINDS OF JUNK IT
IT INCLUDES THE OCEAN --
POLLUTES OUR WATERWAYS IN A
PRETTY SIGNIFICANT WAY AND IT'S
NOT GOOD.
SO WHAT'S HAPPENED IS THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IMPLEMENTED
TO THE STATE SYSTEM STATE WATER
RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD HAVE
BASICALLY COME UP WITH A METHOD.
TO FIND GOVERNMENTS AND AND IN
THE LA COUNTY WHERE I COME FROM
WE PASSED A BIG MEASURE THAT
REQUIRES A CLEAN UP BEFORE THE
DISCHARGE.
I WANTED TO CAPTURE THAT WATER
AND REUSE IT THAT'S FOR ANOTHER
CHAPTER IN ANOTHER DAY.
BUT THE BOTTOM LINE IS WHAT ARE
WE TRYING TO DO HERE SO HOW DO
WE ENFORCE THAT HERE'S THE
PROBLEM.
THAT SO MANY COMPANIES WHO ARE
REQUIRED TO GET THESE PERMITS
FOR DISH CHARGE DON'T DO IT.
SO HOW DOYOU COME UP WITH A
CREATIVE WAY THAT REQUIRES THEM
TO DO SO AND IT'S PARTICULARLY
EGREGIOUS BECAUSE IF A BUNCH OF
COMPANIES ARE POLLUTING.
E. THEY THEY GO OUT THEY POLLUTE
BUT THE BURDEN IF IT FALLS IN
ALL THE COMPLIANCE COMPANIES SO
HOW DO YOU CREATE EQUITY AND
FAIRNESS FOR BUSINESSES HOW DO
YOU REDUCE LIABILITIES FOR
CITIES AND COUNTIES.
AND WHAT WE DID IS WE SAID WHEN
YOU GO OUT THE CITY OR COUNTY
THAT HAS.
THAT HAS A BUSINESS PERMIT IF IT
DOES NOT REQUIRE ACCEPTING THE
AMENDMENTS WHICH IS ONE OF THOSE.
WE JUST BASICALLY GO AND WE SAY
LOOK WHEN YOU DO YOUR PERMIT YOU
GOTTA GO LOOK IT UP ON TO THE
WEBSITE AND MAKE SURE THAT THE
PEOPLE HAVE A PERMIT.
IT WHEN THEY'RE GETTING A
BUSINESS LICENSE IT'S A PRETTY
SIMPLE THING A GOOD THE BENEFIT
TO THE CITY YOU KNOW AND PEOPLE
COMPLAIN AND BELLY ACHE ABOUT
THAT THE COSTS.
BUT IT'S A PRETTY IN BALANCING
THE COST TO THE CITY BY ALL THIS
POLLUTION THAT THAT THE HARM TO
THEIR THE COMMUNITY THAT MEMBERS
OF THE COMMUNITY OF OF THE
BUSINESSES THAT ACTUALLY COMPLY.
IS A PRETTY.
ELEGANT SOLUTION IN MY JUDGMENT
TO BE ABLE TO CREATE MORE
COMPLIANCE REDUCE REST EVERYBODY
ELSE AND CLEAN UP OUR OUR
WATERWAYS AND STORM WATER RUNOFF
THAT'S WHY REDUCE THE BILL
THAT'S WHY I'M HERE TODAY.
AND ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT OF THIS
MEASURE THANK YOU RICH SENATOR --
OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME SEAN BOTHWELL IN
THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
CALIFORNIA BECAUSE KEEPER LANCE --
I WANT TO START WITH JUST A
CLICK MAKING CLARIFICATION OF
THE INTENT OF THIS BILL BECAUSE
THERE HAS BEEN CONFUSION IN THE
PAST.
SB TWO OH FIVE DOES NOT REQUIRE
IN ANY WAY THE MUNICIPALITY IS
RESPONSIBLE FOR ENSURING THAT
THE THE INDUSTRIAL FACILITIES
UNDER THE STORMWATER PERMIT.
THAT THEY'RE IN COMPLIANCE WITH
THE PERMIT AS A WHOLE THAT MEANS
THEY DON'T NEED TO FIGURE OUT IF
THEY'RE IN CHARGE OF THAT THEY
MET WATER QUALITY STANDARDS
THAT'S OF WATER BOARD -- FORTY
THING TO DO THE INTENT OF THIS
BILL IS THE ONLY ENSURE THAT
INDUSTRIAL FACILITIES WITHIN THE
MUNICIPALITY OR IN ROLLED UNDER
THIS INDUSTRIAL GENERAL PERMIT.
AND REALLY AS THE SUMMER
DESCRIBED.
ALL THAT REQUIRES IS -- PUT IT A
FOUR DIGIT AS I SEE CODE ONTO AN
APPLICATION WE'VE ALREADY WORK
WITH THE STATE WATER BOARD TO
HAVE A WEB PAGE THAT SAYS ALL
THIS I SEE CODES THAT NEED.
TO BE UNDER THIS PERMIT YOU
MATCH UP THE THE THE FOUR DIGIT
CODE AND IF THEY MATCH UP AND
THEN THERE'S ADDITIONAL UP THE
PAPERWORK TO JUST SHOW THAT YOU
HAVE COMPLIED UNDER THE PERMIT.
I'M IS SENATE SAID TO THIS.
THIS BILL IS A REALLY ELEGANT
SOLUTION -- TO HELPING
MUNICIPALITIES WITH LIABILITY
RELIEF AND AND ALL TRY TO
EXPLAIN WHY IT'S A LITTLE
TECHNICAL BUT INDUSTRIAL GENERAL
PERMIT -- YOU HAVE THE SELF AND
ROLL INTO YOUR NOT AUTOMATICALLY
INTO THE PERMITS SOCIAL HERE I'M
IN THE SECOND FROM THE REGULATED
COMMUNITY A LOT OF FOLKS HAVE
BUT IT'S REALLY ONLY ABOUT ONE
OUT OF FOUR ONE OUT OF FIVE
INDUSTRIAL PHILLIES.
SPECIALTIES THROUGHOUT THE STATE
HOW IN THE WORLD THAT'S ABOUT
20% ARE ACTUALLY IN COMPLIANCE
ARE UNDER THIS PERMIT.
SO WHAT HAPPENS SPLIT LET'S TAKE
LOS ANGELES FOR EXAMPLE THERE'S
A LOT OF INDUSTRIAL FACILITIES
THERE -- IT TOOK THE LA RIVER ID
LET'S SAY THE LA RIVERS IN
IMPAIRED OR IS TO TOXIC TO BE
ABLE TO SWIM IN WITH THE
REGIONAL BOARD DOES THERE IS
THEY LOOK AT HOW MUCH.
HOW MUCH METALS CAN BE
DISCHARGED INTO THAT RIVER?
OUR WITHOUT MAKING IT TALKS.
AND THE TAKE THAT NUMBER IN THE
DIVIDED AMONG ALL THE PROPERTIES
BUT IF 80% OF THE FOLKS THE
DESTRUCTION METALS INTO THE
RIVER ARE NOT A PERMITS HE THEN
THAT THEY DON'T EVEN KNOW THAT
THIS PROGRAM EXIST AND INSTEAD
THE MUNICIPALITIES IN LA -- LA
COUNTY AND THE INDUSTRIAL FOLKS
THEIR LEFT ARM ON THE HOOK TO
PAY AND DO ALL THE IMPROVEMENTS
NECESSARY TO COME INTO
COMPLIANCE BUT THEY'LL NEVER
ACTUALLY REACH THAT TARGET
BECAUSE AGAIN 80% OR EVEN UNDER
THE PERMIT.
SO THIS IS GOOD FOR THE
ENVIRONMENT IT'S GOOD FOR THE
REGULATED COMMUNITY TO PROVIDE
AN EVEN LATE LATE LEVEL PLAYING
FIELD -- AND IT'S GOOD TO THE
MUNICIPALITY TO REALLY DOES HELP
WITH THEIR LIABILITY RELIEF
UNDER STORM WATER FOR THAT
ANSWER.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WELCOME GOOD AFTERNOON THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR LAURIE CAMERA
REPRESENTING CALIFORNIA METALS
COALITION -- CMC IS HOME TO
ABOUT -- FOUR THOUSAND METAL
MANUFACTURES IN CALIFORNIA WHO
CREATE APPROXIMATELY THREE
HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND JOBS --
WE ARE PART OF THAT 20% WE ARE
THE SMALL BUSINESSES THEY'VE THE
FAMILY OWNED BUSINESSES THE
METAL FOUNDRIES WHO -- PAY THE
SEVENTEEN HUNDRED DOLLAR FEE ON
AVERAGE -- WE NEED TO BRING INTO
COMPLIANCE THAT OTHER 80% -- SO
THAT WE'RE NOT AT A COMPETITIVE
DISADVANTAGE FOR THOSE READ FOR
THESE REASONS WE OUR
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
SUPPORT.
I FELT PLEASE.
YEAH MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
GAVIN THE QUEUE ON BEHALF OF THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA OUT OF
DISTILLERS.
ASSOCIATION WITH THE GREAT
THINGS ABOUT THIS BILL IS THAT
IT SAID OPPORTUNITY FOR THE
BUSINESS COMMUNITY IN THE
ENVIRONMENTAL COMMUNITY TO WORK
TOGETHER ON A BILL THAT'S BOTH
GOOD REALLY GOOD FOR THE
ENVIRONMENT BUT ALSO GOOD FOR
BUSINESS.
I THINK FOR THOSE REASONS OF
IT'S A GOOD BILL WHICH IS
SUPPORTED THANK YOU.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR AND MEMBERS
THEIR CALL HIM AFTER THE
CALIFORNIA CITIES ALSO ASKED --
TO REPRESENT CALIFORNIA OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES WITH THE AMENDMENTS
WERE HAPPY TO REMOVE OUR
OPPOSITION WE REALLY DO
APPRECIATE WORKING WITH -- THE
COMMITTEE AND WITH THE SENATOR
AND HIS STAFF ON THIS BILL AND
THANK YOU FOR ALL YOUR HARD WORK
ON THE ARE THERE ANY QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE.
IS THERE A MOTION [inaudible]
SECOND.
WE HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO MAKE A CLOSING
STATEMENT SENATOR GOOD THANK YOU
SO MUCH LIKE THE CONSIDERATION
WALK.
THE MOTION IS DO PASS AS AMENDED
AMENDED AND RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
AGUIAR-CURRY LACKEY.
BLOOM AYE BLOOM AYE BURNER HERVE
RAMOS.
RAMOS SIDE GONZALEZ ROBERT RIVAS
VOEPEL.
AYE VOEPEL AYE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
MEASURE NEEDS TO MORE VOTES WILL
HOLD THAT OPEN.
I SEE SENATOR CABALLERO.
SIR ARE YOU GETTING THE THIRD
STRING UP HERE.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LACKEY -- GETS
BACK HE'LL WILL STEP IN
[inaudible]
NO PROBLEM.
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH -- MISTER CHAIRMAN.
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
AS YOU KNOW THE LEGISLATURE HAS
RECOGNIZED THE NEED FOR FUNDS
AND TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE TO HELP
ALL CALIFORNIANS.
ACCESS SAFE AND RELIABLE TO
DRINKING WATER THIS IS A NEW
ISSUE THAT I'M DEEPLY PASSIONATE
ABOUT.
SB EIGHT FOUR ONE FOUR MAKES
IMMEDIATE AND LASTING GOVERNANCE
REFORM TOO MANY OF THE NEARLY
THREE HUNDRED WATER SYSTEM SAY
STATEWIDE.
THE STATE WATER RESOURCES
CONTROL BOARD HAS IDENTIFIED --
CHRONICALLY FAILED TO SERVE SAFE
DRINKING WATER GENERALLY THE
SYSTEMS LACK THE FINANCIAL
MANAGERIAL AND TECHNICAL
RESOURCES NECESSARY TO ADDRESS
ONGOING CONTAMINATION.
AND INFRASTRUCTURE ISSUES
NECESSARY TO OPERATE HIGH
FUNCTIONING WATER SYSTEMS.
THE VAST MAJORITY OF THESE
SYSTEMS ARE SMALL RURAL.
RURAL SYSTEM SERVING
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES AND
ISOLATED COMMUNITIES WITH NO
WITH NO LARGER SYSTEM NEARBY.
A SUSTAINABLE SOLUTION IS NEEDED
TO ADDRESS AS ONGOING HEALTH AND
SAFETY CRISIS WHILE LAWS HAVE
BEEN PASSED THAT ADDRESS VARIOUS
ELEMENTS OF THE WATER
ACCESSIBILITY ISSUE IMMEDIATE
AND LASTING CHANGES ARE NEEDED
TO ADDRESS THE UNDERLYING ISSUES
OF THE FAILING SYSTEMS.
SB FOUR ONE FOUR CREATES A
MECHANISM TO MERGE THE SMALL NON
COMPLIANT WATER SYSTEMS INTO
LARGER MORE ROBUST PUBLIC WATER
SYSTEMS THAT CAN TAKE ADVANTAGE
OF IMPROVED ECONOMIES OF SCALE.
STREAM STREAMLINED MANAGERIAL
FUNCTIONS ENHANCED FINANCIAL
CAPACITY AND ROBUST PUBLIC
PARTICIPATION.
THIS BILL COMPLIMENTS EXISTING
STATE BOARD CONSOLIDATION
AUTHORITY.
INCLUDING THOSE IMPLEMENTED TO
RATHER BILLS AS WELL AS EFFORTS
CONTEMPLATED BY THE LEGISLATURE
IN SB TWO HUNDRED AND THROUGHOUT
THE BROUGHT THE BUDGET PROCESS
IT ESTABLISHES NEW AUTHORITY FOR
THE WATER BOARD.
AND A POWERFUL TOOL.
SB FOUR ONE FOUR ALSO
INCORPORATES A ROBUST LAUGH CO
PROCESS TO ENSURE NOTICE PUBLIC
HEARINGS TRANSPARENCY AND
COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT.
SOME OF ARGUED THAT THIS PROCESS
IS CUMBERSOME.
BUT IT IS ESSENTIAL TO ALLOWING
RESIDENTS IN MY RURAL
UNDERSERVED AND DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES THE OPPORTUNITIES TO
PARTICIPATE. TO COMMENT AND HAVE
VOTING POWER IN THE NEWLY
CREATED SYSTEMS TO ENSURE THE
LONG TERM SUSTAINABILITY OF THE
NEW SYSTEMS.
WITH ME TO PROVIDE TESTIMONY
TODAY ARE DANIEL COATS OF
EASTERN MUNICIPAL WATER DISTRICT
AND DANIEL BLANCHETTE OF THE
CALIFORNIA MUNICIPAL UTILITIES
ASSOCIATION BILL SPONSORED.
THANK YOU CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE I'M DANIEL COATS
WITH EASTERN MUNICIPAL WATER
DISTRICT OF WATER WASTEWATER AND
RECYCLED WATER COMMITTEE.
ITER TO OVER EIGHT HUNDRED
TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND RESIDENTS
IN WESTERN RIVERSIDE COUNTY.
EASTERN IS PLEASED AND
SUPPORTIVE OF THE INCREDIBLE
PROGRESS MADE BY THE LEGISLATURE
IN THE ADMINISTRATION TOWARDS
ESTABLISHING A LONG TERM FUNDING
SOLUTION.
AND FUNDING IMPLEMENTATION PLAN
TO ENSURE ALL CALIFORNIANS HAVE
ACCESS TO SAFE AND RELIABLE
DRINKING WATER.
WELL THESE SOLUTIONS OFFER
REMARKABLE PROGRESS WE BELIEVE
THERE IS AN ADDITIONAL ELEMENT
THAT IS NEEDED UNDER THROUGH
GOVERNANCE REFORM.
THAT WOULD ENSURE THERE IS A
FULL PORTFOLIO OF SOLUTIONS
AVAILABLE TO ENSURE THAT
SUSTAINABLE AND RELIABLE WATER
SERVICES PROVIDED IN AN
EXPEDITED AND COST EFFECTIVE
MANNER.
IN DEVELOPING AS BEFORE FOURTEEN
WE HAVE MET WITH AND CONSIDERED
AND PUT FROM A VERY FROM A
VARIETY OF STAKE HOLDERS
INCLUDING EXPERT.
FROM MUTUAL AND PRIVATE WATER
COMPANIES LAUGHTER
REPRESENTATIVES PUBLIC WATERS
PROVIDERS ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
ADVOCATES HOWARD JARVIS AND THE
STATE BOARD AMONG AND OTHERS.
THE RESULT IS LEGISLATION THAT
NOT ONLY FACILITATES
REGIONALIZATION OF FAILING WATER
SYSTEMS THROUGH THE FORMATION OF
A SMALL SYSTEM WATER AUTHORITY.
THAT IMPLEMENTS NEEDED
GOVERNANCE REFORMS THROUGH A
LOCAL TRANSPARENT LASKO PROCESS
THAT ENSURES LOCALS INTERESTS
AND COMMUNITY NEEDS ARE
APPROPRIATELY CONSIDERED AND THE
BEST PATH TO MEET THE
COMMUNITIES WATER QUALITY NEEDS
ARE.
ARE ADEQUATELY ASSESSED.
CONDITIONALLY FORMATION WITH
FORTY BENEFITS FROM ENHANCE
STATE AND LOCAL OVERSIGHT
ARGUABLY MORE SO THAN ANY OTHER
AVENUE FOR CONSOLIDATION. TO
ENSURE THAT LONG TERM FINANCIAL
OPERATIONAL VIABILITY OF AND
HIGHER QUALITY WATER IS
DELIVERED.
THIS IS ACCOMPLISHED THROUGH
STATE BOARD MEETINGS AND
OVERSIGHT AT THE LOCAL LEVEL BUT
THE LOCAL LASKO AND ANNUAL
REPORTING AT THE LOCAL LASKO
PUBLIC HEARINGS THROUGH THE LAST
GO PROCESS.
ULTIMATELY THIS EFFORT
TRANSITIONS THE LOCAL MUNICIPAL
SERVICE REVIEW PROCESS
ADDITIONALLY FOLLOWING THE
FORMATION THE STATE
COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE IS REQUIRED
PERFORMANCE FISCAL AN
OPERATIONAL HEALTH ASSESSMENT.
OF EACH AUTHORITY.
AND THE STATE BOARD IS REQUIRED
TO SUBMIT A REPORT TO THE
LEGISLATURE ON THE
CONSOLIDATIONS THAT HAVE TAKEN
PLACE AND ANY OUTSTANDING
REPORTED DRINKING WATER QUALITY
ISSUES.
AS LOCAL PUBLIC AGENCIES THESE
ENTITIES WILL ALSO BE
RESPONSIBLE FOR A VARIETY OF
TRANSPARENCY REQUIREMENTS AND
REPORTING TO STATE AND LOCAL
ENTITIES.
WE BELIEVE THAT THIS TRANSLATES
INTO A BILL THAT WILL ULTIMATELY
AND SURE THOUSANDS OF FAMILIES
WILL RECEIVE PERMANENT ACCESS TO
SAFE AND RELIABLE DRINKING WATER
AND FOR THESE REASONS WE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST DRIVE OUT.
I THINK YOU TURN MEMBERS MY NAME
IS DANIEL BLASTED WITH
CALIFORNIA MUNICIPAL UTILITIES
ASSOCIATION WE ARE PROUD TO BE
CO SPONSORS AND SUPPORTERS OF SB.
FOUR FOURTEEN ON THE
LEGISLATURE'S ACTED ON FINDING A
POLICY PROPOSALS THAT RECOGNIZE
THE IMPORTANCE OF CONSOLIDATION
AS A TOOL TO ENSURE SAFE
DRINKING WATER FOR MANY
COMMUNITIES.
SB FOUR FOURTEEN SIX TO BRIDGE
AN IMPORTANT GAP IN THE STATE'S
CURRENT CONSOLIDATION AUTHORITY
RIGHT NOW THE STATE MUST RELY ON
A RECEIVING AGENCY TO MERGE WITH
THE SYSTEM THAT IS CONSISTENTLY
FAILING TO PROVIDE SAFE DRINKING
WATER.
WHICH CAN BE A CHALLENGE FOR
VARIETY OF REASONS THE PROCESS
AND AS WE FOR FOURTEEN WOULD
INSTEAD ALLOW CHRONICALLY NON
COMPLIANT WATER SYSTEMS TO MERGE
AND BECOME A FUNCTIONAL MORE
ROBUST SYSTEM.
AS A RESULT OF THE BENEFITS
OUTLINED BY THE AUTHORED OR CO
SPONSOR THIS PROCESS OUTLINED IN
SB FOUR FOURTEEN IS
COMPLEMENTARY TO EXISTING
AUTHORITIES RATHER THAN
DUPLICATING OR SUPERSEDING.
EXISTING PROCESSES IF THE STATE
BOARD FINDS OF THE CREATION OF A
SMALL SYSTEM WATER THIRTY IS THE
MOST APPROPRIATE SOLUTION THE
SUBSEQUENT PROCESS IS A COULD
LOCALLY CONTROLLED AND
TRANSPARENT WHICH WE BELIEVE IS
ESSENTIAL TO LONG LASTING GOOD
GOVERNANCE.
WE BELIEVE THE CUSTOMERS CAN AND
SHOULD FULLY PARTICIPATE IN
DECISIONS RELATED TO THE FUTURE
OF THEIR WATER SUPPLY AND IN
THIS SCENARIO CUSTOMERS OF
EXISTING SYSTEMS WOULD HAVE MORE
OF A VOICE.
THAN TRADITIONAL CONSOLIDATIONS
BECAUSE THE BILL REQUIRES THAT
THE INITIAL BOARD OF DIRECTORS
INCLUDED REPRESENTATIVES FROM
EVERY WATER SYSTEM THAT JUST
MERGED INTO THE NEW AUTHORITY.
THIS TOOL IN THE TOOLBOX ALSO
WILL COMPLEMENT NOT CONFLICT
WITH THE PLAN AND ACTIVITIES
OUTLINED IN SB TWO HUNDRED AND
CAN EFFECTIVELY ADDRESS THE
SYSTEMS THAT ARE NOT CLOSE
ENOUGH TO ANOTHER SYSTEM.
TO ANOTHER LARGER SYSTEM TO TO
MERGE SB FOUR FOURTEEN WILL NOT
DELAY EXISTING CONSOLIDATIONS IT
WILL NOT CREATE ORPHANS SYSTEMS
OR DIVERT RESOURCES FROM OTHER
SOLUTIONS BECAUSE THE WATER
BOARD IS TRULY IN THE DRIVER'S
SEAT.
I WANT SELECT THE OPTION THAT IS
MOST APPROPRIATE FOR THE
SITUATION THE TIME IS NOW TO
ADDRESS THESE CHALLENGES FACING
OUR STATE WE APPRECIATE ALL THE
WORK THE LEGISLATURE HAS PUT
INTO THIS ISSUE.
AND WE BELIEVE SB FOUR FOURTEEN
PROVIDE SUSTAINABLE PATH FORWARD
TO HELP ACHIEVE THIS GOAL AND WE
URGE YOUR AYE VOTE.
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT GOOD
AFTERNOON CHRISTIE FOR ON BEHALF
OF THREE VALLEY'S MUNICIPAL
WATER DISTRICT HERE IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
MR TERM MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
PLUGINS OFFICE HERE TODAY ON
BEHALF THE ORANGE COUNTY WATER
DISTRICT AND THE CITY OF
ROSEVILLE SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON BATH A LOSS ON
BEHALF OF THE CUCAMONGA VALLEY
WATER DISTRICT INLAND EMPIRE
UTILITIES AGENCY AND THE SANTA
ANA WATERSHED PROJECT THIRTY IN
SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON CAROLYN JOHNSON
WITH KP PUBLIC AFFAIRS ON BEHALF
OF WESTERN MUNICIPAL WATER
DISTRICT IN SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS EIGHT
THIRTY MILLION ON BEHALF OF MESA
WATER DISTRICT IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON I BE RID OF BUSH
WITH THE SAN DIEGO COUNTY WATER
AUTHORITY IN SUPPORT.
MAX PRAYED CITY OF RIVERSIDE
OFTEN SUPPORT.
CAN BE REDONDO SANTA CLARA
VALLEY WATER DISTRICT AND
SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS -- AFTERNOON FEELS LIKE
MORNING IT'S BEEN ONE OF THOSE
DAYS A CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE PAMELA MILLER
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF LOCAL AGENCY
FORMATION COMMISSIONS.
WANT TO THANK SENATOR CAFIERO
FOR AUTHORING THE BILL AND THE
SPONSORS WE STRONGLY SUPPORT
THIS MEASURE AND THANK YOU FOR
WORKING WITH US SO CLOSELY. TO
ENSURE THE STRONG PUBLIC LAUGH
CO PROCESS STAYS INTACT WITH
THIS THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON READY THOMPSON
WITH METROPOLITAN WATER DISTRICT
OF SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA ALSO IN
SUPPORT.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
WE GOOD AFTERNOON AND THANK YOU
CAN BE SEEN WITH LEADERSHIP
COUNCIL FOR JUSTICE AND
ACCOUNTABILITY -- WE SHARE --
THAT THAT AUTHORS AND THE
SPONSORS CAN DESIRE TO SEE TO
ADDRESS.
SOME OF THAT CAN INTRACTABLE
OBSTACLES IN SMALL COMMUNITIES
IN THERE CAN EFFORTS TO SECURE
SAFE AFFORDABLE DRINKING WATER --
ISN'T AS I'M SURE MANY OF YOU
KNOW I THINK OUR BIGGEST CONCERN
ARE THE WHERE WERE WE THE
REASONS THAT UNFORTUNATELY WE
HAVEN'T BEEN ABLE TO SUPPORT
THIS BILL.
IS THAT WE THINK THAT THE STATE
BOARD CURRENTLY HAS -- THE TOOLS
AND ASSETS IN PLACE TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE'RE ADDRESSING THE SMALL
SYSTEMS THROUGH KIND OF A
COMBINATION OF CONSOLIDATION
AUTHORITY.
BUT ALL TO THE ADMINISTRATOR
AUTHORITY WHICH SB TWO HUNDRED
IMPROVED UPON -- THAT CAN USE
THAT THAT THAT THAT WERE AND IT
WERE BY AN ADMINISTRATOR CAN
WORK WITH A GROUP THING A SERIES
OF SYSTEMS -- AND MANAGE THEM
BRING THEM TOGETHER WE DO -- SEE
POTENTIALLY A ROLE FOR REGIONAL
AUTHORITY -- CA AS THIS BILL
ENVISIONS RECEIVED IS A FAR
DIFFERENT PATH AND WHAT WE ARE
HOPEFUL FOR IS THAT WE CAN
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THAT WITH
THE SPONSORS WITH THE AUTHORED
WITH OTHER STAKEHOLDERS. TO TO
ACTUALLY DETERMINE WHAT THAT
CORRECT PATH IS TO CREATE A
STRONG SUSTAINABLE WATER SYSTEMS
OF ARE GOING.
TO BECOME A KEY KEY ISSUES KEY
CONCERNS WITH THIS IS THE FAIRLY
CUMBERSOME AND PROCESS.
THAT THEY STATED THE THAT
PRESENTATION DISCUSSED ARE
CONCERNED THAT THIS IS
CUMBERSOME AND CAN CREATE NOT
JUST A HUGE AMOUNT OF COST ON
THE PART OF THE STATE -- BUT
ALSO A HUGE A SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT
OF DELAY FOR COMMUNITIES THAT
HAVE BEEN FIGHTING FOR YEARS AND
YEARS AND YEARS FOR SAFE
DRINKING WATER -- AND IN THE END
OF THIS PROCESS COULD BE.
IN THE END AND UNSUCCESSFUL
AFTER DELAY AFTER SIGNIFICANT
AMOUNT OF MONEY ANOTHER GOING TO
ISSUES ON TO RAISE REAL QUICKLY
IS THAT IMPORTANT WE SHARE.
A COMMITMENT TO PUBLIC PROCESS
IN THE IMPORTANCE OF COMMUNITY
MEMBERS HAVING A SAY IN THE FATE
OF THEIR WATER SYSTEM IN THE
WATER DELIVERY -- WE ARE WE HAVE
WORKED VERY VERY HARD WITH
LEGISLATION OVER THE PAST
SEVERAL YEARS TO MAKE SURE THAT
THE STATE'S TOOLS INCLUDE AND
INCORPORATE A VERY STRONG PUBLIC
PROCESS.
THAT MAKE SURE IS THAT MAKES
SURE THAT COMMUNITY RESIDENTS
IMPACTED BY UNSAFE DRINKING
WATER AND WORKING TOWARDS A
DRINKING WATER SOLUTION CAN TAKE
PART IN THE PROCESS -- THROUGH
THE CONSOLIDATION AUTHORITY THE
ADMINISTRATOR AUTHORITY OR
THROUGH OTHER TOOLS AND MEANS.
THANKS SO MUCH.
THANK YOU.
WELCOME.
THANK YOU CHAIR AND MEMBERS
JONATHAN NELSON WITH THE
COMMUNITY WATER CENTER WANT TO
START JUST BY SAYING THANK YOU
TO THE SENATOR FOR SUPPORT OF SB.
TWO HUNDRED AS WELL AS SOME
REMEMBER BLOOM FOR A CO
AUTHORSHIP -- IT'S BEEN AN
EXTRAORDINARY WEEK FOR SAFE
WATER AND ALSO SENATOR MINING IS
IN THE ROOM AND WE COULDN'T HAVE
DONE IT WITHOUT YOU THANK YOU AS
WELL.
I JUST BRIEFLY WANT TO ECHO THE
COMMENTS MADE BY A LEADERSHIP
COUNCIL GIVEN THE PASSAGE OF
THIS SAFE AND AFFORDABLE
DRINKING WATER FIND RATHER THAN
PROCEED -- WITH THE FRAMER
PROPOSED IN THIS LEGISLATION.
WE WOULD PREFER TO WORK WITH THE
STATE WATER BOARD TO IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH PUBLIC
STAKEHOLDERS HAVE THE BOARD
IDENTIFY WHAT CHANGES ADDITIONAL
CHANGES OR MODIFICATIONS MAY BE
NEEDED TO EFFECTUATE
CONSOLIDATIONS.
AT BOTH THE LOCAL AND REGIONAL
LEVEL -- AND WE WOULD LOOK
FORWARD TO PARTICIPATING IN THAT
PROCESS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ARE THERE OTHERS IN
OPPOSITION [inaudible]
GOOD AFTERNOON.
AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS
TELETRACK NUMBER HALF THE WATER
FOUNDATION MUSIC TO ECHO THE
SAME CONCERNS ARE COLLEAGUES IN
OPPOSITION [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MANY OTHERS IN OPPOSITION SAYING
NONE.
OF ANY QUESTIONS OF THE
COMMITTEE.
OKAY WE HAVE A MOTION -- WE DO
HAVE A QUESTION FROM ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BLOOM -- MOSTLY A COMMENT
I ALSO IS GOING TO GIVE A SHOUT
OUT TO A SENATOR MINING THIS HAS
BEEN A PRETTY EXTRAORDINARY --
OF OF A FEW DAYS SO ON ON AN
ISSUE THAT HAS REALLY.
ODD AND ONE OF THE MORE
INTRACTABLE ISSUES AT AND AN
IMPORTANT ISSUES -- THAT THAT
WENT ON RESULTS FOR FOR SEVERAL
YEARS SO WE'RE WE'RE IN A GOOD
PLACE NOW WHERE -- AGREE OR
DISAGREE WITH THE FUNDING SOURCE
WE'VE GOT A FUNDING SOURCE IS
GOING TO GENERATE A HUNDRED AND
THIRTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS A
YEAR -- ROUGHLY AND AND SO I
THINK IT'S WE FIND OURSELVES IN
A VERY ENVIABLE PLACE AND NOW
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT. FIVE THE
THE IMPLEMENTATION PROCESS AND
HOW WE GO ABOUT DOING THAT --
I'M GONNA BE A SUPPORTING THE
THIS BILL TODAY I DO WANT -- TO
A CALL OUT THE THE FACT THAT --
AB ONE THIRTY FOUR ALSO DEALS
WITH THE WITH SOME OF THESE
ISSUES IN A PERFECT WORLD -- WE
WOULD BE HAVING A CONVERSATION
ABOUT HOW TO MOVE BOTH OF THESE
VEHICLES FORWARD IN A IN A WAY
THAT -- COMPLIMENTED ONE ANOTHER
UNFORTUNATELY MINDS ON A TWO
YEAR TRACK NOW SO THINGS ARE A
LITTLE BIT DISCOMBOBULATED AND
AND I REALLY HOPE THAT WERE --
AND CERTAINLY NOT OF BY ANY --
EFFORTS OF YOUR SENATOR BUT I
HOPE THAT WE DON'T ALL GET
BOGGED DOWN -- IN A WAY THAT
MAKES IT TO THE THAT STRETCHES
OUT PERIOD OF TIME WITHIN WHICH
A IMPLEMENTATION REALLY HAPPENS
AND AND GEARS UP AND AND AND AND
MOVES FORWARD BECAUSE THIS
ISSUES ALREADY WAITED TOO LONG.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY OTHER
COMMENTS TO THE COMMITTEE.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM CHAIR
AND I I WON A SECOND YOUR
COMMENT THAT THIS IS.
BEEN TO IT'S BEEN IN IN THE
WINGS WAY TOO LONG -- I THINK
THAT THAT THE CHALLENGE WITH ME
WITH THE OPPOSITION IS THAT
FRANKLY THERE HAS BEEN NO
PROPOSAL THAT SAYS THIS IS A
BETTER WAY TO DO IT -- NUMBER
ONE NUMBER TWO IS -- THIS IS NOT
THE FIRST TIME THAT I'VE WORKED
ON THIS I WORKED ON THIS WHEN I
WAS IN THE ASSEMBLY.
AND THE WHOLE PURPOSE IS TO I'M
AND AND LET ME JUST START OFF BY
SAYING IT. FOR ME TO BE GIVING
MORE THIRTY TO THE WATER BOARD
IS.
IT IT'S IT'S UNIQUE.
BECAUSE GENERALLY SPEAKING A LOT
OF THE THINKS THE WATER BOARD
DOES I GET I DON'T AGREE WITH
BUT THERE IN THE IN THE PRIMARY
POSITION TO BE ABLE TO SAY HERE
ARE THE SYSTEMS.
AND HERE'S THE DATA WE'VE
RECEIVED FROM THEM IN REGARDS TO
WHY WHY THEIR WATER IS NOT
POTABLE AND AND SO THEY HAVE
THIS ABILITY TO GO IN AND AND
AND IDENTIFY THOSE AND SO WE'RE
GIVING THEM THE AUTHORITY
THROUGH THIS -- TO TO START A
PROCESS THAT THEN INVOLVES LAUGH
GO.
ON AND AND LAUGH GOES IMPORTANT
BECAUSE THEY HAVE THE REGIONAL.
THEY HAVE THE THE THE VIEW OF
THE REGION AND WE GIVE THEM THE
AUTHORITY TO MAKE DECISIONS
ABOUT -- HOW LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
WENT WILL INTERACT WITH EACH
OTHER -- AND SO -- I'M I'M.
WE'VE WORKED REALLY HARD AT
TRYING TO STREAMLINE TO MAKE
THIS A MUCH AS MUCH AS EFFICIENT
AS POSSIBLE.
AND IT IS A TOOL IN THE TOOLBOX
THEY CAN USE IT OR NOT AT THEIR
DISCRETION AND IF THERE'S A
BETTER WAY TO GET TO YES QUITE
FRANKLY I'D LIKE TO SEE THEM GET
TO YES.
IN A BETTER WAY BUT WE NEED TO
GIVE THEM THE TOOLS TO BE ABLE
TO LOOK AT CREATING J. P. A.'S
ACROSS THE REGION THAT HAVE.
THE ABILITY TO REALLY START
CLEANING UP THE SMALL WATER
SYSTEM SO -- I REALLY APPRECIATE
THE OPPORTUNITY PERCENT THIS
BILL HERE TODAY AND I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR AS YOU KNOW
FROM COMING FOR LOCAL GOVERNMENT
ANY TOOL THAT WE CAN HELP A
COMMUNITY MOVE FORWARD -- THE
TOOLBOX IS PRETTY IMPORTANT
SOMETIMES IT WAS DRAINED AND NOW
WE GOT A PHILLIP BACK UP RIGHT.
SO I REALLY APPRECIATE BEING
THIS FOR EVERYBODY DESERVES TO
HAVE RELIABLE SAFE DRINKING
WATER.
SO WITH THAT I WILL BE
SUPPORTING YOUR BILL THIS
AFTERNOON AND THE SECRETARY TAKE
THE ROLE.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AND
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS AGUIAR-CURRY
AGUIAR-CURRY I A LACKEY.
BLOOM AYE BLOOM AYE BURNER HER
OF THAT RAMOS RAMOS SAYANGKAN
SALAS ROBERT RIVAS.
ROBERT RIVAS SIGH VOEPEL.
VOEPEL I MEASURES UP FIVE ZERO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
ARE MUCH BEFORE WE MOVE ON TO OF
SENATOR MONNING YOU'RE MORE THAN
WELCOME TO COME SAID IT WE'RE
JUST GOING TO TAKE A COUPLE OF
BILLS.
THEY'RE ON CALL -- ITEM NUMBER
TWO SB THIRTEEN WHITE HOUSE GAVE
CURRENT VOTES [inaudible]
FOR ZERO LACKEY.
BOERNER HORVATH.
GONZALEZ ROBERT RIVAS ROBERT
RIVAS SIDE.
THE BILLS OUT -- FIVE ZERO NEXT
IS ITEM FIVE SB TWO ZERO FIVE
HERTZBERG HIS CURRENT VOTES.
THREE ZERO AGUIAR-CURRY HI
AGUIAR-CURRY I A LACKEY.
WERNER HER VAST.
GONZALEZ ROBERT RIVAS.
ROBERT REVIEW RIVAS I BILLS OUT
[inaudible]
FIVE ZERO OKAY.
A GOOD AFTERNOON WE ARE LOOKING
RIGHT NOW AT ITEM NUMBER FOUR SB
ONE EIGHTY NINE SENATOR MONNING
WELCOME THANK YOU THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR -- MEMBERS I WANT TO
START BY THANKING THE CHAIR AND
HER CONSULTANT FOR YOUR WORK
WITH US IN.
REFINING AND IMPROVING SB -- ONE
EIGHTY NINE SINCE ITS
ESTABLISHMENT IN NINETEEN
SEVENTEEN THE FORT ORD MILITARY
BASE HAS BEEN AN INTEGRAL PART
OF THE MONTEREY BAY REGIONS
ECONOMY.
WHEN THE BASE CLOSED IN NINETEEN
NINETY FOUR THE STATE
LEGISLATURE ESTABLISHED THE
FORWARD REDUCE A THORNY KNOWN AS
FOR A? TO CARRY OUT THE PLANNING
FINANCING AND MANAGEMENT OF THE
FORMER FORT ORD FACILITY AS
DESCRIBED IN THE NINETEEN NINETY
SEVEN RE USE PLAN.
DUE TO AN ECONOMIC RECESSION FOR
STRUGGLE TO EXECUTE THE BASE
REDUCE PLAN.
IN TWENTY TWELVE THE LEGISLATURE
PASSED ASSEMBLY BILL SIXTEEN
FOURTEEN WHICH EXTENDED THE
SUNSET DATE FOR FOR A FROM JUNE
THIRTIETH TWENTY FOURTEEN TO
JUNE THIRTIETH.
TWENTY TWENTY THE BILL ALSO
REQUIRED FOR TO DEVELOP THE
TRANSITION PLAN TO FULFILL ALL
OUTSTANDING OBLIGATIONS.
THE FOUR BOARD HAS APPROVED A
TRANSITION PLAN IN IS CURRENTLY
NEGOTIATING IMPLEMENTING
AGREEMENTS FOR WATER
AUGMENTATION TRANSPORTATION
INFRASTRUCTURE ENVIRONMENTAL
RESTORATION.
CAPITAL IMPROVEMENT PROJECTS
LOCAL FUNDING MECHANISMS TO
SUPPORT THESE ACTIVITIES AND
UNEXPLODED ORDINANCE REMOVAL.
FOREIGN NEEDS TO ADDITIONAL
YEARS TO ALLOW LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS TO IMPLEMENT
ADEQUATE FUNDING MECHANISMS TO
SUPPORT PROJECTS IDENTIFIED IN
THE FOR A TRANSITION PLAN.
AS WELL AS TO ENSURE CONTRACTS
THAT CONTRACTS ARE ESTABLISHED
FOR ALL TRANSITION PLAN
IMPLEMENTING AGREEMENTS.
SB ONE EIGHTY NINE NARROWS THE
JURISDICTIONAL OVERSIGHT OF THE
FOUR OH BOARD AS WELL AS REDUCES
THE NUMBER OF BOARD MEMBERS FROM.
THIRTEEN TO FIVE THE BOARD THE
FOR A TRANSITION PLAN UNTIL JUNE
THIRTIETH TWENTY TWENTY TWO WHEN
THE BOARD WILL SUNSET.
UNDER THIS BILL PROPOSAL.
THIS BILL ENSURES THAT THE
COMMUNITIES IMPACTED BY THE
REDEVELOPMENT OF FOR A HAVE
ADEQUATE FUNDING MECHANISMS TO
ACHIEVE THE REGIONAL ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT THAT WAS PROMISED
WHEN THE AUTHORITY WAS
ESTABLISHED.
WE'RE WORKING HARD TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE PATH FORWARD BENEFITS
THE MONTEREY BAY REGION AS A
WHOLE AND IS CONSISTENT WITH THE
OBJECTIVES OF THE BASE REDUCE
PLAN.
APPROPRIATE TIME I RESPECTFULLY
SECURE AYE VOTE TODAY IN THROUGH
THE CHAIR WOULD LIKE 2%
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT STARTING
WITH PRESIDENT EDUARDO A CHIRLA
PRESIDENT OF CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY AT MONTEREY BAY.
WELCOME MISTER PRESIDENT OF
CHIRLA.
THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS OF I WOULD LIKE TO
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB ONE
EIGHTY NINE CENTER MONIES BILL
TO EXTEND THE AUTHORIZATION. FOR
THE FOUR DOOR REVIEWS OF THORNY.
I BELIEVE THIS BILL IS IN THE
BEST INTERESTS OR UNIVERSITY IN
OF THE COMMUNITIES THAT WE SERVE.
AS MOST OF YOU KNOW CAST A
MONTEREY BAY HAS A UNIQUE
HISTORY FOUNDER A PORTION OF THE
SITE OF THE HISTORIC FORT ORD.
WERE TENS OF THOUSANDS OF OUR
TROOPS WERE TRAINED FOR MUCH OF
THE TWENTIETH CENTURY.
CSU NB WAS THE RESULT OF AN
INTENSE COMMUNITY WIDE EFFORT
BOTH TO MITIGATE THE ECONOMIC
EFFECTS OF THE BASE CLOSURE.
AND TO PROVIDE INCREASED
EDUCATIONAL OPPORTUNITIES TO
PEOPLE IN OUR REGION AND OUR
STATE.
WHEN I CAME TO THE CAMPUS AS
PRESIDENT IN?
TWO THOUSAND TWELVE ASSOCIATION
BEES ONGOING RELATIONSHIP WAS
COMMUNITIES AS ONE OF THE
UNIVERSITIES GREAT ASSETS.
I'M A STRONG BELIEVER IN THE
CONCEPT OF STEWART OF PLACE.
THE IDEA THAT PUBLIC
UNIVERSITIES HAVE AN OBLIGATION
TO BE ACTIVELY INVOLVED THEIR
COMMUNITIES TO HELP THEM ADVANCE
THE ONLY EDUCATIONALLY BUT ALSO
SOCIALLY CULTURALLY AND
ECONOMICALLY.
SYSTEM BE CANNON HAS ACTED AS A
CONVENER AND THOUGHT LEADER IN
HELPING THE MULTIPLE
STAKEHOLDERS IN THE REGION
CHARTER FUTURE FUTURE DIRECTION
ALONG THESE DIMENSIONS.
AS A CUSTODIAN OF THE FOR ARGUES
PLANNED FOR A HAS BEEN A KEY
AGENCY AND HELPING FACILITATE
THOSE CONVERSATIONS.
BEYOND ITS UNIQUE FUNDED HISTORY
CSU IN BE IS AN UNUSUAL CAMPUS
AND OTHER ASPECTS OF WELL.
WE DO NOT EXIST WITHIN A
TRADITIONAL COLLEGE TOWN.
WE SIT ASTRIDE THE CITY LIMITS
OF CAESAR MARINO.
AND ARE BOUNDED BY LAND GOVERNED
BY A NUMBER OF DIFFERENT
JURISDICTIONS.
ALSO UNLIKE MANY OTHER CAMPUSES
IN THIS ISSUE SYSTEM WE HAVE
ROOM TO GROW OUR AND ROMAN
SUBSTANTIALLY. TO HELP OUR STATE
MEET IS WELL DOCUMENTED NEED
FROM COLLEGE GRADUATES.
THAT GROWTH WILL REQUIRE BOTH A
THOROUGH UNDERSTANDING OF ITS
IMPACT ON NATURAL RESOURCES AND
TRAFFIC.
AND A SHARED STRATEGY AMONG
SURROUNDING COMMUNITIES ON HOW
BEST TO MEET THE NEEDS OF A
GROWING COLLEGE CAMPUS.
AND TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THE
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
OPPORTUNITIES IT PRESENTS FOR
ALL OF THEM.
AS PRESIDENT I HAVE TAKEN A
PERSONAL ROLE AND WORKING
DIRECTLY WITH FOR A AN AGENCY
THAT I SEE AS INSTRUMENTAL IN
FORGING THOSE CONNECTIONS.
IN MY EXPERIENCE FOR HAS BEEN
EFFECTIVE IN PROMOTING THE
CONSTRUCTION OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING WHICH IS VITAL BOTH TO
SEIZE HIM BE AND THE LARGER
COMMUNITY.
IT DOESN'T GET ASIAN IMPORTANT
ENVIRONMENTAL MEDICATIONS OF
HELPS PROTECT THE MONTEREY BAY.
IT HAS HELPED FINISH REMOVAL OF
UNEXPLODED MUNITIONS A MORE THAN
THREE THOUSAND ACRES OF THE
FORMER ARMY BASE.
AND HAS HELPED SPEARHEAD EFFORTS
TO REMOVE DILAPIDATED ARMY
STRUCTURES THAT WE'RE BOTH AN
EYESORE AND POTENTIAL SAFETY
HAZARDS.
AND IT HAS DEVELOPED A
TRANSPORTATION INFRASTRUCTURE
WITHIN THE FORMER FORT ORD
NEEDED FOR PLANNED DEVELOPMENT.
WELL FOR HAS BEEN SUCCESSFUL IN
MANY ASPECTS OF MANAGING THESE
TRANSITIONS IS WORK IS NOT
FINISHED.
OUR REGION CONTINUES TO SEEK
WAYS TO GENERATE FINANCING FOR
ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTION
INFRASTRUCTURE AND OTHER CROSS
BOUNDARY CAPITAL NEEDS.
THE NEED TO DEVELOP AFFORDABLE
HOUSING REMAINS IMMENSE.
HABITAT PROTECTION A WELFARE
MITIGATION OR ONGOING CONCERNS.
AND FUTURE CAMPUS GROWTH WILL
REQUIRE US TO FULLY ADDRESS
TRANSIT INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDS ON
A CORE NAY BASIS AS ENVISIONED
IN THE FORT ORD REUSE PLAN.
I BELIEVE FOR REMAINS AN
EXCELLENT FORUM FOR THOSE
DISCUSSIONS AMONG
REPRESENTATIVES OF VARIOUS
JURISDICTIONS.
I WAS PLEASED TO SEE THE MARIE
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS
AGREED IN PASSING A RESOLUTION
SUPPORTING FOR HIS EXTENSION.
DURING THE 200-019-2000 TWENTY
ACADEMIC YEAR CAL STATE MONTEREY
BAY WILL CELEBRATE.
OUR TWENTY FIFTH ANNIVERSARY.
WE HAVE COME A LONG WAY.
WE HAVE MUCH POTENTIAL STILL TO
BE FULFILLED.
I SEE THE EXTENSION OF THE FORD
OR REUSE OF THOR IS AN IMPORTANT
ASSET IN THAT EFFORT.
AND I GREATLY APPRECIATE THE
COLLABORATIVE APPROACH THE
CEREMONY AND HIS STAFF HAVE
TAKEN IN CRAFTING THIS BILL TO
MEET THE DIVERSE NEEDS OF
STAKEHOLDERS IN OUR REGION.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH IN YOUR
OTHER ONE OFF IS A IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS JOSH METS AND I SERVICE THE
FORT ORD RESTORING THE ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT MANAGER.
OUR EXECUTIVE OFFICER MICHAEL
WHO ARE MARTYRS AND WASHINGTON
DC TO ATTEND A FUNERAL AT THE
ARLINGTON NATIONAL CEMETERY AND
HAS ASKED ME TO SPEAK ON HIS
BEHALF.
WE APPRECIATE PRESIDENT OR CHAU
AS COMMENTS AND CONSISTENT
THOUGHTFUL AND DIPLOMATIC
SUPPORT OF THE FOR ENDEAVOR.
INDEED DURING THE SIX YEARS THAT
I'VE WORKED AT FOR A THE
RELATIONSHIP WITH CSU AND BE
ADMINISTRATION FACULTY HAS BEEN
PARTICULARLY CONSTRUCTIVE.
IN PURSUING LONG DREAMED OF
ECONOMIC RECOVERY GOALS
INCLUDING CULTIVATION OF A
THRIVING ENTREPRENEURSHIP
ECOSYSTEM.
ADVANCING ECO TOURISM AND
SUSTAINABLE HOSPITALITY
INITIATIVES.
AND LAUNCHING A NEW REGIONAL
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT STRATEGY
FOCUSED ON DRONES AUTOMATION AND
ROBOTICS TECHNOLOGIES.
NEVER LET THE LESS EVEN WITH ALL
THE PROGRESS TO DATE THERE STILL
REMAINS CRITICAL INFRASTRUCTURE
ENVIRONMENTAL REMEDIATION
CONSERVATION WORK YET TO BE
COMPLETED.
ESPECIALLY FOR THOSE
JURISDICTIONS WHO DEFERRED
REVIEWS ACTIVITIES TO ALLOW MORE
SEVERELY IMPACTED JURISDICTIONS
TO REGAIN STABILITY AND THRIVE.
WHICH BY ALL MEASURE THEY ARE
DOING TODAY. FOR A HAS REVIEWED
THE REVISED ITEMS AND SENATE
BILL.
ONE EIGHTY NINE AND FIND THE
BILL CONSISTENT WITH THE TWENTY
EIGHTEEN TRANSITION PLAN WHICH
WAS ADOPTED BY THE BOARD AND
SB ONE EIGHTY NINE WILL CONTINUE
THE STABILITY THAT HAS SERVED
THE MONTEREY BAY REGION SINCE
NINETEEN NINETY FOUR BY
OVERSEEING THE TWENTY EIGHT
THOUSAND ACRE FORTY FIVE SQUARE
MILE RECOVERY FROM THE US ARMY'S.
BASE CLOSURE CONTINUE THE
COMMUNITY FACILITY DISTRICT
FINANCING THAT FUNDS HABITAT
CONSERVATION.
WILD FIRE PROTECTION
TRANSPORTATION TRANSIT AND WATER
AUGMENTATION.
PROVIDE PLANNING STABILITY FOR
THE SEVERAL LARGE SCALE MID
COURSE DEVELOPMENT PROJECTS
MAINTAIN CONSISTENCY WITH THE
BASE REUSE PLAN REGIONAL GOALS
OF EDUCATIONALLY BASED ECONOMIC
RECOVERY.
SUPPORTED BY A PRIVATE SECTOR
DEVELOPMENT AND ENVIRONMENTAL
CONSERVATION.
SUSTAIN THE SUPPORT OF BASS
REVIEWS INFRASTRUCTURE PROGRAMS
THAT ASSIST THE FORMER FORT ORD
WORK OF CALIFORNIA STATE PARKS
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
VETERANS AFFAIRS CSU AND BE AND
THE CALIFORNIA FISH AND WILDLIFE.
AND FINALLY ASSURE THE ACTIVE
BUILDING REAM REMOVAL
DECONSTRUCTION PROGRAM THROUGH
OVERSIGHT OF BOND ISSUANCE AND
OTHER RESOURCES.
SENATOR MORNINGS EFFORTS TO
SUSTAIN THE REGIONAL RECOVERY
FROM THE CLOSURE FORT ORD ARE
GREATLY APPRECIATED.
WE ALSO APPRECIATE THE ASSEMBLY
IS ONGOING CONSIDERATION OF FORT
ORD AND OTHER STATE WIDE BASE
CLOSURE RECOVERY WORK.
AT THANK YOU AGAIN FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO DELIVER THESE
COMMENTS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM CHAIR --
WITH YOUR PERMISSION PRESIDENT
OF THE MONEY COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS JUDGE PHILLIPS IS
WITH THIS FOR A BRIEF COMMENT
WITH YOUR INDULGENCE I WOULD BE
MORE THAN HAPPY TO WELCOME.
THANK YOU THANK YOU I APPRECIATE
IT.
OUR COUNTY IS A WELL WE WE ASKED
THE SENATOR TO CARRY THIS
LEGISLATION APPRECIATE HIM DOING
IT AND AND ASSEMBLYMAN RIVAS BUT
UP.
THE FORD AWARD -- SEEMS LIKE A
GREAT THING WE GOT. FORTY FIVE
SQUARE MILES IN TWENTY EIGHT
THOUSAND ACRES BUT IT WAS A FULL
OF UNEXPLODED MUNITIONS HAZARD
MATERIALS DILAPIDATED BUILDINGS.
AND YEAH HAD MULTIPLE
JURISDICTIONS TO HAVE TO WORK ON
THIS THE CITIES THE COUNTY IS
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT I'VE BEEN
BACK COMMON AMONG THE FOUR BOARD
AS WELL AS AS WELL AS BEING THE
CHAIR OF THE BOARD.
AND WE WENT BACK A NUMBER TIMES
WORKING WITH THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT AND SO.
IT'S JUST WE GOT TOO MANY THINGS
THAT HAVEN'T BEEN SETTLED UP YET
IN THE COUNTY IS VERY VERY
CONCERNED THAT WE'RE GOING TO
END UP WITH A LOT OF OBLIGATIONS
THAT WE JUST DON'T HAVE THE
FISCAL.
RESOURCES TO DEAL WITH WHEN THIS.
ANSWER IS ONE EXAMPLE -- ON THE
BARRACKS THAT WAS IN ROUGH SHAPE
WHEN I WAS STATIONED AT FORT ORD
IN NINETEEN SIXTY FIVE IS STILL.
STANDING THERE READY TO BE.
A TORN DOWN A SHORT ISSUE SHARE
THAT STORY WITH THE WEATHER SO
WE APPRECIATE ALL THE WORK THAT
SENATOR MINING AND AND MISTER
REVISIT ON FORTUNE THANK YOU FOR
HEARING MASS.
HERE VERY WELCOME OTHERS IN
SUPPORT.
ROOM BOARD MEMBERS -- JOHN GET
REALITY CITY COUNCIL MEMBER ALSO
FOR BOARD MEMBER -- FOR DEL REY
OAKS -- WE ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT
IN FACTORIALS NEEDS THE THE
EXTENSION OF THIS -- IN ORDER
FOR US TO REALIZE OUR OUR
HOUSING OR ARE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING GOALS AND SO WE ARE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AS BI<c.cyan> AT</c>
EXTENSION TO OF THE CFD RIGHT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY OTHERS
IN SUPPORT.
SING NONE ANY IN OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
WELCOME [inaudible]
GOOD AFTERNOON.
DO YOU YOU CAN HAVE TO APPEAR IF
THEY DON'T WANT TO SPEAK THE
RECIPE FOR ME TO USE
[inaudible]
RED.
AND CHAIRED AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE.
MY NAME IS CRAIG MAILING ON THE
CITY MANAGER OF THE CITY OF SHE
THOUGHT.
I AM HERE -- TO TELL YOU THAT
THE BILL OF UNNECESSARY IN
HARMFUL.
IT IS LITERALLY UNNECESSARY AS
FOR BOARD HAS APPROVED THE
TRANSITION PLAN.
I FOR CLOSE TODAY THERE'S NOT
ONE SINGLE TASK THAT'S NECESSARY
THAT WOULD GO ON DON'T NOT WANT.
FINALLY UNNECESSARY TERM FULL.
SHE SAID AS LABOR UNDER THE YOKE
OF FOR FOR MORE THAN TWENTY
YEARS.
AND BLAKE STILL REMAINS -- THIS
THE LINGERING BLAKE STOPS THE
FIGHT FROM BEING SUCCESSFUL.
AS I SIT HERE TODAY WE HAVE FIVE
HUNDRED THIRTY FOUR HOMELESS
STUDENTS AND 24% OF OUR HIGH
SCHOOL STUDENTS ARE ECONOMICALLY
DISADVANTAGED CITY OFFICIALS
READY WILLING AND ABLE. TO HELP
SOLVE THAT PROBLEM BY.
APPROVING.
AND SUPPORTING HUNDREDS OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING UNITS BUT THE
EXTENSION OF FOUR WILL NOT ONLY
HELP WILL NOT HELP IT WILL ONLY
HURT.
THE PRIMARY PURPOSE OF THIS BILL.
IS TO DIVERT MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
FROM SEASIDE TO OTHER
JURISDICTIONS MAKE NO MISTAKE
THAT IS THE PRIMARY PURPOSE OF
THIS BILL. TO DIVERT MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS FROM SEASIDE TO OTHER
JURISDICTIONS.
NOT ONE ELECTED OFFICIAL FROM
SEASIDE OR MARINA.
IS IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL NOT.
ONE THE SUN THE SIX VOTED FOR
BOARD.
EXPRESSING SUPPORT FOR EARLIER
VERSION OF THIS BILL DOES NOT
INCLUDE ANY REPRESENTATIVE OF C.
SIDE A MARINA IN THE COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVE THAT REPRESENTS.
THE FOR ERIN ALSO DID NOT.
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THIS BILL IS EFFECTIVELY
TAXATION WITHOUT REPRESENTATION
IT'S UNNECESSARY IT'S HARMFUL ON
BEHALF OF SEASIDE SINCE AND
DESERVE AT LONG LAST TO HAVE A
FULLY IMPORTS.
CITY.
HOPING THEM -- MEET THE NEEDS OF
THIS CENTURY NOT THE LAST
CENTURY I WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK
THE COMMITTEE TO STOP THIS BILL
RIGHT NOW.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WELCOME.
THANK YOU CHAIR MY NAME'S LANE
LONG AND THE CITY MANAGER REINA
ADJACENT TO SEASIDE.
HI WE APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO SPEAK IN WE ARE REALIZE THIS
IS TOUGH FOR US BECAUSE WE ARE
POSING.
CENTER MONEY NISSIM WOMEN STONE
WHO'VE DONE INCREDIBLE WORK FOR
OUR REGION -- AND SEE IT SHOULD
BE BUT THIS BILL IS CRAIG TALKED
ABOUT ABSOLUTELY IS DEVASTATING
FOR CITIES.
I'D LIKE TO GIVE A DIFFERENT
PERSPECTIVE FROM THE COMMUNITIES
WHO ARE MOST IMPACTED.
BY THIS DECISION WE LIVE DAY
TODAY WITH THE REALITIES OF THE
X. EXISTENCE OF 475% OF THE LAND
TO BE DEVELOPED IS HE IN OUR TO
COMMUNITIES IT'S NOT IN THE
COUNTY IT'S NOT IN.
HOW ALL THESE ADJACENT AREAS
IT'S IN OUR COMMUNITIES AND WE
LIVE WITH THE DAY TO DAY? TWENTY
FIVE YEARS AGO FOR WAS A GREAT
IDEA HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS WERE PLANNED. TO BE
GENERATED FOR THESE MASSIVE ROAD
PROJECTS MASSIVE HABITAT
CONSERVATION PROJECT MASSIVE
WATER INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECT
HUGE SINGLE FAMILY HOME SAID
TURN.
THE CLOSURE FORD OF THE FORMER
FORWARD INTO THE JEWEL OF
MONTEREY PENINSULA TWENTY FIVE
YEARS LATER.
IT'S CLEAR THE PLAN IS DEEPLY
FLAWED IN THE PICTURES SHOW WAY
IS DEEPLY FLAWED.
THIS MASSIVE CAPITAL IMPROVEMENT
PROGRAM CAN NEVER BE FUNDED --
THE FUNDING WILL NEVER BE THERE
UNTIL SO THE SOLUTION HAS ALWAYS
BEEN IN TWENTY FOURTEEN LET'S
KICK THE CAN DOWN THE ROAD LET'S
EXTEND FOR AGAIN AND SO THE
SOLUTION ONCE AGAIN.
LET'S EXTEND FOR TWO MORE YEARS.
WELL SB ONE EIGHTY NINE
ELIMINATES MANY OF THE PROBLEM
ELEMENTS OF THE BASE FOR USE
PLAN.
IF FOUR IS ALLOWED TO SUNSET IN
TWENTY TWENTY ALL OF THE
PROBLEMS WILL BE ELIMINATED AND
THEY WILL GO AWAY AND READ IT
AND SEE SIDE WILL HAVE THE TOOLS.
TO DO THE REDEVELOPMENT THAT WE
NEED TO DO.
AS STATED THEIR OPPOSITION
LETTER ALL THE REGIONAL AGENCIES
ARE IN PLACE AND HAVE SAID THAT
THEY'RE FULLY ABLE TICKLE THEIR
REGIONAL RESPONSIBILITIES.
TRANSPORTATION AGENCY MONTEREY
COUNTY THEY CAN TAKE OVER THE
ROAD TO ME IMMEDIATELY RATED
COAST WATER DISTRICT THEY'LL
TAKE OVER ALL THE WATER
INFRASTRUCTURE SEE CITED SAID
THEY'LL TAKE OVER ALL THE
MUNITIONS REMOVAL LAUGH CO HAS
SAID THEY ARE IN PLACE TWENTY
TWENTY THEY'LL BE READY TO GO --
HABITAT WE NEED TO WORK OUT BUT
WE DON'T NEED AN EXTENSION A TWO
YEARS PRESS TO FIGURE OUT HOW WE
WANNA FORMER JP OR SOME OTHER --
OR ORGANIZATION TO OVERSEE THE
HABITAT EXTENDED FOR TWO MORE
YEARS.
SIMPLY EXTENDS THE FUNDING OF
PRIORITIES OF CARMEL PACIFIC
GROVE MONTEREY MONTEREY COUNTY
DEL RIO OAKS THE WEALTHY
COMMUNITIES OF THE AREA.
AND THEY DIVERTED FROM THE
PRIORITIES OF SEASIDE IMERINA.
THAT THE PICTURES THAT YOU SHOW
THEIR THERE'S SIX HUNDRED THIRTY
THREE REMAIN IN BLIGHTED
STRUCTURES FIVE HUNDRED EIGHTY
EIGHT OF THOSE ARE IN OUR
COMMUNITY THE SURROUND OUR HIGH
SCHOOL.
THE SURROUND OUR MAIN INTEREST
FOR CITIES THE STRONGER PARKS
THESE AROUND OUR NEIGHBORHOOD
HOMES.
THEY'RE FULL OF LEAD THEY'RE
FULL OF ASBESTOS HOMELESS LIVE
IN THEM.
DOESN'T SEEM MATTER THE EFFECT
OF HOMELESS PEOPLE ON THOSE ARE
SCHOOL KIDS THEY PLAN THEM THEY
TAKE DRUGS TO THEM THEY DO ALL
SORTS OF THINGS THOSE HOMES.
AND THERE'S NO PLAN FROM TO GO
AWAY.
IN TWENTY SIXTEEN THE SITTER
MARINA TOOK OUT AT THIRTY SIX
MILLION DOLLAR INTEREST ONLY
LOAN PURCHASE PRESTON PARK FROM
FOR A AND LAND SO DOLLARS PARTY
IS TO GO -- TO BLIGHT REMOVAL ED
THAT THIRTY SIX MILLION DOLLARS.
ZERO OF THE FIVE HUNDRED EIGHTY
EIGHT HOMES IN MARINO RICK WERE
REMOVED THIRTY SIX MILLION
DOLLARS. ZERO HOMES REMOVED THAT
SHOWS YOU WHERE THE PLAYER
PRIORITY OF THE FOUR BOARD.
IS GOING IT'S NOT INTO THE BIKE
REMOVAL AND IT'S CERTAINLY NOT
INTO. TO THE PARTIES OUR
COMMUNITY OUR PRIORITIES ARE WE
HAVE EXISTING ROADS AND
INFRASTRUCTURE THERE ARE FALLING
APART.
WE HAVE PARKS WE HAVE EXISTING.
STRUCTURES THAT NEED TO BE
REHABILITATED.
THEY GIVE THE EXAMPLE THERE'S A
OLD POOL BUILDING FROM THE ARMY
INDOOR POOL TWENTY FIVE YEARS
OLD.
VACANT FALLING APART.
WE HAVE FEASIBILITY STUDIES TO
RENOVATE THE BUILDING -- TURNED
INTO AN AQUATIC CENTER THAT THE
BOMB RIPPED PENINSULA UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT CAN USE FOR
COMPETITIVE SWIMMING.
THE VETERANS TRANSITION CENTER
OUR LOCAL COMMUNITIES CAN USE.
BUT THERE'S NO FUNDING IN A
COUPLE YEARS THAT STRUCTURE WILL
FALL AWAY WE HAVE AN EXISTING
STRUCTURE IN EXISTING POOL.
AT BUT THE MONEY'S NEVER COME TO
PRODUCE LIKE THIS WE HAVE
FOURTEEN ACRES A PARK RIGHT NEXT
TO THAT.
COVERED THE BLIGHTED HOMES.
WE HAVE.
A LOCAL GROUP THAT WANTS TO
BUILD AN ALL INCLUSIVE
PLAYGROUND WHICH IS A DISABLED
PLAYGROUND THE LARGEST IN
CALIFORNIA PROBABLY THE LARGEST
IN THE WESTERN REGION.
THEY WANT TO BUILD IT THERE IT'S
A J. SENT TO THE POLE ADJACENT
TO THE BEACH HI MOM.
BUT WE HAVE THESE BLIGHTED HOMES
WE HAVE NO ABILITY TO PUT.
MONIES INTO THE PRIORITIES THE
IMPORTANT TO OUR COMMUNITIES HOW
WE HAVEN'T ARTS VILLAGE WE HAVE
TWO QUARTER MILE LONG WAREHOUSES
IN A MASON ARTS VILLAGE PLAN TO
BRING IN ARTISTS FROM AROUND THE
WORLD WE'VE TALKED WITH.
A LOT OF PEOPLE GET MOVING
FORWARD THOSE STRUCTURES IN A
COUPLE YEARS WILL BE GONE IF WE
DON'T DIVERT MILLION CENTER.
REHABILITATING THEM AND SO
REALLY WHAT IT GETS DOWN TO IS
PRIORITIES.
THE FOUR BOARD IN THE REGION HAS
ITS PRIORITIES FOR THE REGIONAL
ROADS IN THESE MASSIVE HABITAT
PROJECTS.
ON OUR COMMITTEES CONTINUE TO
FAIL AND FALL APART OUR ROADS
FALL APART.
AND WE WOULD ASK THAT
[inaudible]
YOU NOT.
SB ONE EIGHTY NINE IT REALLY OF
TEXAS -- IF YOU ALLOW FOR TO
SUNSET IN.
TWENTY TWENTY I CAN GUARANTEE A
YOU'LL SEE A TRANSFORMATION
START KERR.
IN OUR COMMUNITIES A MARINE IN
SEASIDE WE WILL HAVE THE
RESOURCES AND THE REVENUE AND
THE FUNDS WILL RECONSTRUCT TO
MAKE A DIFFERENCE.
IN OUR POOR COMMUNITIES THAT
WILL TRANSFORM THE REGION.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ARE THERE OTHERS IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE ARE THERE ANY
QUESTIONS OF THE COMMITTEE
[inaudible]
OUR COMMENTS.
OKAY WE HAVE A MOTION -- WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND I JUST WANT TO
THANK YOU IN THE COMMITTEE FOR
YOUR INDULGENCE IN.
ALLOWING US TO PRESENT -- SENATE
BILL ONE EIGHTY NINE IN MY
CLOTHES IF I COULD JUST OFFER A
COUPLE OF RESPONSES.
I WANT TO THANK ALL THE
STAKEHOLDERS WHO ARE HERE TODAY.
I KNOW WE'RE IN DISAGREEMENT
WITH THE TO THE LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS A MARINE IN
SEASIDE AS WAS POINTED OUT.
ON BY THE WITNESS THE COUNCIL
MEMBER FROM DEL REY OAKS THERE'S
BEEN A LITTLE BIT OF A I WOULD
SAY IN IMBALANCE IN HOUSE SOME
OF THE DEVELOPMENT OPPORTUNITIES
HAVE PROCEEDED.
A LOT OF THE HOUSING HAS BEEN.
BUILT IN MARINA -- HOTELS
BUSINESS PARK IT CETERA OM WE
HAVE A REGIONAL RESPONSIBILITY
AND I WOULD REASSURE THE CITIES
OF SEASIDE IMERINA.
THAT THERE IS NOTHING IN SENATE
BILL ONE EIGHTY NINE BEFORE YOU
TODAY THAT PREVENTS THEM FROM
MOVING FORWARD.
ON THEIR OWN BREAKING TIES WITH
FOR A ANNA.
THEY SECURE THEIR FUNDING
MECHANISMS THEY ARE FREE TO MOVE
FORWARD -- AND PURSUE THEIR SELF
DETERMINATION.
AS A SENATOR REPRESENTING THE
AREA AS ASSEMBLY MEMBER RIVAS
KNOWS IN AS THE OTHERS WHO
TESTIFIED IN FAVOR.
THIS IS A REGIONAL RESOURCE AND
SOME SAY WE CAN WALK AWAY FROM
THIS TOMORROW.
WE HAVEN'T HAD THE FULL
COOPERATION OF ALL REGIONAL
ENTITIES LAUGH GO HAS A
RESPONSIBILITY TO OVERSEE THIS
TRANSITION THEY'RE SEEKING
INDEMNIFICATION AND PROTECTION
THEY WANT TO MAKE SURE ALL
CURRENT OBLIGATIONS ARE FULLY
ASSIGNED.
YOU GET ALL THE JURISDICTIONS IN
THEIR LAWYERS TOGETHER.
AS A LAWYER MYSELF I KNOW WHAT
LAWYERS DO WHEN THEY GET CLOSE
ROOMS TOGETHER.
EVERYONE HAS A DIFFERENT
APPROACH TO HOW THINGS SHOULD BE
SOLVED SO WE BELIEVE THAT THIS
THREAD A NEEDLE OF CREATING AN
ONGOING GLIDE PATH FOR THE
DISSOLUTION OF FOR A CONSISTENT.
WITH THE DISSOLUTION PLAN
APPROVED BY THE FOR A BOARD IN
WOULD ASK FOR YOUR COMMITTEES
SUPPORT IN FOR AN AYE VOTE THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SENATOR --
THESE ARE TOUGH ONES.
I'VE BEEN THERE DONE THAT WE'VE
HAD A COUPLE OF FACILITIES WE'VE
HAD TO A PARTICULAR ONE IN MY
DISTRICT.
THERE'S SO MANY PIECES TO THIS
YOU KNOW YOU HAVE SO MANY
AGENCIES OF DIFFERENT GROUPS
INVOLVED.
THEY'RE JUST REALLY REALLY
DIFFICULT AND YOU KNOW IF YOU
GOT THE MAGIC WAND AND JUST TO
HIT IT JUST SAY.
EVERYTHING EVERYTHING GET WHAT
THEY WANT THIS DOESN'T HAPPEN
THAT WAY YOU KNOW YOU GOT
ENVIRONMENTAL ISSUES GOT THE
HOUSING ISSUES YOU'VE GOT OLD
BUILDINGS YOU GOT.
AS BEST AS I MEAN BEEN THERE
DONE THIS IT'S NOT FUN AND IT'S
DIFFICULT.
AND SO -- I UNDERSTAND THAT
YOU'VE BEEN WORKING HARD TO TRY
TO MAKE A COMPROMISE I'VE HAD
CONVERSATIONS WITH --
ASSEMBLYMEMBER STONE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RIVAS TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND YOUR ISSUES IN YOUR
AREA.
MY HEART GOES OUT TO I KNOW HOW
TO BE WANTS TO GET THIS DONE
IMMEDIATELY IT'S UNFORTUNATE
TAKE SO LONG.
SO I'LL BE SUPPORTING THIS TODAY
TO CLARIFY THE WIND DOWN OF
FLORA AND GIVE THE AGENCY IS
MEMBERS A LITTLE MORE TIME TO
COMPLETE THAT WIND DOWN IT TAKES
TIME AND I KNOW.
PATIENCE IS ONE OF THE HARDEST
THINGS -- I HAVE A LITTLE
COMMUNITY IN WINTERS CALIFORNIA
THE MY PATIENTS ALMOST ONE OUT
AND NOW IT'S FLOURISHING AND IT
TOOK SOME TIME BUT WITH GOOD
PLANNING -- YOU CAN MAKE CHANGE
EXACTLY WHAT YOU'RE GOING TO
WANT SO -- WITH THAT I'M A
SECRETARY TO TAKE THE ROLE.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AND
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS AGUIAR-CURRY
AGUIAR-CURRY AYE LACKEY BLOOM
[inaudible]
BOERNER HORVATH BOERNER HORVATH
I RAMOS GONZALEZ ROBERT RIVAS
ROBERT RIVAS I VOEPEL.
VOEPEL HI.
WE NEED ONE MORE FOR THE BILL TO
GET OUT -- WILL PUT ON CALL
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR THANK YOU
MEMBERS AND I THANK YOU ALL FOR
COMING UP IN TROUBLING THANK YOU
SO MUCH [inaudible]
GOOD JOB.
ITEM NUMBER ONE SB FIVE SENATOR
BILL [inaudible]
I REFORM -- BUT AGAIN.
SENATOR BILL YOU SURE YOU WANT
THAT GUIDE YOU LEFT THE NORTH.
IS A GOOD.
OKAY WELCOME WELL THANK YOU -- I
WANT TO SAY THAT MY MOM AND DAD --
BEFORE THEY GOT MARRIED WENT TO
DANCES AT FORT ORD.
SO.
SHE'S FROM HOLLISTER.
HE'S FROM LOS GATOS OF THESE THE
FOR THEY GOT MARRIED THEY WENT
WITH OTHER FRIENDS DOWN THERE SO.
IT'S GOT GOOD MEMORIES THERE.
SO GOOD AFTERNOON -- MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS AND PRESIDING SB
FIVE TODAY.
THIS IS -- PART OF A PACKAGE OF
BILLS THAT CENTER MCGUIRE AND I
HAVE WITH CENTER PORTANTINO.
AND THE PACKAGE IS BASED ON
INPUT GATHERED THROUGH A SERIES
OF PUBLIC HEARINGS WE CONVENE.
ROUTE THE STATE THIS FALL WE
WENT AROUND WE DID A TOUR OF THE
STATE WE LISTENED AND HEARD A
LOT OF CRITICISM.
BUT WE DECIDED WE CAN PULL
SOMETHING TOGETHER HERE AND
THAT'S WHERE WE CAME UP WITH SB.
FIVE HOUSINGS CRISIS IS
STAGGERING AND SINCE NINETEEN
EIGHTIES.
WE HAVE BEEN PRODUCED THAT EIGHT
HUNDRED EIGHTY THOUSAND
NECESSARY NEW HOUSING UNITS PER
YEAR.
NOW AS RESULT OF NEARLY A
HUNDRED THIRTY THOUSAND MEN
WOMEN AND CHILDREN.
IN CALIFORNIA LIVED IN OUR
STREETS LAST YEAR.
THERE IS OFTEN A MISCONCEPTION
ABOUT.
WHO WE ARE TALKING ABOUT WHEN
WE'D SAY HOMELESS AND?
YOU KNOW WE KNOW NOW THAT IT'S
COLLEGE STUDENTS WORKING
FAMILIES OUR NEIGHBORS ARE BEING
PUSHED DOWN THE HOMELESSNESS
BECAUSE THEY CAN'T AFFORD RANTS.
AND THIS YEAR'S BUDGET WE TOOK
SOME BIG STEPS AND INCLUDE A
HISTORIC ONE TIME.
INVESTMENTS TO HELP SHELTER
THOSE ON OUR CITY STREETS AND
PROVIDE SIGNIFICANT FUNDS. TO
GET A LOCAL GOVERNMENT.
INVOLVED IN COMPLIANCE WITH
THEIR HOUSING ELEMENTS BUT IT
FAILS TO ADDRESS THE ROOT CAUSE
OF OUR HOMELESSNESS PROGRAM
WHICH IS THE LACK OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING UNITS -- IN CALIFORNIA
WE HAVE TWO POINT TWO MILLION.
OF THE CATEGORY OF EXTREMELY LOW
INCOME AND VERY LOW INCOME
RENTER HOUSEHOLDS AND THEIR
COMPUTING ACTUALLY FIRST.
SIX HUNDRED SIXTY FOUR THOUSAND
AFFORDABLE HOUSING UNITS SO THAT
LEAVES -- OF SHORTAGE.
OF ONE POINT FIVE FOUR MILLION
CALIFORNIANS OF LOWEST INCOME
HOUSEHOLDS THAT'S HOUSEHOLDS NOT
PEOPLE.
WITHOUT ACCESS TO HOUSING AND
THE RISK OF BECOMING HOMELESS
AND CITIES LIKE SO LOS ANGELES
FOR EXAMPLE BECAUSE DESPITE THE
BEST INTENTIONS THAT PASSED THE
BOND ELECTION THE THEIR KEEP.
THEY KEEP WORLD STRUGGLING.
TO KEEP UP WITH THE EVER GROWING
PRODUCTION NEEDS TO KEEP WROTE
THE RENT BURDEN VERY AND VERY
LOW INCOME FAMILIES OFF THE
STREETS AND THEY'RE NOT.
THEY'RE FALLING BEHIND. SIX OF
THE TRUTH -- FALLING BEHIND.
AND MARKET RATE HOUSING IS PART
OF THE SOLUTION OF COURSE BUT
WITHOUT DELIBERATE INVESTMENTS.
IN AFFORDABLE HOUSING IT
CONTRIBUTES TO THE RISING COST
OF RENTS.
AND THAT'S WHY THE STATE NEEDS
TO INVEST ONGOING FUNDS. TO
BUILD AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
NOW SB FIVE DOES A CREATES A
LONG TERM FINANCIAL PARTNER TO
IMMEDIATELY CONSTRUCT.
DESPERATELY NEEDED HOUSING. FOR
HARD WORKING CALIFORNIANS AND
COMPLIMENTS THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET.
AND OUR LATE -- TWENTY NINETEEN
INVEST WE JUST DID.
THE BILL CREATES -- EIGHTY SIX
THOUSAND NEW AND REHABILITATED
HOUSING UNITS.
IT HELPS ALLEVIATE POVERTY
CREATES JOBS NEEDS ARE STATEWIDE
ENVIRONMENTAL GOALS WITHOUT
AFFECTING SCHOOL FUNDING.
AND SPECIFICALLY -- SB FIVE
ALLOWS LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO
COLLABORATE ON A STATE APPROVED
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT PLANS.
WHICH WILL BE FUNDED BY REDUCING
THEIR CONTRIBUTION.
AND EDUCATION REVENUE
AUGMENTATION FUNDS.
EMPHASIS WILL BE PAID IT TO THE
DEVELOPMENT OF HOUSING FOR VERY
LOW LOW AND MODERATE INCOME
FAMILIES AS WELL AS TRANSIT
ORIENTED.
PRIORITY PROJECTS ADDITIONALLY
INFILL DEVELOPMENT AND PROJECTS
THAT MEDICAID.
MITIGATE DEFECTIVE SEALEVEL RISE
IN CLIMATE CHANGE OR ALSO
PRIORITIZE -- SB FIVE CREATES A
A CAP.
ON THE FUNDING AVAILABLE AT TWO
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS ANNUALLY
BEGINNING IN TWENTY TWENTY AND
TWO HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION.
ANNUALLY AFTER THAT IN
202-020-2020.
FIVE AFTER THE PROGRAM IS RAMPED
UP OR A TEN YEAR PERIOD IT
CANNOT EXCEED THE TENT TWO
BILLION DOLLARS ANNUALLY.
THE STATE GENERAL FUNDS WILL YOU
WILL BE USED TO BACK FILL THE
PROPERTY TAX -- SCHOOL FUNDS
ACCORDING TO THE LA -- REPORT
THE BILL HAD NO IMPACT ON SPENT
ON SCHOOL FUNDING.
THE LEGISLATURE CAN SUSPEND NEW
PLANS DURING THE FISCAL
DOWNTURNS THE BILL ALIGNS WITH
OTHER STATE AND FEDERAL PROGRAMS
TO ENSURE.
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS LEVERAGE
ADDITIONAL NON STATE GENERAL
FUNDS.
AND THE LEGISLATURE CONSTRAINTS.
STRONG ACCOUNTABILITY PROVISIONS
TO ENSURE FUNDS ARE ONLY SPENT
ON THE DESIGNATED PROJECTS AND
TO PROTECT THE SCHOOL FUNDING.
THE BILL CAN CREATE A STATE
COMMITTEE.
A HOUSE UNDER THE HOUSING
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT DEPARTMENT.
TO REVIEW AND APPROVE PROPOSED
PLANS PROVIDING STRONG STATE
OVERSIGHT.
THE COMMITTEE IS THIS COMMITTEE
IS EMPOWERED TO TAKE CORRECTIVE
ACTION.
WHEN LOCALS DID NOT MEET THEIR
PLAN OBJECTIVES THIS IS
SUPPORTED BY A LARGE COALITION?
OF BUSINESS LABOR LOCAL
GOVERNMENT HOUSING ADVOCATES AND
COMMUNITY LEADERS -- WILL TURN
IT OVER WITNESSES RDS FROM THE
BUILDING CONSTRUCTION TRADES
COUNCIL AND MAYOR JOHN DUNBAR
FROM A YOUNG BILL.
AND WE'LL TURN OVER.
JOHN WAS OVER GO AHEAD.
GONNA GO FIRST.
THANK YOU WELCOME.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS I'M JOHN
DUNBAR MAYOR OF THE TOWN OF YOU
DON'T FILL.
I'M ALSO HERE TODAY IS THE
SECOND VICE PRESIDENT OF THE
LEAGUE OF CALIFORNIA CITIES.
AND I WANT TO EXPRESS THE
LEAGUES AND MY SUPPORT FOR
SENATE BILL.
FIVE I COMMEND THE GOVERNOR'S
LEADERSHIP TO INSPIRE HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT ALL INCOME LEVELS.
I APPLAUD HIS COMMITMENT TO
SUPPORT LOCAL GOVERNMENT.
WITH SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENT IN
THE BUDGET.
WHICH CALL FOR MORE THAN TWO
BILLION DOLLARS FOR HOUSING AND
HOMELESSNESS HOWEVER.
THESE FUNDS LARGELY ARE ONE TIME
REVENUES.
SB FIVE WOULD COMPLEMENT THE
BUDGET ALLOCATIONS BY CREATING
AN ONGOING FUNDING PARTNERSHIP.
BETWEEN THE STATE AND CALIFORNIA
CITIES.
THE JUMPSTART THE ACTUAL
PRODUCTION OF AFFORDABLE HOUSING
UNITS.
THIS NEW PROGRAM WOULD PROVIDE
CITIES AND COUNTIES.
THE RESOURCES TO SUBSIDIZE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
INVESTED RELATED INFRASTRUCTURE
AND ADDRESS OTHER CRITICAL STATE
PRIORITIES.
LIKE CLIMATE CHANGE IN FIRE WISE
BUILDING.
LOCAL GOVERNMENT OFFICIALS ARE
PREPARED TO USE THE REVENUE
GENERATED BY SB. FIVE TO SUPPORT
THE CONSTRUCTION OF BELOW MARKET
RATE UNITS FOR FAMILIES
STRUGGLING TO AFFORD HOUSING
YOUR THEIR JOBS.
DEVELOP TRANSIT ORIENTED HOUSING
THAT WILL REDUCE TRAFFIC
CONGESTION.
THE COURAGE URBAN INFILL
DEVELOPMENT.
BY HER REHABILITATING AN
IMPROVING INFRASTRUCTURE.
AND PROTECT COMMUNITIES
ADVERSELY AFFECTED BY SEA LEVEL
RISE GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS
AND OTHER SECURE SIGNIFICANT
IMPACTS OF CLIMATE CHANGE.
NOW BILL IS A SMALL TOWN TO
FEWER THAN THREE THOUSAND
RESIDENTS WHEN THE HEART OF THE
NAPA VALLEY.
IN.
NINETEEN SIXTY EIGHT NAPA COUNTY
ADOPTED THE NATION'S FIRST
AGRICULTURAL PRESERVE IN ORDER
TO PROTECT THE RURAL CHARACTER
AND ECONOMY OF OUR REGION.
DESPITE LOCAL EFFORTS INCLUDING
THE PASSAGE LAST YEAR.
OF A COUNTY WIDE 1% INCREASE IN
THE HOTEL TAX THAT'S DEDICATED
TO WORKFORCE HOUSING PROJECTS.
WE STRUGGLE WITH HIGH HOME
PRICES AND LOW INVENTORY.
THAT KEEP HOUSING.
OUT OF REACH FOR MANY WORKING
HOUSEHOLDS.
THE LARGEST EMPLOYER IN OUR
COMMUNITIES THE CALIFORNIA
VETERANS HOME.
WHICH IS HOME TO CLOSE TO ONE
THOUSAND MILITARY VETERANS.
AND NEARLY NINE HUNDRED
EMPLOYEES.
UP TO ONE HUNDRED CARE GIVER
JOBS REMAIN UNFILLED AT THE
VETERANS HOME.
MAINLY BECAUSE THE COST OF
LIVING IN THE AREA DOES NOT
ALIGN WITH HOUSEHOLD INCOMES.
OUR NAPA VALLEY UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT CONTINUES TO EXPERIENCE
DECLINING ENROLLMENT IN LARGE
PART BECAUSE FAMILIES CANNOT
AFFORD TO LIVE IN THE AREA.
THE RELATED DROP IN STATE
FUNDING HAS RESULTED IN MILLIONS
OF DOLLARS IN BUDGET CUTS.
AN IMMINENT CLOSURE OF SEVERAL
HIGH PERFORMING BUT SMALL PUBLIC
SCHOOLS INCLUDING.
YOUNTVILLE ELEMENTARY SCHOOL
WHICH DATES BACK TO THE EIGHTEEN
EIGHTIES. FOR MORE THAN THREE
YEARS I WORK WITH LEADERSHIP OF
THE DEPARTMENT OF VETERANS
AFFAIRS GENERAL SERVICES.
HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT AND THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE TO BRING HOUSING TO UNDER
UTILIZED AREAS.
OF THE SIX HUNDRED PLUS ACRE
VETERANS HOME CAMPUS.
IN CONJUNCTION WITH GOVERNOR
NEWSOME'S EXECUTIVE ORDER THAT
PRIORITIZES ACCESS STATE OWNED
PROPERTY FOR HOUSING DEVELOPMENT.
WE HAVE IDENTIFIED LOCATION
SUITABLE FOR HOUSING.
AND THE TOWN OF YOKO HAS
COMMITTED ONE HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS FOR A FEASIBILITY STUDY.
TO CREATE HOUSING THE
CONSERVATORIES.
HOMELESS VETERANS AND OTHERS.
COMBINED WITH EXISTING PLANNING
DESIGN DOLLARS SB FIVE COULD
PROVIDE ENOUGH MONEY TO ACTUALLY
GET THIS HOUSING BILLS.
THIS MONTH THE DEPARTMENT OF
GENERAL SERVICES IS EXPECTED TO
RELEASE ITS LIST OF AN ESTIMATED
ONE HUNDRED AND FIFTY STATE
OWNED PROPERTIES.
SUITABLE FOR HOUSING.
CITIES ARE PREPARING RIGHT NOW
TO PARTNER WITH THE STATE AND
THE DEVELOPMENT INDUSTRY TO MOVE
THE NEEDLE ON HOUSING
AFFORDABILITY AND AVAILABILITY.
WITH SB FIVE DOLLARS THESE
OPPORTUNITIES CAN GO FROM
CONCEPT TO REALITY.
I URGE YOU TO VOTE A ON SENATE
BILL FIVE AND SUPPORT INVESTMENT
IN AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT.
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WELCOME
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
SISTER THE OTHER BEHALF FOR THE
STATE BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION
TRADES COUNCIL IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF THIS LEGISLATION.
ARE WE WANT TO THANK THE SENATOR
FOR INTRODUCING THIS VERY
INNOVATIVE -- CREATIVE WAY TO
FUND AFFORDABLE HOUSING WE ALSO
WANT TO THANK MANY MEMBERS OF
THIS COMMITTEE ESPECIALLY YOU
MAN CHAIR FOR YOUR EFFORTS TO
TRY TO ADDRESS THE VOTER
THRESHOLD ISSUES THAT EXISTS --
FOR THE LOCAL LEVEL AS
LOCALITIES ARE SEEKING TO
ACTUALLY DO FOR THEMSELVES AND
PROVIDE FOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING
FUNDING SO THEY CAN BUILDING
INFRASTRUCTURE AND THE PROJECT
NEEDED. TO KEEP PEOPLE IN THEIR
HOMES AND IN THEIR LOCAL
COMMUNITIES.
THIS BILL IS VERY IMPORTANT
BECAUSE IT TRIES TO BRIDGE ONLY
AFFORDABLE HOUSING BUT CLIMATE
CHANGE ISSUES IN A WAY THAT IS
MEANINGFUL.
THE STATE DOES HAVE TO
PARTICIPATE IN A VERY MEANINGFUL
WAY TO PROVIDE THAT TYPE OF
LEVERAGE FUNDING RESOURCES.
IT HAS DONE SO THROUGH SB TWO
BACK IN TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN
AS WELL AS SB.
THREE THOSE WERE MONUMENTAL BUT
THERE WERE DOWN PAYMENT AND THE
NECESSARY FUNDING THAT'S
REQUIRED BECAUSE OF THE LOSS OF
REDEVELOPMENT AGENCIES.
THAT WAS A HARD HIT ARE WE STILL
HAVE NOT RECOVERED FROM THAT AND
I THINK WE'RE TRYING TO FIGURE
OUT HOW TO PUT THE PUZZLE BACK
TOGETHER IN A WAY THAT DOES NOT
HARM SCHOOLS.
AND OTHER VERY VITAL PUBLIC
SERVICES THAT ARE PROVIDED
THROUGH THE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
THIS BILL ACHIEVES THAT WE
BELIEVE THAT IS A VERY CREATIVE
VERY COLLABORATIVE IT'S A GOOD
WAY TO ACTUALLY ADDRESS SOME OF
THE ISSUES THAT ARE BEING WORKED
BY REYES BY.
OUR BROTHERS AND SISTERS IN THE
A SCHOOL COMMUNITY.
WE ALSO THINK THAT THE BILL
CONTAINS VERY IMPORTANT
PROTECTIONS FOR THE WORKERS THAT
ARE ACTUALLY BUILDING THE
HOUSING AND BY ENSURING THAT
THERE'S APPRENTICES ARE ACTUALLY
GOING TO PARTICIPATE THEY'RE
ALSO ALL LOOKING TO THE
WORKFORCE SHORTAGE.
SAID THERE'S GOING TO BE THE
READILY ACCESSIBLE SKILLED AND
TRAINED WORK FORCE TO ADDRESS
THE FUTURE PROJECTS FOR ANY
FUTURE TYPE OF BIG MARKET RATE
PRODUCTION TYPE LEGISLATION.
SO WE BELIEVE SB FIVE IS
COMPLEMENTED COMPLEMENTARY TO
THE GOVERNOR'S HOUSING GOALS AND
THE STATE BUDGET. TO PROVIDE NEW
OPPORTUNITIES FOR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AND THE PRIVATE
SECTOR TO WORK TOGETHER
REVITALIZED COMMUNITIES AND
BUILD AFFORDABLE HOUSING WHILE
ADDRESSING THE CLIMATE.
CHANGE IMPACTS PROVIDING GOOD
MIDDLE CLASS JOBS IN A TIME OF A
LOT OF INCOME INEQUALITY FOR
THOSE REASONS WE STRONGLY URGE
YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT JUST YOUR NAME IN YOUR
TITLE IN YOUR ABSOLUTELY MADAM
CHAIR -- MANAGER MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE PLUGINS ALL OF US HERE
TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE CITIES OF
LAKE WOULD ROSEMEAD BELAY -- Là
MARADA ROSE FILL THOUSAND OAKS
CAME RIO RANCHO CUCAMONGA SIR
RIDEAU'S PALMDALE ATASCADERO
NORWALK AND PARAMOUNT.
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
REMEMBER TRUST BUCKLEY ON BEHALF
OF SACRAMENTO GAIL STEINBERG AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MALINA PRIOR CALIFORNIA SEVEN
DOUBLE ACP AND SUPPORT THANK YOU.
JOHN CLAD BEHALF OF THE CITY OF
INCENTIVES AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
SHAUNA VALENTINE ON BEHALF OF
UNITED CONTRACTORS IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
JULIE SNYDER ON BEHALF OF
HOUSING CALIFORNIANS STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MERRILL LYNCH A CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF HOUSING
AUTHORITIES IN CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF LOCAL HOUSING
FINANCE AGENCY STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
HI THIS IS LIKE A STEEL CRANES
ON BEHALF OF NONPROFIT HOUSING
ASSOCIATION OF NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
TRACY STEVENS ON BEHALF OF THE
CONSTRUCTION EMPLOYERS
ASSOCIATION ALSO IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MORE TOP ON BEHALF OF THE CITY
OF SAN DIEGO IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
MANAGER DAVID JOHNSON HALF THE
CITIES OF BURBANK GLENDALE THE
MARIN COUNTY COUNCIL OF MAYORS
AND COUNCIL MEMBERS PASADENA
SOUTH PASADENA AND THE CITY OF
STOCKING AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
SENATE GEORGE WITH AMERICAN
PLANNING ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
MAX BURIED THE CITIES OF NAPA
AND SAN CARLOS IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
CHIANA CITY DAY FOR THE CITY OF
ALAMEDA AND SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
CHRISLEY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES IN SUPPORT.
PERSONAL COULD US HERE BEHALF OF
CITY OF SANTA MONICA AND A LOS
ANGELES CITY MAYOR ERIC GARCETTI
ON BEHALF -- THROUGH THIS BIG
CITY MAYORS A LETTER IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
THANK VENTURE KEEP DONE ON
BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA APARTMENT
ASSOCIATION SUPPORT.
CASEY -- IT ON BEHALF OF THE
CITIES OF CUPERTINO LAFAYETTE
AND SANTANA AND SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
MELISSA ROMERO WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF
CONSERVATION VOTERS IN SUPPORT.
ENTRY ENTRY ON BEHALF OF THE
CITY OF BEVERLY HILLS AND
SUPPORT.
ALEX GIVES ON THE EFFICACY OF
HALF MOON BAY IN THE TRI VALLEY
CITIES OF DANVILLE DUBLIN SAN
RAMON PLEASANTON IN LIVERMORE
AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS CAN BE DONE
YOU DURAN WITH THE CALIFORNIA
STATE COUNCIL LABORS AND SUPPORT.
SENATE TRUSTS CALIFORNIA RENTERS
LEGAL ADVOCACY AND EDUCATION
FUND SUPPORT THANK YOU.
AND YOUR MEMBERS MIKE MONEY
GOING TO BE HALF OF THE
METROPOLITAN TRANSPORTATION
COMMISSION IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON KURT BUCKMAN ON
BEHALF OF THE SAN DIEGO
ASSOCIATION OF GOVERNMENTS AND
AGAIN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MATT REAGAN ON BEHALF OF THE BAY
AREA COUNCIL IN SUPPORT.
LARA FIGHT ON BEHALF OF THE TWO
THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED MEMBERS OF
YOUR BE ACTION IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
HEIDI FELT ON AN INDIVIDUAL
RESIDENT OF LOS ANGELES IN
SUPPORT WITH THE THANK YOU FOR
FOCUSING ON AFFORDABLE HOUSING
AND LEAVING US WITH RENT LOCAL
CONTROL.
THANK YOU YOU'RE WELCOME AND
THANK YOU.
ARE THERE ANY OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
WELCOME
.
GOOD AFTERNOON AND JENNIFER
BAKER WITH THE CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION ON AND
UNFORTUNATELY WE DO OPPOSE THE
BILL AND IT'S A VERY PRECARIOUS
SITUATION -- THAT WERE INVOLVED
AND WE ABSOLUTELY DON'T --
OPPOSE AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND WE
BELIEVE THAT WE NEED TO TAKE
SIGNIFICANT STEPS TO HELP --
FAMILIES TO BE ABLE TO HAVE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING WE SEE THE
IMPACT OF THAT DIRECTLY IN THE
CLASSROOM AS OUR SCHOOL SYSTEMS
ARE WORKING TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
CAN GIVE STUDENTS AS MUCH OF A
STABLE ENVIRONMENT IN THE
CLASSROOM.
WHEN WE HAVE THEM DURING THE DAY --
THE SOLE DILEMMA THAT WE HAVE
WITH THIS MEASURE IS THE USE OF
THE RAF FUNDS THAT HAS AN IMPACT
ON PROPERTY TAXES THAT WOULD GO
TO SCHOOLS.
NOW FORTUNATELY CENTER BILL HAS
BEEN EXTREMELY HELPFUL IN TRYING
TO AMELIORATE ANY KIND OF ISSUES
OF THAT HE CAN IN REGARD TO
TRYING TO PROTECT SCHOOLS SO
WHEN WE ARE IN GOOD ECONOMIC
TIMES LIKE THIS YEAR TO NOT A
PROBLEM THE BILL DOESN'T HURT AS
IT DOESN'T.
IMPACT US IN A NEGATIVE WAY AND
WE DO APPRECIATE THAT MULTITUDE
OF A TENSE THAT THE CENTER HAS.
TRIED TO ACHIEVE TO ADDRESS --
ISSUES THAT COULD HARM SCHOOLS
OUR PROBLEM IS WHAT HAPPENS IF
WE GET INTO ANOTHER FISCAL
DECLINE WHICH COULD POTENTIALLY
HAPPEN WE LEARN VERY CLEARLY
DURING THIS PAST RECESSION WHEN
PROP NINETY EIGHT WAS SUSPENDED
TWICE.
THAT OUR SCHOOLS ARE SUBJECT TO
SIGNIFICANT HARM THE ANALYSIS OF
THE MEASURE ACTUALLY NOTES THAT
GENERALLY THE THE GENERAL FUND
WILL BACK FILL OUR SCHOOLS AND
THIS SIGNIFICANT WORD TO KIAN ON
IS GENERALLY BECAUSE TWICE IN
THE PAST DECADE.
THE STATE DID NOT BACK FOR ALL
OUR SCHOOLS THAT IS THE SOLE
REASON WHY WERE OPPOSING THIS
MEASURE IF WE DO GO INTO AN
ECONOMIC DECLINE.
THIS OUR SCHOOLS THAT ARE
RELIANT ON THOSE PROPERTY TAX
REVENUES COULD BE IN A SITUATION
WHERE THE STATE COULD CHOOSE NOT
TO BACK FILL.
I'M IN THE DILEMMA THAT WE WOULD
HAVE IS IF WE'RE IN THAT
ECONOMIC SITUATION THE SCHOOLS
THAT ARE RELYING ON THOSE FUNDS
WOULD BE HURT EVEN MORE
SIGNIFICANTLY THAN THEY WERE OR
IN THE LAST ECONOMIC DECLINE.
BECAUSE WHEN TIMES ARE TOUGH IN
IF THE STATE DOESN'T BACKFILL
SCHOOLS THE PROPERTY TAXES THAT
THEY WOULD RECEIVE WOULD HAVE
ACTUALLY BEEN A MORE STABLE
ECONOMIC SOURCE -- THEN THE PROP
NINETY EIGHT FUNDS THAT THEY
COULD HAVE RECEIVED AN
UNECONOMIC DECLINE FOR SO FOR
THOSE REASONS CTA'S
UNFORTUNATELY IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH YES MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS.
GOOD AFTERNOON DAVID WOLF WITH
THE HOWARD JARVIS TAXPAYERS
ASSOCIATION OPPOSED SB.
FIVE AND MEMBERS I ACTUALLY IS
SORT OF BIZARRE BUT I WANT TO
MERE SOME OF MS BAKER'S COMMENTS
THIS -- SIMPLY SIMPLY IN REGARDS
TO THE FISCAL IMPACT OF THIS
BILL.
OF THE MONEY HERE THAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT.
YOU KNOW COULD RESULT IN WOULD
BE THE EQUIVALENT OF A THIRTY
BILLION DOLLAR GENERAL FUND BOND
I MEAN THAT'S THAT'S HE AMOUNT
OF MONEY THAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT HERE THAT COULD BE BONDED
OUT.
OVER A PERIOD OF DECADES BUT THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN A GENERAL
OBLIGATION BOND AND WHAT'S BEING
PROPOSED IN SB.
FIVE IS THAT G. O. BONDS REQUIRE
A TWO THIRDS VOTE OF THE
LEGISLATURE AND STATEWIDE VOTER
APPROVAL NONE OF THAT EXISTS
UNDER SB.
FIVE RIGHT NOW LISTEN WE HAVE A
DEBT SERVICE RATIO IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA 6% THAT MEANS THE
FIRST 6% OF REVENUE OUT OF STATE
GENERAL FUND GOES TO NOTHING
MORE OR LESS THAN PAYING OFF.
BOND AND TO MISS BAKER'S POINT
WE REALLY DO NEED TO BE
CONCERNED I THINK WHEN AND IT
WILL BE WHEN AND NOT IF WE HAD
AN ECONOMIC DOWNTURN THAT WE
SIMPLY DO NOT HAVE THE
FLEXIBILITY.
GOING FORWARD WITH FIND AT AND
OTHER GENERAL FUND EXPENDITURES
TO BE ABLE TO DEAL WITH THIS
PROBLEM -- NUMBER TWO REGARDING --
PRIVATE PROPERTY RIGHTS HAMMOND
COME IN OBVIOUSLY AN IMPORTANT
ISSUE AT THE HOWARD JARVIS
TAXPAYERS ASSOCIATION.
EXPLICIT EMINENT DOMAIN
AUTHORITY IS IN THIS BILL AND IS
EXPRESSLY NOT PROHIBIT.
THE TAKING OF PRIVATE PROPERTY
SHOULD AND FUNDAMENTALLY ONLY BE
FOR A PRIVATE USE AND THAT
RESTRICTION IS NOT IN THE BILL.
MEMBERS IN CLOSING WE DO NEED TO
ASK AND THIS IS ESPECIALLY TRUE
WITH SB TWO AND SB THREE
FLOATING AROUND OUT THERE THERE
ARE EXISTING DEDICATED SOURCES
OF REVENUE. FOR AFFORDABLE
HOUSING PROGRAMS THEIR EXISTING
REVENUE STREAMS OUT THERE IN THE
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
A YEAR SB THREE WAS A FIVE
BILLION DOLLAR HOUSING BOND.
PLENTY OF MONEY THERE -- BUT IN
EXCHANGE WHAT WE'RE DOING WITH
SB FIVE IS IT WORTH THE LIMITING
OUR FLEXIBILITY TO ISSUE BONDS.
IS IT WORTH LIMITING FUNDING FOR
OTHER GENERAL FUND PROGRAMS AND
IS IT WORTH NOT CREATING ONE OR
TWO OR EVEN -- THREE YOU KNOW
REVENUE STREAMS OUT OF THIS BILL
BUT UP TEN NINE NEW REVENUE
STREAMS TO FUND THIS PROPOSAL.
ON AVERAGE THAT'S ONE POINT SIX
MILLION DOLLARS A YEAR OF
GENERAL FUND COSTS AND IT COULD
GO -- THEY COULD GO MUCH MUCH
HIGHER THAN THAT AND THIS CLASS
OVER THIRTY EIGHT YEARS MEMBERS.
THIRTY EIGHT YEARS AND AFTER
NINE YEARS WE ARE LOCKED IN.
LOCKED INTO THE SPENDING WITH NO
WAY OUT.
AND AGAIN WHEN YOU'RE FACING
UNIQUE A POTENTIAL ECONOMIC
DOWNTURN IN THE FUTURE THIS
DOESN'T SEEM LIKE A WISE FISCAL
PATH TASK FOR NUMBER.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OTHERS IN
OPPOSITION.
BROUGH UP TO THE MICROPHONE NAME --
PARKER THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
BOARDS ASSOCIATION FOR THE
COMMAS PREVIOUS SEDATED WERE IN
OPPOSITION.
IN THE GARAGE WITH THE LOS
ANGELES UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
WITHIN OPPOSED TO NOTE UNLESS
AMEND THAT **** WHILE AN ALLY MY
COMMENTS WITH THOSE SOME AS
BAKER THANK YOU.
STEVE HENDERSON REPRESENTING THE
COUNTY SUPERINTENDENTS
ASSOCIATION WE WOULD ALIGN
OURSELVES WITH COMMENTS FROM CTA.
THANK YOU.
SAYS THE MATTER NOT HERE -- FOR
ROBERT MUELLER WHO COULDN'T BE
HERE TODAY ON BEHALF OF HIS
CLIENT FIELD STAT AND HEART
AHMANSON IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
SERGIO MARTINEZ WITH THE
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS ASSOCIATION
AND I ALIGN MYSELF WITH MY
EMPLOYEE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHERRY BOMB
WAY YES I'M I'M PRESIDENT
DECEMBER DINO COUNTY TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION I JUST LIKE TO
MARROW OUT WHAT MISS BAKER SAID.
AND ASK PROPOSITIONS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
FOR KATHY FAIRS SEMOLINA COUNTY
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION AND ALSO
POSE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON NUMBER AND A
WALKER PRESIDENT OF ASSOCIATED
CHINO TEACHERS IN SAN BENITO
COUNTY AND I OPPOSE THE BILL.
THANK YOU.
FAIR ABACHA'S WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF SCHOOL
BUSINESS OFFICIALS OPPOSE SALAS
AMENDED.
THANK YOU MANY OTHERS IN
OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE ARE THERE ANY.
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE OR
QUESTIONS MADAM CHAIR SOME
ROSARIO.
WAS AT ANOTHER COMMITTEE COMING
BACK BUT I MUST.
I MISS THE THE PRESENTATION BUT
I WANT TO GET CLARITY ON NINETY
EIGHT MONEY AND AND HOW THAT
BACK FEEL WILL TAKE PLACE
BECAUSE BEEN SOME DISCUSSION ON
IT.
BOB AND HOW THAT WILL MAY COME
SCHOOLS HOLE.
THROUGH THAT MONEY IN THE BACK
FEELING OF THAT [inaudible]
WELL -- TO GET THAT CLARIFIED WE
ACTUALLY WENT TO THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE AND WE ASK THEM
TO ANALYZE THIS PARTICULAR
QUESTION -- IT TURNS OUT THAT
THIS IS BEEN DONE BEFORE.
IN TERMS OF THE E. RAF --
SHIFTING TO PAY OFF -- STATE
DATIN FOR STATE PURPOSES BACK
WHEN.
THE EARLY YOU KNOW LIKE FIFTEEN
YEARS AGO.
WHEN WHEN THIS OCCURRED BUT THIS
BILL AND ONLY THIS BILL?
HAS A SPECIFIC SECTION IN IT
THAT GUARANTEES THAT ALL THE
FUNDS THAT ARE TAKEN OUT OF THE
E. RAFFLE BE BACK FILLED.
BY THE STATE GENERAL FUND AND IF
THE ECONOMIC DOWNTURN OCCURS AS
QUESTION -- WE FOUND OUT THAT
PEOPLE HAD QUESTIONS ABOUT THERE
IS THERE IS A PAUSE BUTTON THAT
THE LEGISLATURE AND THE GOVERNOR
CAN DO COULD PUSH.
THAT WILL STOP THIS PROGRAM FROM
CONTINUING.
AND IT WILL -- IT IS IN ESSENCE --
SAY WE'RE NOT GOING TO THIS
PROGRAM THIS YEAR BECAUSE OF THE
PROBLEM.
WITH -- PROP NINETY EIGHT SO THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S CONCLUDED.
ED SAYS -- IT IS IN THE SUMMARY
I GOT THEY HAVE A THREE PAGE
LETTER THEY RIP THEY WROTE.
AND IT'S PUBLISHED A PUBLISHED
LETTER.
IS IS UNDER SB FIVE THE STATE
WOULD REQUIRED TO READ BENCH THE
RAFT REDUCTIONS.
AUTHORIZED BY THE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT
INVESTMENT PROGRAM.
THIS REQUIREMENT MEANS THE STATE
EFFECTIVELY WOULD BE COVERING
THE COST OF THE PROGRAM THROUGH
GENERAL FUND SPENDING RATHER
THAN REDUCTION IN SCHOOL FUNDING.
IN OTHER WORDS IT'S GOING TO BE
COMPLETELY COVERED AND I THINK
IF YOU WANTED TO GET INTO DETAIL.
OF FURTHER ON THE SUBJECT -- THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST HAS HAS
LOOKED AT SO -- WE WE'VE LOOKED
AT THIS MANY DIFFERENT WAYS WE
PUT A LOT OF GUARANTEES TO
PROTECT SCHOOLS AND I THINK THEY
RECOGNIZE THAT WE TRIED TO DO
THAT.
THEY'RE JUST OBJECTING TO THE
USE OF THE ROUGH I THINK.
THEY KNOW THAT THIS BILL AS
OPPOSED TO MANY OTHER BILLS THAT
HAVE GONE THROUGH THIS COMMITTEE.
AND THROUGH THE SENATE --
RELATING TO PROPERTY TAX -- OF
SHIPS.
THAT HAD NO PROTECTION
WHATSOEVER.
THIS BILL IS THE ONLY BILL THIS
YEAR THAT ACTUALLY HAS THE
PROPERTY TAX PROTECTION.
OF ANY KIND OF SHOW OF
PROTECTING SCHOOLS SO.
SO SOME OF THE COMMENTS AS FAR
AS WHAT'S BEEN DONE IN THE PAST
AS FAR AS BACK FEELING NOT
COMING TO FRUITION DURING SOME.
OF TOUGH TIMES WITHIN THE BUDGET
THIS BILL HAS BUILT IN
PROTECTIONS TO ENSURE THAT ANY
MONEY COMING OUT OF THROUGH THIS
BILL FROM PROP NINETY EIGHT WILL.
WILL BE BACK FIELD AND IF THERE
IS SOME HESITANCE TO THAT THE
LEGISLATURE DOES HAVE THE WHERE
WITH ALL TO STOP THAT.
FROM CONTINUING FOR THAT'S
DIFFERENT THAN WHAT'S BEEN GOING
ON IN THE PAST.
AND WE HAVE ALSO OF COURSE NOW.
THE LAW REQUIRES IS TO HAVE A
RAINY DAY FUND.
WHICH PROVIDES A RESERVE IN CASE
WE NEED TO USE THAT AND IF THE
RAINY DAY FUND ISSUES THIS BILL
FREEZES PROGRAM.
AND PROHIBITS OF PROHIBITED TO
GO ON FOR EXAMPLE.
SO WE HAVE WE HAVE SOME
PROTECTIONS IN THE BILL THAT
PROTECT OUR SCHOOLS OKAY THANK
YOU I WOULD HAVE OPPOSE A BILL
OF THAT MYSELF PERSONALLY.
OKAY I REMEMBER CHAIR AND THE
FINAL BILL DEPARTMENT AS WELL AS
ME IT'S THAT THE COMMITTEE'S
TIME -- EXCUSE ME OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER VOEPEL.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
SENATE BILL.
ON PAGE TWENTY FOUR THE BILL
LINES TWENTY ONE THROUGH TWENTY
FOUR IT SAYS IT THIS NEWLY ALONG.
THIS NEW ENTITY AS ALLOWED TO
ACQUIRE IN TRANSFER REAL
PROPERTY AND CARRY ON ANY OTHER
ACT NECESSARY TO CARRY OUT A
PROJECT.
SOME OF IT INTERPRETED THIS
INCLUDING MYSELF TO INCLUDE THE
POWER OF EMINENT DOMAIN.
AND I KNOW THAT THERE WAS MUCH
BACK AND FORTH IN A HOUSING
COMMITTEE ABOUT WHETHER.
THAT IS WHAT IT MEANS -- SO I
KNOW THIS IS BEEN BEAT UP A
LITTLE BIT BEFORE.
GIVEN THE CONTROVERSIAL NATURE
OF THIS POWER AND TO MAKE THE
LANGUAGE MORE CLEAR.
WOULD YOU BE WILLING TO ADD A
SIMPLE LINE TO THE EFFECT.
OF NO PROPERTY SHALL BE ACQUIRED
OR TRANSFERRED BY EXERCISING THE
POWER OF EMINENT DOMAIN.
YOU COULD MAKE THAT AMENDMENT OR
THROW THAT IN THEN I WOULD BE.
LOVELY TO SUPPORT THIS BILL WELL
WE WE DID WE DID LOOK AT THAT AS
KIND OF THE BILL DOES NOT.
CHANGE EMINENT DOMAIN OFF OKAY
FIRST OF ALL.
IT DOES NOT MAKE IT EASIER TO
EXPAND WHO ARE WATER WHEN IT CAN
BE USE IT DOESN'T MAKE A CHANGE
ON EMINENT DOMAIN.
AND THE EXISTING FINANCE TOOLS
THAT WE HAVE.
RIGHT NOW ALL OF SUCH AS ENHANCE
INFRASTRUCTURE FINANCE DISTRICTS
AND SO FORTH.
THEY ALREADY HAVE THE EMINENT
DOMAIN IN THOSE LAWS THEY HAVE
THAT ENTERED THIS BILL DOES NOT
HAVE.
EMINENT DOMAIN MENTIONED AND
THAT.
IS IMPORTANT TO POINT OUT THAT
THE BILL'S FOCUS ALSO IS ON
BUILDING AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
NOT ON ELIMINATING BLIGHTED
DOING SLUM CLEARANCE KIND OF
REDEVELOPMENT OLDSCHOOL
REDEVELOPMENT TYPE PROJECTS
THAT'S NOT THE PURPOSE OF THIS
BILL THIS PURPOSE OF THIS BILL
IS TO BUILD AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
IT ALSO INCLUDES TEN PROTECTIONS
SUCH AS ANTI DISPLACEMENT
PROTECTIONS.
AND THEREFORE I DO NOT EXPECT A
LOT OF ARE INTO IT ENTITIES
USING THIS THIS -- BILL TO
FINANCE ANYTHING WILL USE
EMINENT DOMAIN SPECIFICALLY THE
BILL REQUIRES EACH PROJECT
IDENTIFIED IN THE PLAN.
A REQUIREMENT AND KNOWING
FICTION.
HAS BEEN MADE ON A PROJECT SITE
WITHIN THE LAST TEN YEARS.
PROTECTIONS TO AVOID
DISPLACEMENT INDIVIDUALS BY THE
PROJECTS SO SO THERE IS THERE IS
SOME REALLY SERIOUS --
PROTECTIONS -- THAT I I THINK
RESULT IN VERY LITTLE IF IF IF
NOT ALL.
OF VERY VERY SMALL AMOUNT OF
EMINENT DOMAIN PERIOD AND I
DON'T THINK IT'S NECESSARY TO
ELIMINATE -- THAT IS AND YOU
KNOW IN THIS BILL I MEAN IF YOU
WANT TO INTRODUCE A BILL AN
EMINENT DOMAIN TO DISCUSS IT
THAT'S A POLICY ISSUE.
THAT WE SHOULD HAVE MORE OR
BROADER DISCUSSIONS ON I MEAN
THIS IS -- A BIGGER ISSUE SO.
THAT'S I JUST WANT TO CLARIFY MY
ANSWER FOR YOU I HOPE I DID
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OF THE
COMMITTEE.
HEY WE HAD RIVER MOTION YET.
OKAY WE HAVE A MOTION.
WE HAVE A SECOND -- I DO HAVE
THIS IS A SUPPORT WITH
AMENDMENTS IS THAT TRUE.
OKAY.
EXCEPT THE MOMENT OKAY -- WHO
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE?
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I THINK WE
NEED TO HAVE SOME INVESTMENTS IN
THE IN THE HOUSING ON ON GOING
BASIS WE DID A GREAT JOB ON THE
BUDGET -- THE BUDGET -- DOES NOT --
INCLUDE ANY ONGOING HOUSING
FUNDS.
OF THE THE HOUSING BOND WAS.
THREE THREE BILLION DOLLARS NOT
FIVE BILLION DOLLARS TO SO WE
CAN CORRECT THAT SO I I THINK I
THINK -- WE NEED TO HAVE THIS ON
GOING A PARTNERSHIP WITH THE
CITIES IF WE'RE GOING TO BE
CLOSING RULES REGULATIONS.
REQUIREMENTS.
ND SO FOR ON THE CITY WE GOT
INTO SOME TO PROVIDE THEM WITH
SOME AND CENTER THE BILL THE
HOUSING THIS IS WHAT THIS BILL
DOES I REGION I VOTE -- SENATOR
I'LL BE SUPPORTING THE BILL
TODAY BUT IF YOU HAVE A COUPLE
OF COMMENTS NUMBER ONE IS THAT --
I SIT BACK AND THINK ABOUT WHERE
ARM MAYOR OF FROM -- TELL REAL
BILL IS -- THEIR STRUGGLE LIVING
ON THE BEAUTIFUL NAPA VALLEY
WITH GETTING HOUSING AFFORDABLE
HOUSING WHO WOULD HAVE THOUGHT
IN THAT AREA THE IN THE SCHOOLS
ARE STRUGGLING BECAUSE AND
CLOSING BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE
HOUSING FOR THE TEACHERS.
AND SO -- I THINK ABOUT THAT FOR
A RURAL AREAS A MINT THE STATE'S
VAST AND WE GET LEFT OUT
SOMETIMES IN A RURAL COMMUNITIES
AND I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
MAKING SURE THAT.
YOUR ENSURING THAT ARE REAL
COMMUNITIES HAVE A FAIR SHOT
RECEIVING SOME OF THIS FUNDING
AND THAT'S IMPORTANT TO ME
PERSONALLY.
AND THAT -- EACH COMMUNITY HAS A
DIFFERENT LOOK ABOUT IT BUT THIS
IS I THINK.
A GOOD BILL AND I APPRECIATE
YOUR BRINGING IT FORWARD -- FOR
MAKING SURE YOUR HOUSING FOR SO
MANY PEOPLE IN THE STATE.
SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND I'LL
BE SUPPORTING TODAY SECRETARY.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
AND RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS AGUIAR-CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY I LACKEY VOTING
LACKEY NOT VOTING BLOOM.
BLOOM AYE BOERNER HORVATH.
BOERNER HORVATH I RAMOS.
RAMOS SIDE GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ I ROBERT RIVAS VOEPEL.
VOEPEL NOT VOTING.
MEASURES OUT FIVE ZERO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH VERY MUCH SENATOR.
THANK YOU FOR SHOWING UP.
ALL RIGHT WE HAVE ITEM NUMBER
EIGHT IS.
SENATOR WIENER HERE I KNOW HE
WAS -- THERE YOU ARE HIDING
BEHIND EVERYONE.
I KNOW I WAS.
LOOKING FOR YOU [inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
LET OF THEIR A PISTOL.
THE RING [inaudible]
TO CARILLO [inaudible]
EVERYONE.
OKAY WELCOME SENATOR ITEM NUMBER
EIGHT SB FIVE NINETY TWO MISTER
WEINER WE LIKE TO PEOPLE SPEAK
IN SUPPORT TO IN A POSITION IN
THE ME TO USE THE THREE TWO AND
THEN SOMEONE HERE PER AT FOR ANY
QUESTIONS.
THAT'S FABULOUS OKAY PLEASE
BEGIN I THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MADAM CHAIRMAN THANK YOUR YOUR
STAFF -- FOR WORKING WITH US
SENATE TO FIVE NINETY TWO AND
I'M HAPPY TO ACCEPT.
OF THE COMMITTEES AMENDMENT TO
REMOVE THE COMPENSATORY DAMAGES
PROVISION -- FROM THE BILL.
I SENATE BILL -- FIVE NINETY TWO
CLARIFIES EXISTING LAW CONTAINED
IN THE HOUSING ACCOUNTABILITY
ACT AND I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT
THAT PEOPLE UNDERSTAND.
OF THE COUNTRY TO SOME
STATEMENTS THAT HAVE BEEN MADE
BY SOME ABOUT THE BILL.
OF HOUSING ACCOUNTABILITY ACT IS
NOT BEING ENACTED BY THIS BILL
IT WAS ENACTED IN NINETEEN
EIGHTY TWO WHEN I WAS TWELVE
YEARS OLD -- AND HAS BEEN ON THE
BOOKS FOR THIRTY SEVEN YEARS --
TWO YEARS AGO AS PART OF THE
LEGISLATURE'S HOUSING PACKAGE ON
THE BILL -- SOME MORE TEETH IN
ENFORCEMENT WERE PUT INTO THE
BILL.
AND TODAY -- BEFORE USE -- FIVE
NINE TWO WHICH MAKE SOME
CLARIFICATIONS -- AND CLOSES
SOME LOOPHOLES IN THE BILL -- TO
MAKE CLEAR WHAT WE THINK IS
ALREADY THE INTENT OF THE BILL.
AND WHAT THE HOUSING
ACCOUNTABILITY ACT IS ABOUT AND
WHAT THIS BILL WILL HELP FURTHER.
ON THE H. A. IS ABOUT MAKING
SURE THAT -- CITIES AND COUNTIES
FOLLOW THEIR OWN RULES THAT THEY
HAVE ADOPTED AND THAT THEY DON'T
CHANGE THE RULES IN THE MIDDLE.
OF THE GAME -- SO IF THE CITY
HAS ZONED -- PARCEL FOR FOUR
UNITS ARE SIX UNITS ARE TEN
UNITS.
THEN THE CITY NEEDS TO ALLOW
ABOUT ZONING TO BE PROPELLED OF
ITS OWN FOR THIRTY FEET -- IN
NEEDS TO ALLOW THAT IF IT IS
ADOPTED CERTAIN OBJECTIVE DESIGN
STANDARDS PEOPLE NEED TO BE ABLE
TO RELY ON THOSE DESIGN
STANDARDS AND CAN'T BE CHAINS
AND PULL THE RUG OUT.
SO THIS IS REALLY JUST ABOUT
CITIES FOLLOWING -- THEIR OWN --
RULES -- AND THAT'S AT THE HEART
OF THE H. A THIS BILL -- DOES A
FEW THINGS -- IT CLARIFIES --
THAT WHEN THE HA TALKS ABOUT A A
LOWER A REDUCTION IN DENSITY OR
REDUCTION AND HOUSING -- THAT
ACCESSORY DWELLING UNITS ON
COUNT AS HOUSING -- AND ALSO
DIED NEW BEDROOMS -- ACCOUNT AS
HOUSING -- TO THE CITY FIVE
EIGHTY USE ARE ALLOWED THE CITY
CAN'T ARBITRARILY REFUSED TO
ALLOW YOU TO PUT THE EIGHTY AND
OR IF THE BUILDINGS WHAT IN THE
ZONING ALLOW. FOR THREE BEDROOMS
YOU HAVE TO BE ALLOWED.
TO PUT IN THREE BEDROOMS AND
THEY CAN'T ARBITRARILY SAY NO --
YOU CAN ONLY HAVE ONE BEDROOM
AND STUFF BECAUSE WE DON'T WANT
ANY CHILDREN -- IN THIS
COMMUNITY FOR EXAMPLE -- SO --
AGAIN WANT TO THANK THE THE
COMMITTEE AND THE CHAIR -- I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE BOAT
WITH ME HERE TODAY -- HOLLY FOR
MANY FROM HABITAT FOR HUMANITY A
JENNIFER STOCKTON CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF REALTORS AND
DEALING CASEY FROM.
WILL BE AVAILABLE FOR TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS FROM THE CALIFORNIA
RENTERS LEGAL ADVOCACY AND
EDUCATION FUNDS.
GREAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WELCOME.
HI HOLLY FOR ME ON BEHALF OF
HABITAT FOR HUMANITY CALIFORNIA
AND HABITAT IT'S BEEN FORCED IN
RECENT YEARS LIKE MANY OTHER
NONPROFITS TO GET REALLY
CREATIVE AND HOW DO WE SERVE
MORE FAMILIES WITH LESS MONEY
AND LESS LAND.
SO THE EIGHTY YOU MODEL AND ONE
OF OUR AFFILIATES IN SANTA CRUZ
HAS BEEN THE TRAILBLAZER AT
COMING UP WITH A CREATIVE NEW
TOOL TO TRY TO CREATE MORE
EIGHTY USED TO ALLOW US TO SERVE
AGAIN MORE FAMILIES WITH LESS.
WITH LESS LAND AND WITH LESS
MONEY.
IN SOME OF OUR AFFILIATES OF
STARTED TO USE THAT MODEL
BECAUSE IT'S CREATED A TENANT IN
COMMON ARRANGEMENT HAVE MORE
AFFORDABLE CO OWNERSHIP --
OPPORTUNITIES IN THE COMMUNITIES
BUT ALSO SOME OF OUR AFFILIATES
ARE ALSO STARTING TO BUILD AND
FINANCE EIGHTY USE THAT ARE
RENTAL PROPERTIES FOR LOW INCOME
FAMILIES BE RESTRICTED TO HAVE
AN ADDITIONAL LOWER INCOME.
RENT OPPORTUNITY FOR THEM ON
THEIR PROPERTY THAT THEY MAY NOT
BE ABLE -- TO BUILD THEMSELVES.
THREE TO USE ON THE NATURAL --
ARE MORE AFFORDABLE UNITS WITH
LESS SUBSIDY IS BECAUSE THEY'RE
SMALLER AND THE RENTS JUST
NATURALLY WITHOUT DEED
RESTRICTIONS ARE GONNA BE A MORE
AFFORDABLE SO WE SUPPORT THAT --
PHILOSOPHICALLY BUT THIS BILL
ALSO IS COMPLEMENTARY TO SEVERAL
OTHER BILLS THAT THIS COMMITTEE
HAS PASSED THIS YEAR AND EIGHTY
USE INCLUDING OUR SPONSOR BELL --
HIS FRIEDMAN'S A. B. I'M FIVE
EIGHT SEVEN WHICH WE'RE PROUD TO
SPONSOR AND AND WITH SEVERAL
OTHER BILLS THAT WERE SUPPORTING
AND THIS WILL HELP AND YOU DON'T
HAVE ENFORCEABLE.
MECHANISMS TO ENSURE THAT THAT
SAME PROTECTION THAT'S AFFORDED
TO OTHER HOUSING UNITS IN THE
COMMUNITY UNDER THE H. A. WILL
ALSO BE AFFORDED THE SAME
PROTECTIONS TO THE EIGHTY UNITS
SO WITH THAT WE EXPECT
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
ABOUT.
THANK YOU.
WELCOME.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE JENNIFER SPEC ABOUT
FOR THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF REALTORS BUT WE ARE PLEASED
TO BE A SPONSOR OF SB FIVE
NINETY TWO WHICH SEEKS TO
ENCOURAGE THE DEVELOPMENT OF
VITALLY NEEDED HOUSING UNITS BY
EXPANDING THE HA A A TO PROTECT.
THE EVELOPMENT OF AN EIGHTY YOU
OR JUNIOR EIGHTY YOU. THOUSAND
CRISIS IN CALIFORNIA IS TAKING
THE LARGEST TOLL ON LOW INCOME
AND WORKING FAMILIES EVERY TIME
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS DENY HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT APPLICATIONS FAMILY
SUFFER.
THE BILL SIMPLY SIX TO HOLD
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ACCOUNTABLE BY
PROTECTING FAMILIES ABILITY TO
CREATE NEEDY YOU OR TO CONVERT
EXISTING BEDROOM TO A JUNIOR
EIGHTY YOU.
FAMILIES WHO LEGALLY CHALLENGE
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS DECISION TO
DENY THEIR EIGHTY YOU ARE FACED
WITH THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS IN
LEGAL FEES.
WHICH CANNOT BE RECOUPED.
THE FAMILIES CHALLENGING THAT
ALLOW ME WHEN THE DECISION BUT
THE MONEY SET ASIDE TO BUILD THE
UNIT IS NOW GONE.
IT SEEMS ONLY FAIR THAT LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS ALSO FACE A
FINANCIAL CONSEQUENCE IF THE
COURTS FIND THAT LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS DENIED AN EIGHTY YOU
WITHOUT APPROPRIATE BECAUSE SB
FIVE NINETY TWO ALSO MAKES IT
CLEAR THAT PROJECTS CONSISTENT
WITH STATE LOCAL PLANNING LAW
THE RECEIVE MINISTERIAL APPROVAL
ARE.
ADDED TO THE AJ.
PROJECTS THAT ARE MINISTER WE
PROVED ARE BY THEIR NATURE
CONSISTENT LOCAL PLANNING AND
ZONING AND SHOULD NOT BE DENIED
UNLESS THEY VIOLATE HEALTH AND
SAFETY STANDARDS AS REQUIRED BY
THE HA.
SB FIVE NINETY TWO CLOSE TO
SEVERAL LOOPHOLES IN HA WHICH
WILL HELP LOCAL TOLD LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS ACCOUNTABLE FOR
PROVING MUCH NEEDED HOUSING
UNITS WHEN THOSE UNITS ARE
CONSISTENT WITH LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS OWN PLANNING AND
ZONING LAW.
IT'S FOR THESE REASONS THAT WE
RESPECTFULLY OUR CLUSTER AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OTHER OTHER
OP OF BUSINESSES IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU SAYS THE MATTER THAT
LIKE HAS PUBLIC AFFAIRS HERE ON
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA BE PROUD
SPONSORS OF THE BALANCE PART.
THANK YOU.
MADISON DRAWING ON BEHALF OF
SILICON VALLEY COMMUNITY
FOUNDATION IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
ALEX TOURISM BEHALF OF TECHNET
IN SUPPORT.
THIS ACCIDENT ON BEHALF OF URBAN
ENVIRONMENTALISTS AND AS OF YET
BE IN SUPPORT.
HI THAT THE LEGACY OF CRANES ON
BEHALF OF NOT NONPROFIT HOUSING
ASSOCIATION OF NORTH
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
MANAGER MEMBERS MICHAEL GETTING
WITH CBI A HERE IN SUPPORT.
SILVIO FRY WITH FACEBOOK IN
SUPPORT.
KEEP MOTOR WITH MISSION AMBIEN
STRONG SUPPORT.
FONG TM WITH SAM'S IS GOING TO
BE IN SUPPORT.
LARA FOOT WITHIN THE ACTION IN
SUPPORT.
JAMES CHIANG ELECTED MEMBER OF
THE BERKELEY RUN STABILIZATION
BOARD AND SUPPORT.
ON MILLER WITH THE WESTERN FROM
ON POVERTY A AND ALSO THEY HAVE
THE CALIFORNIA RURAL LEGAL
ASSISTANCE SYSTEMS FOUNDATION
WERE LISTED AS SUPPORT IF
AMENDED IN THE ANALYSIS BUT ALL
OF OUR CONCERNS ABOUT ADDRESS
SOMEWHERE PLEASE TO NOT BE IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
CEDRAS IN CALIFORNIA RENDERS
LEGAL ADVICE THE EDUCATION FUND
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
TODD DAVID BAY AREA HOUSING
ADVOCACY COALITION IN SUPPORT.
AT MATT READING WITH THE BAY
AREA COUNCIL IN SUPPORT.
BEEN WISELY WITH WESTERN TO
AVOID SINCE OVER THIS GO IN
SUPPORT.
BEEN WILL BE WITH US SAN
FRANCISCO NORTHERN NEIGHBORS --
IN SUPPORT.
MERRILL LYNCH A CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF HOUSING
AUTHORITIES IN CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF LOCAL HOUSING
FINANCE AGENCIES IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU OTHER OTHERS IN
SUPPORT [inaudible]
SEEING NONE.
A WE HAVE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
CITY GEORGE WITH THE AMERICAN
PLANNING ASSOCIATION REALLY
APPRECIATE ALL THE AMENDMENTS
HAVE BEEN TAKEN WERE DOWN TO
JUST A FEW -- I JUST WANT TO
CLARIFY WITH WITH THE
COMPENSATORYDAMAGES GOING TO BE
TAKEN OUT THE COMMITTEE OKAY.
THIS WILL MAKE SURE THAT SO
WE'RE REALLY DOWN TO ONE MAJOR
ISSUE AND THAT IS DEALING WITH
THE MINISTERIAL PERMITS -- THE
WAY THE LANGUAGES IN THE BILL IT
DOESN'T DIFFERENTIATE BETWEEN
PROJECTS THAT HAVE MINISTERIAL
PERMITS AND ALL MINISTERIAL
PERMITS AND THE WAY THE HA.
IS ACTUALLY STRUCTURED FOR EVERY
PERMIT WE WOULD HAVE -- TO DO
WHAT EXTENSIVE ANALYSIS EVEN
THOUGH IT'S JUST A CHECKLIST SO
WE HAVE SUBMITTED SOME LANGUAGE
WE THINK WE'LL TAKE CARE OF THAT
ISSUE IN CORRAL.
THE PROJECTS THAT HAVE THE
PERMITS THE MINISTER OF PERMITS
AS OPPOSED TO ALL MINISTERIAL
PURPOSE REGARDLESS SO WE'RE
HOPING WE CAN WORK ON THAT OVER
THE TIE THANK YOU I CAN HAVE ONE
PERSON APPROVED PROPOSITION IF
THERE'S WANTED. TO SPEAK.
I'M SORRY WHAT WE ALREADY HAD TO
SHE KIND OF GOT MOVE FARTHER
THAN.
YEAH THERE WERE MORE MEN WITNESS
GO AHEAD.
WELCOME THANK YOU.
I'M GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
HEIDI FELDSTEIN AND I'M HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE STATE WHAT
ALLIANCE.
CALLED THE BETTER WAY FORWARD
HOUSE CALIFORNIA AND ALSO ON
BEHALF OF LIVABLE CALIFORNIA --
I'M HERE TO OBJECT TO THIS BILL
REALLY ON THREE BASIS THE FIRST
ONE IS PROCESS.
THIS BILL PASSED THE SENATE AS A
BILL ON BARBERS AND COSMETOLOGY
IS A LICENSING BILL.
IT WAS GUIDED IN AMENDED BEFORE
THIS ASSEMBLY AND SHOWED UP AS A
HOUSING ACCOUNTABILITY BILL BY
SURPRISE.
THAT IS A PROCESS THAT CANDIDLY
PARTICULARLY ON THE SUBJECT THE
SENSITIVE THAT HAS DIVIDED OUR
STATE.
AND HONESTLY DIVIDED OUR PARTY
AS STRONGLY AS THIS ONE HAS.
REALLY SHOULD NOT BE TOLERATED
BY THIS BODY.
IT IS NOT NECESSARY AT THIS
POINT YOU JUST BACK PAST THREE
THIRTY OUT.
AND THERE IS NO REASON TO KEEP
GOING WITH THESE KINDS OF COTTON
AMEND PROCEDURES.
ON THERE REALLY MISPERCEIVED BY
THE ELECTORATE.
AND I WOULD URGE YOU TO NOT GO
FORWARD ON A PROCESS BASIS ALONG
ALONE THE SECOND REASON IS
SUBSTANCE.
ALTHOUGH THE BILL HAS BEEN
AMENDED AND I REALLY DO
APPRECIATE THE AMENDMENTS THAT
WERE DONE IN THE HOUSING
COMMITTEE.
OM I AM CONCERNED BECAUSE THE
LAST WORD FROM CHAIRMAN CHIU
WITH THE HOUSING COMMITTEE WAS
BE CAREFUL WE MAY USE THE SUMMER
RECESS. TO BRING BACK SOME OF
THE THINGS THAT WE TOOK OUT.
AND THAT WOULD BE COMPLETELY
UNACCEPTABLE BECAUSE ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT WAS TAKEN OUT WAS
THE ONE THAT WOULD PERMIT
MANSIONS.
IT BASICALLY SAID THAT THE
HOUSING ACCOUNTABILITY ACT WOULD
APPLY TO A SINGLE UNIT.
AND THERE SEEMS TO BE A CONSTANT
PUSH FROM SACRAMENTO. TO IMPOSE
THE KIND OF LEGISLATION OF ONE
SIZE FITS ALL THAT WOULD PERMIT
MAKE MANSIONS THAT HAS NOTHING
TO DO WITH HOMELESSNESS.
NOTHING TO DO WITH AFFORDABILITY.
AND IS WAY BEYOND WHAT WE OUGHT
TO BE DOING AGAINST LOCAL
CONTROLS AND SO I WOULD URGE
THIS BODY TO NOT PERMIT.
THIS BILL TO GO FORWARD WHEREIT
COULD BE GUIDED IN AMENDED TO DO
THAT AGAIN.
A THIRD REASON IS NEAT.
YOU DON'T NEED THIS BILL YOU
JUST PASSED OUT SB.
THREE THIRTY YOU JUST PASSED OUT
SB.
THIRTEEN IF ALL THIS BILL IS
DOING.
IS REALLY KEEPING CITIES AND
COUNTIES THE HOUSING
ACCOUNTABILITY ACT WE JUST HEARD
SENATOR SKINNER SAID THAT'S WITH
THREE THIRTY WAS DOING.
IF WHAT THIS IS DOING IS MAKING
EIGHTY USE MORE AFFORDABLE AND
MORE ACCESSIBLE WITH US AT A
LOCAL LEVEL WE JUST HEARD
SENATOR WE CAL SKI SAY.
THAT'S WHAT SB THIRTEEN
INSTANTLY.
AND WE DO KNOW THAT -- ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BLOOM IN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FRIEDMAN.
HAVE BILLS THAT HAVE PASSED OUT
OF COMMITTEES IN THE SENATE WE
DON'T NEED THIS BILL FOR OVER OF
FOR EIGHTY USED AT ALL.
OKAY SO LET'S EXAMINE WHAT'S
LEFT OF THIS BILL WHAT IS IT
DOING.
AND I DON'T MEAN TO BE PARANOID
BUT WITH CUTS IN A MAN'S LAST
YEAR AND GOTTEN A MAN'S THIS
YEAR ONE OF THE THINGS THAT IT'S
ARGUABLY DOING.
IS PROVIDING A VEHICLE FOR YET
ANOTHER GUT AND AMEND IN AUGUST
OR SEPTEMBER.
THE COULD AGAIN SURPRISED
ELECTRIC.
AND I SUBMIT TO THIS COMMITTEE
THAT THAT'S NOT AN APPROPRIATE
THING TO PASS OUT INTO A
PASSWORD.
THE SECOND THING THAT IT IS
DOING IS IT IS PROVIDING.
ARGUMENT AND A LIMITATION ON
BEDROOMS LET'S TALK ABOUT THAT
FOR A MINUTE VERY FEW CITIES AND
COUNTIES.
SAY THAT THEY REGULATE THE
NUMBER OF BEDROOMS.
CERTAINLY NO CITY OR COUNTY SAID
YOU CAN'T HAVE.
FROM FEWER THAN THREE BEDROOMS
THIS ISN'T AN ANTI FAMILY BILL
WHAT MOST CITIES AND COUNTIES
SAVES YOU CAN'T REDUCE A BEDROOM
TO A TEN BY TEN DORM ROOM.
STACK IT WITH BUNK BEDS.
AND THEN RENT OUT BETS AS A CO
HOME SHARING ARRANGEMENT WHICH
REALLY CREATES DENSITY WHAT YOU
HAVE IS YOU HAVE A LOT OF
INDUSTRY THAT'S COMING IN PLACE
IS CALLED UPSTART.
THAT CITIES ARE TRYING TO
LICENSE AND REGULATE BECAUSE ALL
OF A SUDDEN YOU HAVE LEAGUE LIVE
WORK ARRANGEMENTS AND LOW
DENSITY RESIDENTIAL
NEIGHBORHOODS.
WITH THE TRASH COLLECTION IN THE
PARKING IN THE CITY SERVICES
CAN'T KEEP UP WITH IT.
OUR CITIES ARE TRYING TO DO THE
ACT.
WHAT BEDROOMS NUMBER OF BEDROOMS
IS JUST NOT SOMETHING THAT
SHOULD BE REGULATED ONE SIZE
FITS ALL FROM SACRAMENTO?
I URGE YOU OKAY ESPECIALLY ON A
GOTTEN THE MEN WERE A POLICY
COMMITTEE HASN'T HAD A CHANCE TO
REALLY LOOK AT THIS AND EXAMINE
WHAT IT DOES ON A STATEWIDE
BASIS. TO JUST SAY NO FINALLY
THE DEFINITION OF LOWER DENSITY
IS INCREDIBLY FAKE.
IT CREATES NOW WITHOUT THE
COMPENSATORY DAMAGES BECAUSE
IT'S NOT AS BAD.
BUT IT CREATES A REALLY VAGUE
DEFINITION FOR A DEVELOPER TO
COME IN AND ARGUE THAT WHAT YOU
ARE DOING BUY EXTRA WIRES YEAR
REQUIRING COMPLIANCE WITH
SOMETHING COMPOSED AS A LOWER
DENSITY.
AND SO FOR ALL OF THESE REASONS
I WOULD URGE THIS COMMITTEE TO
STOP THIS BILL AS UNNECESSARY
YOU'VE PASSED OUT THREE THIRTY
YOU'VE PASSED OUT.
THIRTEEN PLEASE STOP THIS ONE
HERE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
OTHERS IN OPPOSITION.
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES
APPRECIATE THE COMMITTEE A
MOMENT I WANT TO LINE MY
COMMENTS WITH THE AMERICAN
PLANNING ASSOCIATION.
THANK YOU.
MANAGERS MEMBERS SAID JASON
RILEY CALIFORNIA CITIES WE HAVE
AN IT WAS AWESOME IN A POSITION
OF THE BILL CERTAINLY AGREE WITH
WHAT HE BE APA MENTIONED -- BUT
THE REMOVAL OF THE COMPENSATORY
DAMAGES A BIG DEAL FOR US REALLY
APPRECIATE THE SENATOR DOING
THAT.
TIME WAS CERTAINLY -- REEVALUATE
OUR POSITION THANK YOU THANK YOU.
KIANA VALENTINE ON BEHALF OF THE
URBAN COUNTIES OF CALIFORNIA AT
REITERATE OUR GRATITUDE FOR THE
COMPENSATORY DAMAGES AMENDMENT
AND I WOULD LIKE MY COMMENTS
WITH A P. AS WELL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
DAVID JONES ABOUT CITY SAN
MARCUS WE APPRECIATE THE REMOVAL
OF THE COMPENSATORY DAD DAMAGES
WILL LOOK AT IT AND SEE IF WE
CAN REMOVE OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ENTER ENTRY ON BEHALF OF THE
CITY OF BEVERLY HILLS ECKEL
OTHER THANKS ON THE AMENDMENT
REMOVING THE COMPENSATORY
DAMAGES WE'LL TAKE A LOOK NEVER
LOOK AT THE BILL BUT I'M HERE
TODAY. TO EXPRESS THE CITY'S
OPPOSITION.
GOOD AFTERNOON PETER
PAPADOPOULOS WITH THE MISSION
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT AGENCY IN
SAN FRANCISCO WE APPRECIATE THE
SIGNIFICANT IMPROVEMENTS THROUGH
AMENDMENTS INCLUDING TODAY WHICH
WE SUPPORT WITHIN AN OPPOSE
POSITION WE STILL ARE CONCERNED
ABOUT THE DISCUSSION OF POSSIBLY
BRINGING BACK -- ESPECIALLY SOME
OF OUR MOST CONCERNING ELEMENTS
THAT WE HAVE HEARD SO WE ARE
CONTINUING TO MONITOR THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
ALEX GIVES HERE TODAY AND WE
HAVE THE CITIES OF CUPERTINO
LAFAYETTE AND WALNUT CREEK LIKE
TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
ACCEPTING THE AMENDMENTS AND WE
WLL ONCE AGAIN ALIGN OUR
COMMENTS OF PREVIOUS BECAUSE
WELL.
DAVID CAN TANA WITH L. AIDS
HEALTHCARE FOUNDATION --
CURRENTLY OPPOSE BUT ONCE WE SEE
THE A COMPENSATORY DAMAGE
REMOVAL AND PRINT WE'RE PREPARED
TO REMOVE OPPOSITION THANK THANK
YOU.
RECALL LIVABLE CALIFORNIA AND
CULTURAL ACTION NETWORK STRONGLY
OPPOSE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ARE THERE ANY QUESTIONS OF THE
COMMITTEE.
FOREVER.
HI THANK YOU SO MUCH -- I A YOU
KNOW ONE OF THE THINGS MY MY
CITY DOESN'T ALWAYS DO HOUSING
WELL BUT ONE THING WE DO WELL AS
EIGHTY USE.
AND WE ACTUALLY TRY TO GET
EIGHTY USE AS PART OF A HABITAT
FOR HUMANITY PROJECT.
SO I APPRECIATE THE ADDITION OF
EIGHTY YEARS INTO THIS BILL.
YOU KNOW WHEN I WAS GOING
THROUGH IT I THINK THE CENTER I
HAD SEVERAL CONVERSATIONS.
THE PERCEPTION OF THIS BILL IS
IT.
WHAT?
DOES NOT ALLOW CITIES TO HAVE
ANYMORE DISCRETIONARY PERMITTING
PROCESS AND COULD YOU JUST.
GO ON RECORD ABOUT THAT BECAUSE
I DON'T KNOW WHAT'S CAUSING THAT
YOU CAN I DON'T WHAT KNOW WHAT
PART OF THE LANGUAGE BECAUSE OF
THE CONFUSION BUT IF YOU COULD
JUST.
CLARIFY THAT FOR ON THE RECORD
THAT WOULD BE HELPFUL.
SURE THAT A MICROPHONE BACK --
YET THERE BUT A LOT OF THINGS
SAID ABOUT THIS BILL SOME PEOPLE
WHEN I INTRODUCED TO ANNOUNCED.
THAT I HAD AMENDED SB FIFTY INTO
THE SPELL SO THERE WERE SOME
PEOPLE -- WHO -- DECIDED NOT TO
READ THE BILL OR SOME PEOPLE WHO
ACTUALLY I THINK DELIBERATELY
SPREAD MISINFORMATION TO THE LOT
OF THINGS THAT I'VE BEEN SPREAD
AROUND -- AROUND THIS BILL
UNFORTUNATELY IT'S A PRETTY -- A
DISCREET BILL THAT THAT SOME
VERY SPECIFIC.
THINGS THIS DOES NOT AND
DISCRETIONARY PERMITTING.
THE H. A CURRENTLY EXISTS AND
REQUIRES CITIES TO ABIDE BY
THEIR OWN.
LOCALLY ADOPTED RULES THAT EXIST
RIGHT NOW SO TO TO THE EXTENT
THAT THAT LIMITS DISCRETION.
THAT DISCRETION HAS BEEN LIMITED
SINCE -- NINETEEN EIGHTY TWO
THIS DOES NOT CHANGE THAT -- YOU
I'M FOR EXAMPLE WE HEARD ABOUT
THE THE BAY DEFINITION OF LOWER
DENSITY THAT'S IN A THAT'S THE
DEFINITION IN THE EXISTING
HOUSING ACCOUNTABILITY ACT SO.
IF PEOPLE COMPLAINTS ABOUT THE
EXISTING A TODAY PEOPLE ARE
ENTITLED TO THE COMPLAINTS BUT
THAT'S NOT AN ISSUE -- WITH THIS
BILL -- SO ALL WE'RE DOING IN
THIS BILL IS MAKING
CLARIFICATIONS ABOUT A FEW
THINGS THAT.
ARE INCLUDED IN THE HA WE'RE NOT
CHANGING THE STANDARDS OF THE H.
A..
THE OTHER THING -- IF YOU COULD
ANSWER THIS QUESTION SUMMER IN
IN MY IN MY CITIES NONE OF US
HAVE PERMITTING -- OR ANY
SPECIFICATIONS AROUND NUMBER OF
BEDROOMS THAT'S NOT SOMETHING IN
OUR ZONING -- SO IT'S CONFUSING
I THINK TO SOME PEOPLE IN MY
DISTRICT AND THEY READ IT
BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE THAT COULD
YOU GO INTO WHY YOUR BILL TALK
ABOUT THAT YES -- AND THERE ARE
SOME CITIES THAT I SHOULD DO IN
THEIR ZONING HAVE SAY A MINIMUM
NUMBER OF BEDROOMS FOR EXAMPLE
WANTING MORE FAMILY SIZE HOUSING --
SO THERE THERE ARE SOME CITIES
THAT DO THAT -- BUT WHAT THE IN
THIS BILL IT WOULD YES IF YOU
HAPPEN TO HAVE AS YOU'RE
REQUIRED TO BYE BYE -- BUT WHAT
THE BUILT WITH IT'S DESIGNED TO
GET AT IS THAT SOMETIMES FOR
EXAMPLE.
A PERSON MIGHT BE KNOWN FOR FOR
UNITS -- AND BASED ON THE HI AND
THE MASS ALLOWED BY LOCAL ZONING
WHICH IT SAYS NOT OVERRIDE --
YOU WOULD BE ABLE TO BUILD FOR
UNITS OUTSIDE OF NINE HUNDRED
SQUARE FEET EACH.
WHAT THIS BILL WOULD DISALLOWED
MAYBE EACH OF THEM HAVING TWO
BEDROOMS OR MAYBE THREE SO
COMICAL ABOUT -- WHAT THIS BILL
WOULD DISALLOW THAT THE CITY
CAME BACK AND SAID YOU KNOW WHAT
WE KNOW IS GOING TO FOR FOR
UNITS WE KNOW WE SAID AX HI WE
KNOW WE SAID THIS IS A STEP BACK
REQUIRED?
AND WE KNOW THAT THAT MEANS YOU
CAN DO FOR UNITS AT NINE HUNDRED
SQUARE FEET EACH.
WE'RE GONNA REALLY ONLY ALLOW
YOU FOR UNITS AT THREE HUNDRED
SQUARE FEET EACH.
BECAUSE WE DON'T WANT A FAMILY
LIVING THERE WOULD PREFER TO
HAVE A SINGLE PERSON LIVING
THERE SO THE CITY WOULD HAVE
OVER ROAD AND VIOLATED ITS OWN
RULES.
AND SO UNDER THE BUILDING CODE
WHEN YOU HAVE -- A HOUSING UNIT
OF ACTS FOOT PRINT ABOUT SUMMER
SQUARE FEET.
THE BUILDING CODE WILL DICTATE
HOW MANY WHAT'S THE MAXIMUM
NUMBER OF BEDROOMS THAT YOU CAN.
FIT THEIR CONSISTENT WITH THE
HEALTH AND SAFETY AND AND THE
BUILDING CODE THERE MIGHT BE ONE
BEDROOM OR MIGHT BE. TWO THREE
FOR WHATEVER THE CASE MAY BE.
AND ALL WE'RE SAYING IS WHATEVER
YOU HAVE ZONE FOR WITH HIGH BALK
AND DENSITY -- YOU NEED TO ALLOW
PEOPLE TO PUT BEDROOMS AND
CONSISTENT WITH THE BUILDING
CODE UNDER THAT BOOK PRINT THAT
YOU'VE ESTABLISHED LOCALLY --
AND THAT'S WHAT THIS IS ABOUT.
I DO APPRECIATE THOSE
CLARIFICATIONS BECAUSE WHEN WHEN
YOU READ THROUGH ESPECIALLY THE
MEN AND A BILL THAT TAKES OUT
THE THE THE LEGAL FEES THAT WAS
THAT WAS A NO GO FOR FOR ME AND
I REALLY APPRECIATE THAT.
SO I'LL BE VOTING YESTERDAY AND
YOU KNOW AS LONG AS IT STAYS
THIS WAY I WOULD ENCOURAGE YOU
TO CONSIDER SOME SORT OF A
MOMENT MAKES CLARIFICATIONS FOR
WITH CITIES THAT DON'T HAVE THAT
BEDROOM REQUIREMENT.
I THINK THAT IS VERY CONFUSING
FOR FOR FOLKS WHEN THEY READ IT
SO MAYBE THAT'S SOMETHING YOU
CAN CONSIDER.
AND AS IT STAYS LIKE THIS OFF I
GUESS ON THE FLOOR THANK YOU
WILL GO BACK AND TAKE A LOOK AT
THAT LANGUAGE MAKE SURE IT'S
CLEAR.
SO REMEMBER LACKEY.
YES TO THE CHAIR IF I COULD JUST
ASK A A QUESTION IF I COULD HAVE --
SANDY GEORGE COME BACK AND SPEAK
TO THE ISSUE OF MINISTERIAL
PERMITTING BECAUSE I I FEEL LIKE.
THE GOOD SENATOR SENSE OF THE
HAS MADE THAT CONFUSED ON SURE
NOW WHAT THAT HAS.
TO IT'S A VERY CRITICAL ISSUE
VERY IMPORT PART OF THIS BILL
FOR ME.
YES I HAVE.
YOU VOICE SOME CONCERN ABOUT THE
MINISTERIAL PERMITTING AND IF
YOU COULD JUST EXPAND ON THAT
REAL QUICKLY AND HELP ME
UNDERSTAND BECAUSE OF I'M
GETTING KIND OF CONFLICTING
INFORMATION FROM GOOD CENTER
THERE.
I DON'T THINK YEAH.
I DON'T THINK WE'RE ON A
DIFFERENT PAGE THERE I THINK
IT'S THE WAY THE AMENDMENT WAS
WRITTEN BECAUSE IT WAS SUPPOSED
TO ACTUALLY MAKE SURE THAT THE
PROJECTS THAT ARE SUBJECT THE HA
IF THEY HAVE.
MINISTERIAL PERMITS THAT THOSE
MINISTERIALES PERMITS WOULD BE
SUBJECT TO THE PENALTIES NATURE
A IF THEY WERE VIOLENCE OF FOOD
IF YOU DELAY THEM WE DON'T
APPROVE THEM.
THAT WOULD BE -- A VIOLATION
UNDER THE HA AS IT IS NOW THOUGH
YOU CAN'T SEPARATE BETWEEN
MINISTERIAL PERMITS AND A
PROJECT THAT HAS MISTER REAL
PERMITS.
SO ACTUALLY ADDS EVERY
MINISTERIAL PERMIT ITSELF NO
MATTER WHAT PROJECT INTO THE HA
AND HA REQUIRES ANYTHING THAT
YOU DO -- IMPOSE ON A
DEVELOPMENT PROJECT TO HAVE
EXTENSIVE ANALYSIS AND THOSE
MINISTERIAL OF PERMITS ARE JUST
A A CHECKLIST OF THINGS YOU
CHECK THEM OFF.
AND YOU GET THE PERMIT AT THE
END OF THE PROCESS IT'S NOT
REALLY DISCRETIONARY.
VENTURE BY IF I MAY ADD TO THAT.
AND WHAT WE'VE BEEN WORKING WITH
A P. AND WILL CONTINUE TO WORK
TO MAKE SURE THE BILL IS DOING
WHAT WE INTEND I BELIEVE IT PAYS
DISTINGUISHING.
BETWEEN LET THEM MINISTER A
PERMIT FOR A LIKE FOR A PROJECT
FOR EXAMPLE IN THERE LIKE IN SB
THIRTY FIVE OR SOMETHING LIKE
THAT.
BIRTH IS SORT OF A MORE MINOR
MINISTERIAL PERMIT SO WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH A PA -- TO
TRY TO MAKE SURE TO SEE IF WE
CAN -- OCT CLARIFY THE LANGUAGE
AND JUST CLARIFY TO THAT UNDER
THE HA THERE'S DIFFERENT CIVIL
COLD PROCEDURES FOR MINISTERIAL
DISCRETIONARY PER PERMITS -- AND
ACTIONS AND YOU CAN'T COMBINE
THE TWO JUST BY.
TRYING TO DO THAT SO WE ALSO
WANT TO MAKE SURE THOSE STILL
ARE INTACT IN THEIR SEPARATE SO
THAT ANY OTHER PRISONER
AMENDMENT BUT WHERE THIS WILL
COME INTO PLAY IS IF YOU GOT THE
OF A PROJECT.
THAT IS WITH THE HAS MINISTERIAL
APPROVAL -- AND IF I IF OF LOCAL
GOVERNMENT LET'S SAY IT'S JUST
IN BAD FAITH SAID WE'RE NOT GIVE
ME THE PERMIT EVEN THOUGH YOU'RE
LEGALLY ENTITLED TO IT TO
MINISTERIAL PERMIT FOR THE
PROJECT.
THEN THE HA COULD BE USED TO SAY
WAIT YOU'VE VIOLATED THE RULES.
SO SO WE WILL CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH A PA ON THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
FOR THE QUESTION ARE THERE ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS THE COMMITTEE.
ARE WE NEED A MOTION.
HEY WE HAVE A MOTION BY.
PHONE NUMBER ALMOST SECOND BY
THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER VOEPEL.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE I THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR AND I APPRECIATE
THE DISCUSSION TODAY I I MEAN WE
HEARD ONE OF EMPLOYMENTOPPONENTS OF THIS BILL WILL BOTH
I'M NOT DO ANYTHING AND WILL DO
EVERYTHING UNDER THE SUN.
I THINK IT'S SOMEWHERE IN
BETWEEN.
SOMEWHERE IN BETWEEN -- WE THIS
THIS BILL IS -- IT'S NOT A
BLOCKBUSTER BILL BUT IT IS A
BILL THAT I THINK WILL MAKE THE
PROCESS BETTER FOR PEOPLE WHO
ARE TRYING TO CREATE HOUSING --
AND FOR PEOPLE WHO LIVE IN
HOUSING I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE.
I JUST WANNA THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR WORKING WITH US AND MAKING
SURE YOU DOT ARISE ACROSS THE
TEASE I THINK WE DID THAT AND
I'LL BE SUPPORTING YOUR BILL
TODAY -- SECRETARY TAKE THE ROLE
PLEASE.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
AND RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS AGUIAR-CURRY
AGUIAR-CURRY I LACKEY.
LACKEY AYE BLOOM.
BLOOM I BOERNER HORVATH.
BOERNER HORVATH I RAMOS.
RAMOS SIDE GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I
ROBERT RIVAS VOEPEL.
VOEPEL I THANK YOU COLLEAGUES.
MEASURES OUT.
SEVEN SEVEN ZERO SOME ASSEMBLY.
FOR GENERAL PUBLIC PUBLIC PRESS
[inaudible]
YOU KNOW [inaudible]
YEAH.
SHOWN ON OKAY IF I COULD JUST
HAVE YOUR ATTENTION JUST FOR SEX
BEFORE WE GO OUT FOR THE ON CALL
VOTE -- THIS IS OUR LAST THE
LOCAL GOVERNMENT COMMITTEE FOR
THE YEAR I NEED TO NOT NEED TO I
WANT TO THANK YOU ALL OF THE
PEOPLE THAT HAVE BEEN INVOLVED
TO MAKE SURE WE HAD A SUCCESSFUL
YEAR -- I WANT TO THANK MY LOCAL
GOVERNMENT COMMITTEE.
DEBBIE JIMMY ANGELA DIXIE YOU'D
SELL MY FELLOW YOU FELL THIS IS
OUR LAST BILL STAND UP.
MY LITTLE FELLOW HERE LOOK AT
THAT AND LET'S SEE I ALSO WANT
TO THANK THE SERGEANTS AND ALL
THE STAFF AND MY STAFF THE MADE
THIS REALLY A GOOD YEAR -- FOR
LOCAL GOVERNMENT SO AGAIN THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AND WITH THAT WE
WILL GO AHEAD AND DO ON CALL --
ON HEALTH.
SO WE HAVE ON ITEM NUMBER FOUR
SP ONE EIGHTY NINE MOM MONNING
THE VOTE CURRENT VOTE IS.
FOUR ZERO LACKEY [inaudible]
WHICH ONE ITEM. FOR FOR YES HI
LACKEY AYE BLOOM.
BLOOM AYE RAMOS.
RAMOS SIDE GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ I THE BILLS OUT.
EIGHT ZERO THEY OUT EIGHT ZERO
BUT I HAVE ASSEMBLY MEMBER BLOOM
THAT HAS SOMETHING.
YEAH THANKS FOR BEING A GREAT
CHAIR OF IT'S A TEAM EFFORT HERE
RIGHT THE TEAM EFFORT.
YEAH OKAY.
LET'S JUST LET'S DO ARE OUT ON
WOULD YOU SAY COME ON OR A
LORETTA WE MISSED YOU.
I AM ONE SENATE BILL FIVE BELL.
ROBERT RIVAS.
ITEM TWO SENATE BILL THIRTEEN
WHITE HOUSE KEY LACKEY.
LACKEY AYE BURNER HER VAST.
I TO BE.
TO WHAT CASTING.
RUNNER HER VAST.
GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ I FINAL VOTE ON THAT'S
EIGHT ZERO ITEM NUMBER.
THREE SENATE BILL ONE EIGHTY TWO
JEFF [inaudible]
GONZALEZ I FINAL VOTE ON THAT IS.
SIX ONE I AM NUMBER FOUR WERE IS
OUT ITEM NUMBER FIVE SENATE BILL
TWO ZERO FIVE HERTZBERG LACKEY.
LACKEY AYE BOERNER HORVATH.
BOERNER HORVATH HIGHER GONZALEZ
GONZALEZ I FINAL VOTE ON THAT'S
EIGHT ZERO ITEM SIX SENATE BILL
THREE THIRTY SKINNER BURNER
HARBACH. TO DEAL WITH BURNER HER
VAST NO.
GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I TO THE I
MEAN.
FIVE SIX SEVEN FINAL VOTE IS.
SEVEN ONE ITEM NUMBER SEVEN
SENATE BILL FOUR FOURTEEN COVER
GYRO LACKEY -- NO LACKEY NO
BOERNER HORVATH [inaudible]
BUT BOERNER HORVATH I CAN SALAS
[inaudible]
SALAS AYE.
FINAL VOTE ON THAT IS.
SEVEN ONE I AM A REGISTERED QUE
ITEM.
ITEM NINE SENATE BILL SIX
SEVENTY TWO LACKEY.
LACKEY I GONZALEZ [inaudible]
GONZALEZ I AND CONSENT CALENDAR
GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ I LACKEY LACKEY AYE.
THAT'S OUT.
EIGHT ZERO AGAIN WOULD YOU LIKE.
ITEM ONE SENATE BILL FIVE BELL
ROBERT RIVAS [inaudible]
ROBERT RIVAS SIGH.
FINAL VOTE ON THAT IS.
SIX ZERO ITEM NUMBER.
EIGHT SENATE BILL FIVE NINETY
TWO WIENER.
ROBERT RIVAS I FINAL VOTE IS
[inaudible]
EIGHT ZERO THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT --
ADJOURNED AS A FOUR FORTY ON
THIS WONDERFUL WEDNESDAY